ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HEALTH-
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT
PROVIDED CUSTOM ABOUT PUT ABOUT
PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING- ANY ANY WITNESS WHO-
DID NOT MAKE THE REQUESTED
ADVANCED AND ARE NOT ON OUR
WITNESS LIST IT WILL BE WILL BE
LIMITED TO NET TAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY.
NO EXCEPTIONS WILL BE MADE.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AFTER THE
MAIN WITNESS TESTIMONIES GIVEN
WILL BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL
TWENTY MINUTES FOR EACH BILL.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION
HOPE AUTHORS AND STAKEHOLDERS
ARE RESPECTFUL OF THE PROCESS.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMIT
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING WE'RE
REQUIRING MASS TO BE WORN BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT OUR VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE FOR IF
YOU'RE TESTIFYING HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS UPSTAIRS. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. TODAY'S AGENDA WILL
BE TAKEN UP IN THE ORDER LISTED
ON THE AGENDA THE DAILY FILE
AND WITH THE EXCEPTION THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WILL
PRESENT- IT'S SB FIVE NINETEEN-
FOR SENATOR WINNER WHEN SHE
ARRIVES- FOR WITNESS OF VIDEO
WITNESSES IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE. OF
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED THE NORTH STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM- AND
ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS. FOR
THOSE PEOPLE CALLING IN WE USED
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE TO WHICH ANY WITNESS
CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO.
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IN THE DAILY FILE IN
ON YOUR SCREEN. YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE DO SO WELL BEFORE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON THIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. YOU'RE
CALLING IN. IT'S IMPORTANT YOU
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
MUTE YOUR LIVE STREAM AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO RECEIVE SOUND
IS DISTORTION. IF YOU ARE
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL. YOU WERE
MADE ON A LIFELINE WE NEED TO
MEET YOURSELF INTO YOUR ALLED
ON TO SPEAK. OR HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE. CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILLTRY TO
HELP. WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL WITH INSTRUCTIONS
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. YOU
CAN FIND THE EMAIL FOR THE
COMMITTEE THERE AS WELL. THANK
YOU VERY FOR BEARING WITH US AS
WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE SIR TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL RESPECTIVE
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
WE ALL STILL FACE. IN FAIRNESS
EVERYONE TODAY WOULD BE
ESPECIALLY STRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS WILL BE HEARING UP TO
TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE. AFTER THE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES READ SIDE
TESTIFYING IF THERE ARE ANY. WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONES AND
COMBINE THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. WE WILL LIMITED
EDITION WITNESSES ON ANY BILL
TO TWENTY MINUTES. OF CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY. THE FOLLOWING
THOSE ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. ANY MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A
BILL FROM CONSENT. THE BILLS
ARE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR
ZERO TWO BY- THE SIMPLE A
SENATOR PER HER TADO. ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB THREE TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR PAT. ITEM NUMBER TEN
S. B. SIX EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR
RUBIO. SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN WILL BE TAKEN UP
TODAY AS A TESTIMONY ONLY. NO
BUILT VOTE WILL BE TAKEN ON
THIS BILL. I'M A REPEAT THAT.
SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT WILL BE
TAKEN UP TODAY AS TESTIMONY
ONLY NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN ON
THE BILL. I WITH THAT- WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND- WHEN I WANT TO
TAKE JUST A BRIEF SECOND A AND
THEN WE WILL GET STARTED SO.
WITH THE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SENATOR CABALLERO
FEED LIKE TO BEGIN PRESENTATION.
WITH SB THREE NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT SB THREE NINETY
FIVE- LET ME START OFF BY
SAYING THAT I'M GONNA ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE LISTED ON PAGE THIRTY
THIRTEEN OF THE ANALISIS AND I.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE THANK YOU
MEMBERS AS YOU ALL KNOW A
TERRIBLE EPIDEMIC HAS PLAGUED
OUR YOUTH AND OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND IF LEFT
UNCHECKED WILL CONTINUE TO DO
HARM. TO DO HARM FOR MANY
GENERATIONS TO COME ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES OR VAPE PRODUCTS
CONTAIN HARMFUL COMBINATION OF
NICOTINE FLAVORS AND OTHER
CHEMICAL ADDITIVES ALTHOUGH
THEY ARE CURRENTLY TAXED AS
OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE OTP
THE TAX RATE IS MUCH LOWER THAN
THAT OF TRADITIONAL CIGARETTES
THEREBY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
GROWING DISPARITY BETWEEN THESE
PRODUCTS AND UNDERMINING
EFFORTS TO CURB VAPING THIS
MEASURE SEEKS TO CREATE PARITY
BETWEEN THESE PRODUCTS. VAPING
HAS BECOME INCREASINGLY POPULAR
DESPITE THE HIGH RISK OF
ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES THIS IS
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC AMONG
OUR YOUTH ACCORDING TO THE
CDC'S NATIONAL YOUTH TOBACCO
SURVEY NEARLY 20% OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS REPORTED
CURRENT E. CIGARETTE USE AND
ABOUT 40% REPORTED HEAVY USE OF
E. CIGARETTES. AND IT HAS YOU
KNOW THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF
NICOTINE ADDICTION IS-
PARTICULARLY SEVERE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE LEADING TO A FEELING OF
NERVOUSNESS IRRITABILITY
DEPRESSION AND OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH SIDE EFFECTS. WHAT THE
INITIALLY THE AVAIL OF YOUTH
APPEALING FAVE FLAVORS SUCH AS
GUMMY BEARS AND COTTON CANDY
ALONG WITH HEAVY MARKETING HAS
IN LARGE PART CONTRIBUTED. TO
THAT THIS TREND TOBACCO
RETAILERS ARE MORE PREVALENT IN
THE POOREST MOST MOST
ETHNICALLY DENSE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHICH INCLUDESPOPULATIONS MOST
AT RISK OF INADEQUATE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS AND COVERAGE. THAT
IS WHY I HAVE INTRODUCED SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY FIVE WHICH
PROPOSES CLOSER TAX PARITY
BETWEEN THE SALE OF BAIT AND
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
PROCEEDS OF THE REVENUE
GENERATED GO TOWARDS EXISTING
VOTER APPROVED SOURCES
INCLUDING EARLY CHILDHOOD
SERVICES PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
FUNDING FOR PHYSICIAN STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS FOR
THOSE WORKING IN OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
COMMUNITIES. AND NOW THEY TO
INCLUDE SEISMIC SAFETY FOR OUR
SMALL HOSPITALS WITHOUT IT
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESSES KATE ROBERT WHO'S THE
YOUTH ADVOCATE WITH THE SAN
BENITO YOUTH ASSOCIATION. AND
SHANNON BECAUSE LOVICH WHO IS
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER BEFORE WE DO THAT WE DO
HAVE A COURT WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM AND LIKE OUR SECRETARY
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
HERE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BURKE CARILLO
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE HAVE A
QUORUM VERY WELL THANK YOU I
WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINESTO OUR OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. FOR SB THREE
NINE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO APPETITE. THE CURRENTLY
HAVE SIXTEEN Q. LINE NUMBER TWO
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER TWENTY
DELGADO ON THE HAPPY COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU AND WEBER HANG ON HANG ON
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT SO THAT WOULD BE K.
WILBUR AND SHANNON- BECAUSE
LOVE IT SO- BEFORE WE GET TO
OUR- OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
PLEASE. THEIR LIVES ARE BETTER.
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIR AND OTHER MEMBERS MY NAME
IS KATE WEBER AND I'M THE CHAIR
OF THE STATE AND YOU KNOW YOU
THE POSITION. FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON PASSING LEGISLATION
AND EDUCATING OUR COMMUNITY ON
THE DANGERS OF UNDERAGE TOBACCO
USAGE. SEEING MY FELLOW
STUDENTS VAPING IN SCHOOL
BATHROOMS. AND WALKINGPAST
YOUR POTS ON MY STREET WE'RE
BOTH HUGE WAKE UP CALL YOU JUST
HAVE TO CREATE THE PROBLEM IS.
BOTH MY COMMUNITY AND STATE.
BEIJING IS NOT AN ISSUE AMADOR
COUNTY IT'S A NATIONAL. THAT
EXISTS. AFFECTING THE- YOUNG
USERS ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME LIFELONG TOBACCO USERS
BUT MORE SEVERE ADDICTION
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. AND THEY COULD NOT
GO TO GAIN ADVANTAGE OF THIS
AND USING BASED PRODUCTS TO
TARGET AND HER KIDS AT AN
EARLIER AGE WHEN THEY'RE MOST
VULNERABLE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THEIR PREDATORY TACTICS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL. BIG PRODUCTS
ARE MORE POPULAR AMONGST USE
THAN ANY OTHER AGE GROUP.
PARTICULARLY DUE TO TWENTY
ADVERTISING AND FLAVORS. DO YOU
THINK THE GOVERNMENT HAS ALSO
SKYROCKETED AMID THE PANDEMIC
HIGH LEVELS OF DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND ISOLATION HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO KEEP BASIC.
PRODUCTS ARE ALSO NOW MORE
ACCESSIBLE THAN EVER WITH
ONLINE RETAILING THAT'S WHY SB
THREE NINETY FIVE IS STILL
ESSENTIAL. THE ADDED TAX WOULD
HELP DISCOURAGE YOUNG READERS
AND MAKE A LEFT TURN OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS I THINK THAT THE BILL
MEANWHILE THE PROCEEDS GO TO
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND HEALTH
EDUCATION. THE STATE HAS TO
TAKE STEPS IMMEDIATELY PROTECT
YOU FROM LIKE TIMES OF
SUFFERING AND STRUGGLE. IT'S
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS THAT
COULD HAVE SAVED MY COUSIN FROM
ADDICTION AND BEING KICKED OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL. SB THREE NINETY
FIVE SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA USED
AND WOULD HELP PREVENT THEM
FROM MAKING NEGATIVE CHOICES TO
HAVE PERMANENT CONSEQUENCES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THIS FIGHT
FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THEIR
FUTURES WITH YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE MOVING NOW ONTO
OUR OUR NEXT- PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT. YOUR CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
SHANNON CARP WHICH SHE HER HERS
PRONOUNS AND THAT DOCTOR ADMIN
SIGN. I'M NOT A MEDICAL
PHYSICIAN. I'M A PROGRAM
MANAGER EQUALITY CALIFORNIA THE
NATION'S LARGEST STATE BASED
LGBTQ PORTABLE RIGHT
ORGANIZATION MY RESEARCH
CURRENTLY FOCUSES ON TOBACCO
USE WITHIN THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY I AM HERE TODAY TO
ADDRESS AT THE THREE NINETY
FIVE AND TO SHARE HOW THIS BILL
WILL BENEFIT MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL WILL ADD
AN ADDITIONAL RETAIL TACKED
ONTO ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES MORE
COMMONLY KNOWN AS BASED
PRODUCTS. TOBACCO USE IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE
PREMATURE DEATH AMONG LESBIAN
GAY BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER AND
QUEER FOR LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE. IT
IS ALSO THE LEADING CAUSE OF
PREVENTABLE PREMATURE DEATH FOR
ADULTS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
AROUND THE WORLD. VAPING IS
TOBACCO USE LGBTQ PLUS PEOPLE
RE UP TO FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY
TO USE TOBACCO PRODUCTS AT
THEIR SAYS GENDER ST PIERCE.
THE TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
STUDENT TOBACCO USE SURVEYS
SHOW THAT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
STILL USE TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
GREAT PRODUCT SPECIFICALLY IN A
YEAR WHEN MANY SCHOOLS WERE
CLOSED AND A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
MADE ACCESS TO THE PRODUCT A
BIT MORE DIFFICULT. IN THIS
SURVEY WE SAW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LGBTQ PLUS HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
NEWSDAY PRODUCTS AT HIGHER
RATES THAN THEIR PEERS
PARTICULARLY ARE GENDER
NONCONFORMING CUTTEN GENDER NON
CONFORMING OR NON BINARY
STUDENTS. THESE DATA SHOW THAT
OUR LGBTQ PLUS BUT OUR LGBTQ
PUTS YOUNG PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU DATE PRODUCT
THAT ONE AND A HALF TO THREE
TIMES THE RATE OF THEIR PEERS.
AND IN CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
VALLEY TOBACCO USE RATES ARE
HIGHER THAN OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE WE ARE HOME TO MANY
COMMUNITIES WITH LOWER TOBACCO
CESSATION RATE. WELL CREEK LOW
QUIT RATES AND HIGH USE RATES
MEAN THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
TOBACCO USE PREVENTION WE NEED
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
UPCOMING GENERATIONS TO BECOME
ADDICTED TO NICOTINE. AFTER ALL
THE TOBACCO EXECUTIVES
THEMSELVES TOLD US THAT TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ARE NOTHING MORE THAN
NICOTINE DELIVERY. DEVICES
WHICH WE HAVE THROUGHOUT THE
LIFE OF PROP SIX AND PROP NINE
NINE FUN THAT WE PUT TO REACH
TAXES WORK AGAIN THE TO BE.
RELATED HEALTH DISPARITIES WE
SEE. WITHIN THE LGBT PLUS
COMMUNITY AND THE- CAN TO WHAT
WE BELONG. ADDITIONAL WE HAVE
SEEN THAT INCREASING THE COST
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACTS AS AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF. OF PRODUCT
USE PREVENTION AND DECREASES
DAILY USE AMONG THOSE WHO
CURRENTLY USE TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
INCREASING TOBACCO PRODUCT COST
INCLUDES MINIMUM. I POLICIES
THE RETENTION OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS COUPONS OR THROUGH
RETAIL AXES AS PROPOSED IN SB
THREE NINETY FIVE. THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE REVENUE TO SUPPORT
VITAL PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
AND INITIATIVES TO COMBAT THE
TOBACCO EPIDEMIC WHILE THE SAME
TIME REDUCING THE NUMBER OF NEW
TOBACCO USERS TO ENTER THE
MARKET EACH YEAR HE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA IS THRILLED TO
SUPPORT SB THREE NINE FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WE HAVE A ONE SEE IF-
WE CAN GO TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
IN THE GALLERY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION DOWN. SEE NOW WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND
WE WILL OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND OR ANY
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU MIGHT RIP
REPRESENTS SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY- MADAM OPERATOR. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
HAVE NOT ALREADY QUEUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ACTIVE
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
EIGHTEEN Q. WITHOUT WITH MY
NUMBER TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MIND IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE THE SENSATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE NUMBERS CASTING OFFERED ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORTER SB THREE NINE
FIVE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DIMITRI AT THE
WORD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
BOTH WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS JESSICA
MORAN CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IS THE PART THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN A MEMBER IN
A QUESTIONNAIRE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF IT EIGHT THREE
NINE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- JOHN LEVEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
KRISTEVA KRIEGER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRIBUTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BEFORE WE OPEN LINE TO TWENTY
EIGHT AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PAUL EUROPE WE HAVE THE
SOLANO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
ON SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THAT'S
WHY I SAY I DO HAVE QUITE A
COMMENTED IT'S ONE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
SENATOR CAFIERO OUT- IT DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH ME AND ACCEPTING
OUR AMENDMENTS ON THIS- SHOULD
THE BILL GET OUT COMMITTEE I'D
LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
CONSIDERED AS A CO AUTHOR OF
PEOPLE. GOING TO HAVING- WITH
THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE
THE- THE SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES. MAYES
NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NO BURKE. CARILLO CARILLO AYE
LARA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS. RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON NOW. SIXTY TWO
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL SENATOR-
THAT PAID FOR CLARIFICATION AND
MY ERROR FIRST BILL OF THE DAY
WHAT CAN I SAY- THE MOTION WAS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
THE SECOND I WAS THAT WAS MY
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND TO CLARIFY
THAT IT WAS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS OF
LEVODOPA CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. SENATOR NEWMAN.
I MEAN YOU HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE
US IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
STARTING WITH SB TWO FORTY TWO.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT I DON'T
MIND EARLY BIRD GETS THE WORM
AND- ESTIMATES CHAIR- THAT
AFTERNOON MR IN MEMBERSHIP I AM
HERE BEFORE TODAY SECURE
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO FORTY TWO.
WHICH WILL HELP CALIFORNIA PLAN
FOR FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES- BEFORE I BEGIN I
WANT TO THANK CHRISTINE MONTHLY
ON YOUR STAFF FOR ALL HER HARD
WORK ON THIS MEASURE ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT I'M ACCEPTING. ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH NOW LIMIT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL TO
FUTURE EMERGENCIES WHILE
NARROWING REIMBURSEMENT
EXCLUSIVELY TO PP. YOU'RE ALL
RIGHT NOW MORE THAN FAMILIAR
WITH THE MYRIAD IMPACTS OF
CODED ON PUBLIC HEALTH ACCESS
TO CARE AND FRONTLINE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ONE OF THE MOST
TRACKING FEATURES OF THIS
RECENT. UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS WAS THE IMPACT ON
SMALL TO MEDIUM MEDICAL AND
DENTAL PRACTICES AS A RESULT OF
THE SUDDEN NEED TO DEVELOP AND
DEPLOY NEW PROTOCOLS AND SECURE
PROPRIA. PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT ALLOW FOR SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE CARE WITH THAT AS
CONTEXT IN THE IN THE EVENT OF
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES SB TWO FORTY TWO
WILL IT WILL REQUIRE INSURERS.
TO REIMBURSE PROVIDERS FOR PP
FOR THE DURATION OF A FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH STATE OF
EMERGENCY OR UNTIL A CONTRACT
IS RENEGOTIATED. DURING THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
STRUGGLE TO STAY OPEN NEARLY
HALF OF MEDICAL PRACTICE OWNERS
SURVEYED BY THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. SAID THAT
SPENDING ON PP INCREASE 50% OR
MORE DURING THE PANDEMIC WILL
PEE PEES BECAUSE BECAUSE
INCREASED PATIENT VOLUME AND
REVENUE DECREASED MANY MEDICAL
PRACTICE HAD A CLOSE OFFICES
ARE FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES. A
RECENT CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SURVEY OF THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED PHYSICIANS SHOW
THAT ABOUT HALF OF PRACTICE
HEAD EITHER LAY OFF OR FURLOUGH
PHYSICIANS AND STAFF AND FULLY
11% HAD TO CLOSE THEIR
PRACTICES AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
A SURVEY BY THE PHYSICIANS
FOUNDATION A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ESTIMATED THAT 8% OF ALL
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES NATIONALLY
AROUND SIXTEEN THOUSAND
PRACTICES ACTUALLY CLOSED UNDER
THE ECONOMIC STRESS OF THE
PANDEMIC THESE CLOSURES AND
STAFF REDUCTIONS WHICH
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
SMALL AND MEDIUM SIZED MEDICAL
PRACTICE TOOK PLACE EVEN AS
INSURERS ENJOYED STEADY REVENUE
AND HISTORIC NET PROFITS IN
SOME CASES MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
PROFITS FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND MAY TWENTY TWENTY THAT
APARTMENT MANAGER. ISSUED AN
ALL PLAN LETTER REMINDING
HEALTH PLANS ABOUT THEIR ON
GOING DUTY. TO ENSURE THEY
MAINTAIN ADEQUATE NETWORKS TO
PROVIDE ENROLLEES WITH ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY SERVICES.
IN A TIMELY AND GEOGRAPHICALLY
APPROPRIATE MANNER THE
DEPARTMENT SAID THE LETTER
BECAUSE PROVIDERS. INCLUDING
MEDICAL AND DENTAL CLINICS AND
HOSPITALS REPORTED EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES DUE TO COVER
NINETEEN. S. PATIENTS DELAYED
RECEIVING ALL BUT EMERGENCY AND
URGENT MEDICAL SERVICES. IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THE
DEPARTMENT ISSUED ANOTHER
LETTER INDICATED CONCERN ABOUT
THE STRENGTH OF HEALTH PLAN
NETWORKS. IF PROVIDERS WERE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
REDUCE TO A LACK OF PP. THE
EXPENSE OF ACQUIRING PP OR THE
EXPENSE OF CRYING OTHER COVERT
NINETEEN RELATED SUPPLIES.
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS HAVE
EXPRESSED FEARS THAT. IN THIS
AND FUTURE HEALTH A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES INCREASE
COSTA PP. COMBINED WITH
CONCURRENT DROPS IN PATIENT
VISITS COULD RESULT IN A WAVE
OF CONSOLIDATION. THAT WOULD
INCREASE HEALTHCARE EXPENSES
AND DECREASE PATIENT ACCESS TO
CARE MOST CONCERNING IS THE
POSSIBILITY. THAT IF CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO LOSE SMALLER
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES. IT WILL
FURTHER INTENSIFY THE STRESSES
ON OUR ALREADY OVERBURDENED
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND MAKE ME
IN THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS OF
PATIENTS EVEN HARDER WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
RURAL AND OTHER UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND GROUPS. SB TWO
FORTY TWO WILL ENSURE THAT IN
FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES THE BURDENS CREATED
BY INCREASED UTILIZATION PP. IN
MEDICAL SETTINGS WILL BE FAIRLY
SHARED BETWEEN HEALTH INSURERS
AND THE SMALL TO MEDIUM SIZED
PRACTICES FROM PRACTICE
PROVIDING PATIENT CARE- IN WHAT
WILL SURELY BE AN EQUALLY
CHALLENGING TIME. CONSOLIDATION
HEALTHCARE PRACTICE INCREASES
HEALTH CARE EXPENSES AND
DECREASES PATIENT ACCESS TO
CARE. SB TWO FORTY TWO AIMS TO
PREVENT SUCH SIX SUCH
CONSOLIDATION AND ENSURE THAT
IN FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES- THE VIABILITY OF
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES ARE NOT
THREATENED HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY VIA THE PHONE LINE. IS
DOCTOR ARE YOU ON CHIRLA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION SZCZECIN AND DOCTOR
HANSEN ERIC HANSON WITH CHOICE.
MEDICAL SOCIETY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER WILL OPEN THE PHONE
LINES TO OUR. WITH PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OUR TURN
LEFT THEIR- DR HANSEN AND
CONTENT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY VERY AT
DR GRANT FLAG I OWN A MEDIUM
SIZED PRACTICE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA I HAVE
SEVENTEEN EMPLOYEE PRIOR TO
COLLUDED TO TRY TO THE
PANDEMIC- WE WERE AVERAGING
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PATIENTS PER MONTH. BECAUSE
THAT WE'RE NOW AVERAGING ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY ONE PATIENTS
FROM US IN THE FUTURE TWENTY
TWENTY I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION'S
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBER
DOWN TO. DENTISTRY HAS THE-
SWIFTLY TO BE ABLE TO TREAT
PATIENTS SAFELY DURING THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC CONDITION. BUT
THIS IS ONLY BEEN POSSIBLE DUE
TO SIGNIFICANT INCREASE AND
INCREASE AND TREATMENT COSTS.
FOUR PP INCLUDING GLOVES FACE
MASKS AND NINETY FIVE LEVEL
THREE MATH AND COUNSELING NOW
REQUIRED TO SAFELY TREAT
PATIENTS AND PROTECT MY STAFF
AND MYSELF. MAKE PP MANDATORY
AND MEDICALLY NECESSARY. THE
COST OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT HAS GONE UP
EXPONENTIALLY THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC. AMPLE A BOX OF GLOVES
USED TO THAT WE USE ON A DAILY
BASIS USED TO COST TWELVE
DOLLARS ABOUT. IT WENT FROM
TWELVE DOLLARS TO SIXTY DOLLARS
A BOX DUE TO INCREASED COSTS
DESTRUCTIONS AND THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND INCREASED LEVELS OF
REQUIRED PP AND WELCOME COSTS
HAVE GONE DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY
THEY'RE STILL TWICE THE PRICE.
TWO TO THREE TIMES THE PRICE
THAT WE PAID REDLANDS THE
LARGEST DENTAL PLAN PAPER PP
FOR ABOUT SIX MONTHS AND TWENTY
TWENTY BUT ALL AT THE END IT AS
OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST AND IT
BURIED IN THE AMOUNT THAT WERE
BEING PAID. AND IT DID NOT
COVER THE P. P. EXPENSIVE
HOWEVER THE CURRENT PANDEMIC
AND INCREASED COSTS REMAIN A
HUGE CONCERN FOR PRACTICES AT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
EXTENSION SECOND YEAR WITH NEW
VARIANTS NUMBER CHECK.
SOMEWHERE TO THE EMERGENCE OF
HIV AND AIDS AND EIGHTY CLUB
HAS REQUIRED A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF THE AMOUNT OF P. P.
USING THEM OFFICES TO PROTECT
PATIENT AND DENTAL PROFESSIONAL.
WELL WE BLINDSIDED BY. SHOULD
BE PER FOR THE NEXT. BY ENSURE
PROVIDER ARE STILL. TO PORTAGE
BUT IT'S NOT THE TO INCREASE
THEIR PEOPLE. USAGE EMPLOYEE
NEEDS PRO TO PROTECT PUBLIC. SB
TWO TWO IS MADE TO AND THAT PER
A PACK. AND FOCUS ON DELIVER
HIGH. CARE TO PAY DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES AND ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO ALSO THE BEAR THE
COSTS OF THESE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY EXPENDITURES ON THEIR
OWN. THREE HI SB TWO FORTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS DR HANSEN. YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT I MY NAME IS
DR ERIC CAMPAIGN I'M A FAMILY
MEDICINE DOCTOR EXAMINED YOU
KNOW COUNTY AND THAT BEEN AN
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE FOR LITTLE
OVER TWENTY YEARS AND- WE'VE
SEEN- ASK MY DENTAL COLLEAGUES
SAID THE UNPRECEDENTED.
UTILIZED NATION OF PP SENT THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC AND EARLY
ON- YOU KNOW I HAD SUPPLIES
AVAILABLE FOR SURGICAL
PROCEDURES THAT WE MAY HAVE
AREN'T BILL PATIENT THAT COMES
IN- BUT NOW EVERY PATIENT HAS
TO BE TREATED AS IF WE'RE DOING
A SEARCH COPAYS FOR THEIR ACUTE
THEY'LL- IN ORDER TO PROTECT MY
STAFF- TO PROTECT OTHER
PATIENTS. AND THE LIGHT CAN SO
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE ONSET OF
THE PANDEMIC I ORDERED A LARGE
SUPPLIES OF DEFEAT THAT NEVER
ARRIVED AND MANY OF IT CAME
FROM CHINA BUT NEVER NEVER CAME
BUT ORDERS WERE CANCELED. THE
PRICES THEN WE END UP IN THAT
FIRST THREE MONTH TO THREE
TIMES WHAT WE WOULD NORMALLY
PAY OUT FROM OUR NOR NOR ARE
NORMAL MEDICAL SUPPLY-
PROVIDERS SO IMMEDIATELY THIS
WAS OBVIOUS THAT THIS IS GOING
TO BE A HUGE ISSUE FOR US
INDEPENDENT POSITION THAT. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A SMALLER- MARGIN
TO OPERATE WITHIN SO WHEN WE'RE
SPENDING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO BUY PP TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SUPPLIES FOR OUR STAFF IT WAS A
HUGE FINANCIAL BURDEN OUT. MY
DENTISTRY COLLEAGUE ALSO
POINTED OUT ABOUT THE CHANGE IN
YOU KNOW- PATIENT ACCESS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO SUFFER AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC THAT- HAS BEEN
A HUGE CHALLENGE AND EVEN
UNLIKE THE DENTIST THOUGH IN
PRIMARY CARE I HAVE. YOU KNOW
HOW TO SEE SICK PEOPLE IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU CAN JUST SAY IF YOU
HAD ANYTHING FOR TWO WEEKS WE
WON'T SEE IRAQ I'M SAYING WELL
THE NINETEENTH PICK THE THAT
AND SO WE HAVE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES WITH EVERY VISIT SO
THIS. THIS BILL SB TWO FORTY
TWO WHAT I THINK YOU KNOW HELP.
TO GIVE THAT NEEDED SUPPORT TO
THOSE PEOPLE ARE THE- THAT
TREATING. THERE ARE THE FRONT.
PROVIDE THEM A JOY OF UNDERSEA
CARE YOU KNOW. FOR LIKE HEARING
THEM AND YOU KNOW. BUT SPECIAL
IN MY REGION- YOU KNOW WE
PROVIDE A GOOD PORTION OF THAT
UNDERSERVED ON HEALTHCARE-
COMMUNITY AND SO WE ARE
BASICALLY HURTING THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED IT THE MOST SO WE
CAN'T HAVE. ACCESS TO THE
NEEDED MATERIALS AND OR YOU
KNOW CAN'T AFFORD. SO THANK YOU
TO THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION FOR GETTING OUR
SUPPLIES BECAUSE WE WOULD RUN
OUT PROBABLY ABOUT FOUR MONTHS
INTO THE PANDEMIC SOAKED LIVES-
BILL THOUGH DOES NOT ADDRESS.
THAT SHARED RESPONSIBILITY THAT
I THINK THAT THE HEALTH PLANS
HAVE. WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
CARE OF THE PATIENTS THAT PAY
THEM PREMIUMS AND WE CONTRACT
WITH TO PROVIDE THEM HEALTH.
CARE YOU KNOW IT'S ONLY
REASONABLE TO HAVE THOSE- THOSE
MEDICAL PLANS TO REALLY SUPPORT
US WORD COUNTS AND SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT WE CAN COUNT ON THE
AYE VOTES FROM YOU GUYS AND- I
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THERE ARE
NO. THERE ARE ACTUALLY SAID
THERE IS A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME- PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
WELL OUR MISTER CHAIRED MEMBERS
NICK WILL EITHER THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS. BUT WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL. HORAN'S ON AS IT
WOULD RESULT IN A- VERY BROAD
MANDATE FOR HEALTH PLANS
PROVIDERS FOR OVERHEAD BUSINESS
EXPENSES- OBVIOUSLY THE
PANDEMIC IS POSED UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES TO CALIFORNIA. ON
HEALTH PLANS RESPONDED PRETTY
DECISIVELY WORKED WITH DOCTORS
AND HOSPITALS TO GET THEM THE
EQUIPMENT AND SUPPORT THEY
NEED. DURING THE DIFFICULT
TIMES- AFTER A BRIEF FOLLOWING
CLAIMS WHILE ACTIVE IN NON
URGENT PROCEDURES WERE HALTED.
HEALTH POINT OF REPORTED A
SURGE IN CLAIMS- LARGELY DUE TO
PENT UP DEMAND. AND OBVIOUSLY
GIVEN- YOU KNOW SOME
CONTINUANCE UNCERTAINTY ANY
AFFECT ON HEALTH SPENDING WE DO
OPPOSE MANDATORY REIMBURSEMENTS
TO PAY PROVIDERS. FOR UNDEFINED
BUSINESS EXPENSE- HAVE SAID
THAT- TO HELP WELL BEING OF OUR
AND REALLY OF COURSE ARE HIGHS
FOR. ON IT IN THE SPIRIT OF. WE
HAVE OFFERED AMENDMENTS TO BE
OFFERED THAT WOULD NARROW SB
TWO FORTY TWO AND A WAY TO MAKE
IT MORE REASONABLE AND
EFFECTIVE. AS WELL AS COSTLY TO
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM- BE
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING TAKEN
TODAY ARE ARE ARE A GOOD FAITH
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS MANY OF OUR
CONCERNS. ON AND SO WE DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT- IN
THE OPEN DOOR POLICY THAT WE
HAD WITH THE SENATOR. ON IN THE
GREAT. WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
WITH COMMITTEE AROUND THIS
IMPORTANT- WE SOME VERY GOOD
DISK. ON BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T THE
FINE FINA VERSION THE LANGUAGE
WERE ON TO. REMOVE OPPOSITE TO
THE BILL TODAY- BUT WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN ONCE WE
REVIEWED THE- LANGUAGE- IF
THERE ARE SOME OF. THAT NEED TO
BE IN A FEW YOU KNOW WE HOPE TO
SEND- YOU KNOW WAS OPEN TO THE
DISCUSS MOVING. BUT I THINK
THEY'RE DEFINITELY MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- AND AGAIN
WE WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR IN
THE COMMITTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
LIKE. TO TESTIFY ON THIS BILL
JUST. PLEASE COME UP. SEEING NO
WAY WILL GO TO THE FOR LINES.
FOR OR EXCUSE ME SUPPORT. FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MA'AM OPERATOR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF SB TWO FOUR TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TENANT YOU
WILL START WITH MY NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KNOW AT
BOTTLE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
NOTHING HE NON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. IN
TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT CENTER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ON MY DATE OF THE WONDERLAND IS
OPEN LATE BUT VACATION A THERE
WILL BE CONFUSION ON MY BLOCK
RECALL COMMITTEE. MEETING THAT
THEY ARE. I THINK. BACK TO.
THAT WE ARE NOT SKEWS ME EIGHT
EIGHT ARMY THE ROCK OR SHOULD
BE FORMED CAN YOU HELP US OUT
THERE OPERATE I DON'T KNOW WHO
THAT IS BUT THE I THINK THAT'S
OUR CALL. I I'M A BY THE NECK
LINE MIGHT THIRTY YOU'RE MY IS
OPEN. THANK YOU TURN MEMBER
TEND REP THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
AND THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY TWO
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AS
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF CAPTAIN LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE AMEND.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MY TWO FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBER
THEY DRAW ON THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION SPONSORED
THE BURIAL SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THE- HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE DAVID
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY TWO
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COOL QUERY WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A HUNDRED BELIEVE
ON BEHALF OF LOS AMIGOS A-
EARLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
TWO SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
STEPHANIE WATKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WE TWO PREVIOUSLY HAD
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING
NANOMEDICINE DETACH LABOR MEANS
BEING OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MAC MILLAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN ESPECIALLY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND BEFORE WE OPEN UP LINE TO
SIXTY AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO FOUR TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AT THIS TIME WHY TO
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIND OF
CHECK ON CALLING ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY BREAK CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
INFUSION SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
VERY WELL THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. SO
C. NO COMMENTS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE NO QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE OF. BILL DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN WHEN I THINK DOCTOR
LEE DOCTOR HANSEN THE OTHER
WITNESSES- TO MISTER LOUISE'S
POINT- WE HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE COMING- I'M VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THEY WILL ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS IT'S NOT
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORK WITH
WORKING WITH THEM. AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN THE MOTION IS-
DO PASSED TO AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW BURKE
CORREO. FLORA MCCARTY I'M SORRY
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY THIS AREA
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON. FIVE TO ONE FIVE ONE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
FUTURE CONSIDERATION OF PLEASE
GO AHEAD WITH SB SIX THREE
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FROM DOCTORS AND DENTISTS
NOW TO NURSES A GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE IN MEMBERS- PLEASED TO NOW
PRESENT THIS SB SIX THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH WILL PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY ON STAFFING LEVELS
AND WAIVERS IN HOSPITALS DURING
THE CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY LET ME BEGIN BY FIRST
THANKING COMMITTEE CONSULT LARA
FLYNN FOR WORKING WITH THE
SPONSOR AND MY STAFF ON THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS NEAR THE BILL TO
COVER STATEWIDE HEALTH RELATED
EMERGENCIES ONLY AS WELL AS
MAKING A NUMBER OF OTHER
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. CONTAINED IN THE
MEASURE I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL
OF THE SUGGESTED CHANGES AS
DESCRIBED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AS WE ALL HAVE
WITNESSED A VIVIDLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC STAFFING IS PERHAPS
THE MOST CRUCIAL PART OF A
HOSPITAL'S OPERATION STAFFING
DETERMINES WHETHER AN EMERGENCY
CAN KEEP ACCEPTING AN EMERGENCY
ROOM CAN KEEP ACCEPTING
PATIENTS HOW MANY SURGERIES CAN
BE PERFORMED AT ONCE AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
QUALITY OF THE CARE THAT
PATIENTS WILL RECEIVE WITH YOUR
MEMBERS TAKEN TODAY SB SIX
THIRTY SEVEN DOES TWO THINGS.
FIRST IT REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO
REPORT NURSE STAFFING DATA AND
STUFF COVERT TESTING DATA TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ON A WEEKLY BASIS DURING
A STATEWIDE HEALTH RELATED
EMERGENCY AND ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AT ALL OTHER TIMES AND
SECOND IT DIRECTS HOSPITALS TO
PROBABLY POST NOTICES OF
EMERGENCY HEALTH AND SAFETY
WAIVERS INCLUDING NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIO WAIVERS DIRECTLY
ADJACENT TO THEIR LICENSE IN ON
THEIR FACILITY WEBSITE UNDER
THE TERMS OF THE BILL THE
COVERT SPECIFIC REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL SUNSET EITHER
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OR THE
END OF THE DECLARED EMERGENCY
WHICHEVER. COMES FIRST
UNFORTUNATELY AS THE RECENT
NEWS ABOUT PLATEAUING
VACCINATIONS IN THE RISE OF NEW
DELTA VARIANT SO ALARMINGLY
ATTEST WE ARE NOT YET ANYWHERE
NEAR BEING CLEAR OF THE CURRENT
CRISIS NURSES AND OTHER
FRONTLINE HOSPITAL STAFF REMAIN
AT HIGH RISK OF EXPOSURE AND
WILL REMAIN SO FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE SO WHAT IT
IS AS IMPORTANT AS EVER FOR
HOSPITALS TO BE TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF COVERT
CASES AMONG THEIR STAFFS HAVING
SAID THAT WE CAN BE THANKFUL
THAT HAAS AS ARE NO LONGER EXT.
THE ON PRESS. SO THAT WE SAW
EARLIER IN THE PANDEMIC. AS A
CONSEQUENCE THE EXPEDITED
WAIVERS OF NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS THAT WERE GRANTED
HOSPITALS AT THAT TIME. HAVE
SINCE ENDED BUT STAFFING ISSUES
NEVERTHELESS REMAIN A SERIOUS
CONCERN THE DATA REPORTING THIS
BILL. WILL ENSURE NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS REMAIN
MANAGEABLE FOR THE SAFETY AND
WELFARE OF PATIENTS. NURSES AND
OTHER CRITICAL STAFF. AND THE
POSTING OF WAIVERS WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
AS WELL AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS AT
LARGE. WILL HAVE READY ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT THE
HOSPITALS IN WHICH THEY ARE
WORKING. OR ARE SEEKING CARE
WITH ME VIRTUALLY TODAY TO
TESTIFY ANSWER QUESTIONS. MISS
TAYLOR JACKSON LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION THE BILL'S SPONSOR-
AND ALSO- MITCH STEIGER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
NEWMAN- MEDITECH MADAM- MEMORY
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THE
LETTER OPENER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI YEAH MISTER KAREN MEMBERS-
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
PROUD BUNKERS OF SB SIX THREE
SEVEN I'D LIKE TO ALSO THANK
THE CHAIR TO MAKE SOUTH FOR
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH
US ON THIS BILL DURING THE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION AS
SENATOR NEWMAN SAID HE AND HE
WAS VERY CONCERNED WHEN
HOSPITALS CREATED ARTIFICIAL
NURSE SHORTAGES IN ORDER TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TEMPORARY WAIVERS.
OF CALIFORNIANS NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIO TAPPING ON THE
DEFINITION OF A FORM HOSPITALS
WERE ALLOWED TO ASSIGN NURSES
AND ALL UNITS INCLUDING THE ICY
YOU MORE PATIENTS AND STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN TO BE SAFE. AS A
RESULT HOSPITAL'S PROFITED
WHILE NURSES WATCH THEIR
PATIENTS SUFFER AND THEIR
COLLEAGUES DIE BECAUSE OF
DECISIONS THAT LEFT NURSES
UNDERSTAFFED OVERBURDENED AND
UNABLE TO GIVE THEIR PATIENTS
THE ADEQUATE TIME AND CARE THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED. HOWEVER
EVEN BEFORE THE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION HOSPITALS WERE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY APPROVAL BY CDPH TO
GET AROUND COMPLYING WITH A
STAFFING MINIMUM MOVING FORWARD
IT WILL BE IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THE REPORTING RULES UNDER AT
THE SIXTY SEVEN IN PLACE TO
SAFEGUARD PATIENT CARE THROUGH
THE PROVISION OF PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE AN ACCURATE.
INFORMATION WE CANNOT FIGURE
OUT THE FRONT LINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART OF ANY HOSPITAL NURSES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THOUGH ON THIS NARROW REPORTING
AND TRANSPARENCY BILL I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. GET UP
CARE WOULD AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER MARRIED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
FILLING IN FOR THE LAST YEAR.
AND THE SPEAKER. WE SUPPORT IT
SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
PROTECT HEALTHCARE WORKERS BY
ESTABLISHING CRITICAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THREE Q. CARE
HOSPITALS DURING STATES OF
EMERGENCY. IN RESPONSE
UNPRECEDENTED DEMAND FOR
EMERGENCY HEALTH CARE SERVICES
DURING THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
HAS PERMITTED HOSPITAL TO APPLY
FOR WAIVERS TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING STATUTORY NURSE TO
PATIENT STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
THE ISSUANCE OF WAIVER IT HAS
RESULTED IN INCREASES THE
WORKLOAD ALREADY OVERBURDENED
NURSES. CONSIDERING THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR PATIENT AND
WORKPLACE SAFETY HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS. TO ALL
RELEVANT INFORMATION ON
STAFFING LEVELS IN THE
HOSPITALS AND WE SHARE WORKING
OR SEEKING CARE. EVEN PRE
PANDEMIC AND CREE WAIVERS SOME
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN FLAGRANTLY
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LIMITS SET BY STATE LAW. LAST
MONTH SENATOR CORTESE AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS CAMERA AND WE-
AUTHORED A JOINT LETTER CALLING
ON GOOD SAMARITAN HOSPITAL IN
THE BAY AREA INSISTING THAT THE
HOSPITAL JEFF THE PERSISTENT
STAFFING ISSUES THAT WERE
FLICKING THE HOSPITAL PRE
PANDEMIC. ACTORS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ROAD UP ITS MERIT AND
FOR BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE.
WITH MANDATORY NURSE TO PATIENT
STAFFING RATIOS FIVE SEPARATE
TIMES. BETWEEN AUGUST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN SEPTEMBER
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. NURSING
STAFFING RATIOS WERE SET BY
STATE LAW BECAUSE OF THE
RECOGNITION THAT WITHOUT THE
APPROPRIATE STAFFING LEVELS IT
CAUSES A REAL DANGER TO
PATIENTS AND HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
THE DATA THAT HOSPITAL PROVIDES
THE CDPH UNDER SB SIX THIRTY
SEVEN WILL ENSURE THE NURSES
HAVE THE RESOURCES. AND
APPROPRIATE STAFFING TO CARE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND STATE
HOSPITAL ENVIRONMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WILL
HELP SAFEGUARD THE PROGRESS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE. TOWARD
IMPROVING HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS. CALIFORNIA'S
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIO LOTS
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO RESELL AND
BETTER PATIENT OUTCOMES. IN
STATES WITHOUT FACE BACKING OF
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE GO AHEAD
PART. GLAZER AND KIANI BURCHELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL SB
NATION. ABOUT THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HOSPITAL PARTNERED
WITH LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS. TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS WITH COPD AT
NINETEEN INCLUDING RECORDING
KEY DATA INFORMATION AIMED AT
COORDINATING AND IMPROVING OUR
COLLECTIVE RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC. SB SIX THREE SEVEN
POSTED NEW DATA REQUIREMENTS ON
HOSPITALS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
COLLECTED WERE NEEDED DURING
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THESE ARE OF ANY PLAYOFF FOR
LOW OR REPEATED CANCELED
SHIPPED. WITH THE AMENDMENT
BEING TAKEN TO SAYING COMMITTEE
ON F. B. SIX THREE SEVEN
HOSPITALS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
RECORD EVEN MORE INFORMATION
RELATED TO CANCEL CHIP. UNIT
INFORMATION. AND REASONS FOR
THE CANCELLATION. STAFFING A
DIE CARE WHICH MAKES TRACK
REPEAT CAN SHE IMMENSELY CHAO
TASK WE QUESTION WHAT VALUE IF
ANY THIS INFORMATION PROVIDES
IN OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE. THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HAD PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO SB
SIX THREE SEVEN TO LIMIT THIS
NEW REPORTING TO OCCUR ONLY
DURING STATEWIDE HEALTH RELATED
EMERGENCY. HOWEVER THE BILL
CONTINUES TO REQUIRE REPORTING
OF THE STAFFING DECISIONS EVEN
WHEN THERE IS NOT AN EMERGENCY
SO WE REGRET GRADUALLY MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED. GIVEN LIMITED
UTILITY TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THE PUBLIC AND INFORMATION ON
SHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN CANCELED
C. H. A. HAS SUGGESTED FOCUSING
THE NEW DATA COLLECTION OF
LAYOFFS AND FURLOUGHS. WHICH
MAY BE MORE RELEVANT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WORKFORCE
CAPACITY OF A HOSPITAL CAN SHIP
CAN CHANGE DAILY. THE VALUE OF
ANY OF THIS INFORMATION IS
QUESTIONABLE AT THE BILL
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THE DATA REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL WOULD NOT LIKELY A
FIFTY P. H. IN DETERMINING. THE
PREFILTER PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEING MET. C.
H. A. HAD REQUESTED THAT THE
BILL BE AMENDED TO SUNSET ALL
OF THE BILL'S REPORTING
PROVISIONS ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. CURRENTLY
SOME PROVISIONS SUNSET ON THAT
DATE AN TIME ARE PERMANENT
CHANGES TO STATE LAW. ONE
CONSISTENT CONCEPT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO REASSESS THE SCOPE THAT
NINETEEN RELATED LEGISLATION
ALL AT ONCE. THAT REVIEW WOULD
TAKE PLACE IN THREE YEARS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WHEN WE WILL
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
GATHER. FOR THESE REASONS C. H.
A. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE TODAY ON SB SIX THREE
SEVEN. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN KEY
ONLY BURCHILL IS ON THE LINE
SHE'S ON THE LINE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU- ANY WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINESFOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE SO WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR SB
SIX THREE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WELL THAT WAS MY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN I'M CALLING BEHALF OF
MEMORIAL CARE WE ARE HAD TAKEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND BEFORE WE OPEN NINE
TO EIGHTY AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX THREE
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE TWO EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK EIGHTY IF YOUR MIND
IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR
YOU. AND WITH NO RESPONSE WILL
HOLD THE LINE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE ON SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
VERY WELL THANK YOU BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. DR
AT. WESTERN IS AREA. OKAY
DOCTORS DOCTORS AREA TODAY HAS
A. THANK YOU DR WOULD YOU FOR
THAT'S ABOUT THE PROMOTION-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD SENATOR AYE- I'D
LIKE TO SAY THAT I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK ANY TIME
WE COLLECT DATA IT HELPS US
IMPROVE OUR OUTCOMES- AND I
THINK IN MANY OCCASIONS- WHEN
YOU COLLECT DATA IT CREATES
QUITE A BIT OF PAPER WORK AND-
SEEMS TO BE ONLY FITTING. THAT
WE CONTINUE COLLECTING THAT
INFORMATION. SO MY QUICK
QUESTION FOR THIS IS. WE JUST
WENT THROUGH A PANDEMIC A
YEARLONG PANDEMIC STILL IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT WE'RE STILL HAVING
SEARCHES IN CERTAIN PLACES. THE
DATA COLLECTED IN THIS TIME
PERIOD OF ABOUT THE LAST YEAR
AND FOUR MONTHS. WOULDN'T THAT
IN ITSELF. HELP US PROVIDE US
THE GUIDANCE THAT WE NEED
RATHER THAN ANOTHER BILL THAT
FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
ALLOWS US TO COLLECT DATA. AND
SHOULD THE QUESTION DOCTOR
MISSOURIAN- I THINK HE
CORRECTED THE CORRECT AND
THOUGHT CORRECTED IT BUT I
THINK IF- I LET ME SEE LET ME
DO YOU KNOW THIS IS ALWAYS A
DYNAMIC SITUATION YOUR POINT
THE PANDEMIC'S NOT YET. OVER
LET ME LET MS JACKSON FROM SEEN
A REPLY TO THAT PLEASE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD MR JACKSON. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND THINK YOU A
FAMILY MEMBER THAT THEY ARE AND
FOR THAT QUESTION- YEAH SOME OF
THE COMPONENTS OF F. B. SIX
THREE SEVEN WORK BEING- ACT TO
AND RECEIVED BY AT THE DPA- BUT
THERE HAVE BEENISSUES NUMBER
ONE WITHOUT INFORMATION BEING
POSTED PUBLICLY INSURED
REGULARLY SO THAT YOU KNOW YOUR
OFFICE ANY OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS LAW. CAN GET ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION AS WELL AS
GOING FORWARD STAFFING IS
STADIUM BACKSTOPPING CHANGES
REGULARLY SO WE WILL CONTINUE
TO NEED TO RECEIVE THIS DATA
I'M PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CANCELLATION OF CHEFS-
ALL THOSE PIECES- THAT ARE LAID
OUT IN THE BILL- BECAUSE THOSE
THINGS ARE ARE CHANGING AND
ONGOING AND IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND-
AND THAT IS NOT GOOD ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION AND IT WILL REALLY
HELP THE DEPARTMENT AS WELL.
ONE IMPORTANT THING- NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS ANTHONY STAFFING
THAT THEY HAVE THE WHOLE DATA
SET THEY CAN GO BACK AND LOOK
AT RATHER THAN YOU KNOW OKAY
THIS PIECEMEAL WHATEVER
INFORMATION THEY MAY BE GETTING
FROM OTHER PLACES OKAY LET ME
LET ME THINK MOMENT THAT. MISS
JACKSON LET ME INTERRUPT YOU
FOR A MINUTE LET ME THAT I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT
HAS IT WARRANTS MERIT AND I
THINK. IT IT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT
TO COLLECT DATA. BUT I ALSO DO
TO MAKE A POINT THAT. WE DO
WENT THROUGH A- SOCIAL IT WAS
AN EXPERIMENT IT WAS REALITY.
AND WE JUST. WEWERE IN A
POSITION WHERE WE COLLECTED
REAL TIME DATA. BASED ON THAT
COULD YOU TELL US WHAT THEY
NEED FOR THIS BILL WOULD BE
BECAUSE FROM THIS POINT FORWARD
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
COLLECTING DATA THAT'S
WONDERFUL. AND WE NEED THAT BUT
WHEN WE JUST WENT THROUGH A
REAL TIME CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE
HAD A YEAR AND FOUR MONTHS TO
COLLECT DATA WHAT IS DATA DATA
SUGGESTING TO US. I'D SAY FOR
THE IN A WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FROM THAT IS THAT THERE ARE
SOME HOSPITALS THAT WERE NOT-
IN A SITUATION OF A STAFFING
SHORTAGE. BUT WERE ATTEMPTING
TO PREVENT THE CDPH FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT THERE WAS A
STAFFING SHORTAGE OF SOME KIND
AND WE FOUND THAT OUT BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW HOSPITALS RETURNING TO
THE FACILITY. AND TURNING I'M
SORRY TO THE STATE AND SAYINGYOU KNOW HEY WE DON'T HAVE AN
ACCOUNT WITH THEM ONE IT'S
COMING BACK FROM THE GROUND IN
THE ACTUAL REPORTING IS THERE'S
MAFFIA POLICE HAVE STAFF NURSES
THAT NORMALLY WORKS. THREE FOUR
FIVE IF THE WEEK ARE ALL OF A
SUDDEN ONLY WORKING ONE SHIFT A
WEEK SO THAT PROBABILITY
ACTUALLY. IN A STAFFING CRISIS
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE GIVEN THE
FREEDOM TO NOT FALL OWNER
SUFFICIENT REFILLS WHICH OFTEN
PUTS THE PATIENT IN DANGER OR
IS THAT FACILITY MANUFACTURING
IT. SO THAT HAS SPENT SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT INFORMATION
WITH YOU THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC- IF THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION. IT'S A BIT MORE
SPECULATION THAN IT WAS BASED
ON DATA SO I WOULD HAVE HOPE
THAT THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
NUMBERS PROVIDED- BUT BUT
THAT'S FINE BECAUSE- I DO ALSO
SEE THE MERIT AND COLLECTING
THIS INFORMATION MOVING FORWARD
SO I DO. I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY AND I- I DO
HOPE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO. BET
GETTER ANSWERS FROM HOSPITALS-
BECAUSE THEIR SERVICES ARE
CRITICALLY ON THE LINE AS WELL
IF THEY CAN'T PRODUCE NUMBERS
TO TELL US WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED WHAT THE PICTURE WAS.
OF I DON'T KNOW C. H. A. WOULD
WANT TO COMMENT ON THIS BUT I'D
BE VERY INTERESTED TO KNOW. OF
WHAT SOME OF THE OUTCOMES OF
THE DATA WAS THAT THEY
COLLECTED DURING THIS PERIOD
WITH THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. VERY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'M SEEING NONE SENATOR NEWMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND- A DO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS. I THANK
YOU MR AYE DEE AYE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIVEAU TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. THE
ROLL. WOOD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BIGELOW NO
BURKE CARILLO CARILLO III FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
RIVAS RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON NO. FIVE TWO TO FIVE TO
LEAVE YOUR BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU- ACTUALLY I WILL HAVE THIS
OF SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
IS GOING TO GO AHEAD AS AS PER
OUR PREVIOUS RRANGEMENT TO
PRESENT- SB FIVE NINETEEN FOR
SENATOR WIENER. OKAY THANK.
WELL SHE'S GATHERED PAPERS WILL
HAVE MAYBE A MADMAN SECRETARY
IS THERE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SECOND OF FOR
A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW A
SECOND BY. MISS WILL MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH INCLUDES
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB FOUR ZERO
TWO. I DON'T NUMBER SIX SB
THREE TWENTY SIX. AND ITEM
NUMBER TEN S. B. SIX EIGHTY TWO.
WOOD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
BURKE CORREO. CARILLO AYE FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVAS AYE
RODRIGUEZ VEGAS ICE SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON I. EIGHT ZERO
ZERO THE CONSENT COUNTERS OUT
THANK YOU- THIS POINT WHERE YOU
READY MIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR SCOTT WIENER
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
ALL OF THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT INCORPORATE THE
FOLLOWING SAFEGUARDS INTO THIS
BILL. ELIMINATE SOCIAL SHARING
FROM THE BILL INTRODUCED
POSITION LIMITS AND LASTLY
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO DEVELOP HARM
REDUCTION EDUCATION AROUND THE
USE AROUND USED FOR THE PUBLIC
ESPECIALLY YOUTH AS WELL AS
DEVELOP FIRST RESPONDER
TRAINING. SENATOR WIENER WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND HS GRATITUDE TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR COLLABORATION ON THE
BILL AND CRAFTING AMENDMENTS
THAT IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
EDUCATION AND REDUCE USE
RELATED HARMS SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETEEN DECRIMINALIZE THE
POSSESSION AND PERSONAL USE. OF
PSILOCYBIN PSILOCIN MDMA LSD
DMT AND MESCALINE AND I WILL
GAME FOR PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
YEARS AND OLDER. THIS IS NOT A
FULL LEGALIZATION BILL. IT
DOESN'T LEGALIZE THE SALE OF
PSYCHEDELICS. IT DOESN'T
LEGALIZE THE SALE DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE OR SHARING OR
GIVING OF PSYCHEDELICS TO
ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE. ALL OF THAT WILL STILL
REMAIN ILLEGAL. INSTEAD SB FIVE
NINETEEN NARROWLY REMOVE SOME
MISDEMEANOR PENALTIES FOR
POSSESSION FOR POSSESSING
PSYCHEDELICS FOR PERSONAL USE.
ARE RACIST AND FAILED WAR ON
DRUGS ON A MORE ON DRUG POLICY
APPROACH HAS DONE NOTHING TO
MAKE US SAFER. BUT IT'S LED TO
MASSIVE PUBLIC EXPENDITURES
TORN COMMUNITIES DEEPLY
IMPACTED BROWN AND BLACK
COMMUNITIES AND DID NOTHING TO
MAKE DRUG USE SAFER OR REDUCE
OVERDOSES. INDEED THE OPPOSITE
IS TRUE. THE WAR ON DRUGS MAKES
OUR COMMUNITIES LESS SAFE AND
MAKE STRESS DRUG USE LESS SAFE
IT'S TIME WE STOP THIS FAILED
MASS INCARCERATION STRATEGY IN
A KNOWLEDGE THAT NOT ALL
SUBSTANCES ARE HARMFUL OR
DANGEROUS IN FACT QUITE THE
OPPOSITE HAS BEEN FOUND. OF
PSYCHEDELICS. THE PSYCHEDELIC
SUBSTANCES SUBSTANCES INCLUDING
THIS BILL HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
ASSIST WITH THE MERIT OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING ANXIETY
ADDICTION DEPRESSION INSOMNIA.
EATING DISORDERS. AND CRUCIALLY
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
VETERANS AND THOSE WITH
SIMILARLY UNRESOLVED TRAUMAS
HAVE REPORTED A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN SUICIDAL IDEATION AND
PTSD RELATED SYMPTOMS AFTER
EXPERIENCING A PSYCHEDELIC
EXPERIENCE OR PARTICIPATING IN
PSYCHEDELIC ASSISTED THERAPY. A
RESULT THAT MANY WERE UNABLE TO
ACHIEVE HER TYPICAL TREATMENTS.
PEOPLE ADDICTED TO HEROIN AND
OTHER SUBSTANCES HAVE LITERALLY
BEEN ABLE TO END THEIR DICTION
THROUGH PSYCHEDELIC THERAPY.
THESE IMPACTS HAVE BEEN FOUND
BOTH IN A CLINICAL SETTING AND
ANECDOTALLY IN MORE COMMUNITY
BASED SETTINGS IT'S TIME WE
RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF THESE SUBSTANCES.
EVEN OUTSIDE OF A CLINICAL
SETTING. FURTHERMORE THE
DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
PHYSICAL ADDICTION SIMPLY
AREN'T PRESENT WITH CLOSE WITH
CLASSIC COLUSA GINS BECAUSE
THESE SUBSTANCES LIKE LSD. AND
PSILOCYBIN ARE SIMPLY NOT
ADDICTIVE. IN FACT THE
SUBSTANCES ARE OFTEN USED AS AN
ADJECTIVE SUPPRESSANT PEOPLE
WITH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
WELL UTILIZED DOSES OF
PSYCHEDELIC TO HELP EASE THE
WITHDRAWAL OR DECREASE THEIR
DESIRES FOR DRUGS ALTOGETHER.
FOR EXAMPLE EXAMPLE PSILOCYBIN
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE SUBSTANCE EVER
MINISTERS TO THOSE LOOKING TO
QUIT SMOKING TOBACCO. I WILL
GAIN HAS HELPED MANY TREAT
THEIR HER ONE ADDICTION. LAST
NOVEMBER OREGON VOTERS PASSED
TWO BALLOT MEASURES ONE THAT
DECRIMINALIZE THE PERSONAL USE
OF ALL SUBSTANCES. AND ANOTHER
TO AUTHORIZED THE CREATION OF A
PSILOCYBIN ASSISTED THERAPY
PROGRAM OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. OTHER COUNTRIES SUCH AS
PORTUGAL HAVE ALSO SUCCESSFULLY
DECRIMINALIZED THE POSSESSION
AND PERSONAL USE OF ALL
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. WHILE
OPPONENTS TO DECRIMINALIZE.
ARGUE PORTUGAL'S APPROACH WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. DRUG OVERDOSES HIV
RATES HAVE PLUMMETED SINCE THE
POLICY WAS IMPLEMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. ADDITIONALLY
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE HAS INCREASED
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE OR THE
GENERAL POPULATION. IT MAY SEEM
COUNTERINTUITIVE AT FIRST. AND
IT MIGHT SEEM FRIGHTENING TO
LIFT CRIMINAL PENALTIES ON
POSSESSION FOR PERSONAL USE BUT
IT'S TIME CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES
WHERE WE HAVE FAILED. WE KNOW
CRIMINALIZATION DOESN'T WORK TO
PREVENT DRUG USE. IT DOESN'T
PREVENT DRUG USE MISUSE OR
OVERDOSE ALL IT DOES IS PUSH
DRUGS INTO THE SHADOWS AND MAKE
THEM LESS SAFE. IT MAKES
SOCIETY LESS SAFE. SB FIVE
NINETEEN ENTERS THAT PEOPLE CAN
KEEP USING THE SUBSTANCES THAT
ARE PROVIDED THAT THE PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THOSE SUFFERING FROM
DEBILITATING MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION DISORDERS WITHOUT
FEAR OF ARREST. TO PROMOTE
SAFER USE THIS BILL ENSURES
PEOPLE CAN LEGALLY TESTS THESE
SUBSTANCES TO REDUCE RISK OF
CROSS CONTAMINATION. WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
EDUCATION FOR YOUTH WILL ALSO
BE DEVELOPED INTO BETTER
EDUCATION. TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT SAFE FOR
USE. AS WELL AS FIRST RESPONDER
TRAINING AS RECORD AS A
RECOMMENDED MODELS WE CAN ADOPT
TO PROVIDE FOR LEGAL ACCESS TO
THESE SUBSTANCES IN A SAFER AND
CONTROLLED MANNER. SB FIVE
NINETEEN PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN CHANGING
COURSE AND MOVING AWAY FROM OUR
MISCONCEPTIONS AND FEARS
SURROUNDING THE SUBSTANCES AND
FROM OUR SOCIETAL OBSESSION
WITH DICTATING HOW OFTEN OR HOW
OTHERS OTHERS UTILIZE THEM FOR
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IS JUST GOLD PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF THE HER ROLL CARTS
PROJECT AND A CO SPONSOR OF SB
FIVE NINETEEN AND A SMELL ALI
ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE COUNCIL
POLICY ADVOCACY AT THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY ASSOCIATION. FOR
PSYCHEDELIC STUDIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS WICKS- WILL GO
TO EXPECT WILL GO TO OUR-
WITNESS ON THE PHONE FIRST
WHICH IS GOING TO BE JUST COOL-
SO OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR JESKELL. JUST WANTED
TO OPEN. MY NAME IS JESSE GOLD
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF HER OWN
PARTY PROJECT WHICH IS THE
FINAL ONE C. THREE NONPROFIT
AND THE CO SPONSOR CALIFORNIA
BILL SB FIVE ONE NINE I COULD
HAVE NEVER IMAGINED BEING IN
THIS POSITION TODAY ADVOCATING
PERCENT OF MEDICINE BUT I'VE
ALWAYS THOUGHT MY HEART IN
TUITION AND HAS CONSISTENTLY
LED TO ME FEELING ALL EXCEPT-
AND LYFT SERVICE BEFORE THE
MILITARY I WORKED AS AN
INVESTMENT BANKER ON WALL
STREET. I DECIDED TO ENLIST IN
THE ARMY TO GIVE BACK AND SERVE
THIS GREAT COUNTRY BUT I DON'T
COMMUNITY AND PURPOSE AS AN
AIRBORNE RANGER NOT DEVELOPED
AS A LEADER AS A NON
COMMISSIONED OFFICER I MADE A
PLEDGE TO LEAVE NO SOLDIER
BEHIND I FIRST FOUND
PSYCHEDELIC MEDICINE OUT OF
NECESSITY HAVING TRIED ALL THAT
WAS OFFERED TO ME BY THE
MILITARY MEDICINE. I WAS BARELY
HOLDING ON. I TURNED TO SAY. OF
THE LACK EFFORT TO SURVIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT WORKED
AMAZINGLY WELL. PRO CARDS
PROJECT WAS CREATED TO EDUCATE
AND CONNECT MY FELLOW VETERANS
TO BE. ACTIVE OPTIONS. THIS WAS
NEARLY FOUR AND A HALF YEARS
AGO AND SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE VETERAN
SUICIDE EPIDEMIC. NEARLY EVERY
DAY MY TEAM RECEIVING MESSAGES
FROM VETERANS WHO HAVE FALLEN
THROUGH THE CRACKS OF THE
SYSTEM. MORE FROM THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE EXHAUSTED AND
DESPERATE AT THE LACK OF
OPTIONS. IT'S HARD TO PUT INTO
WORDS HOW MUCH THIS CRISIS HAS
DECIMATED THE MILITARY
COMMUNITY. MY COMMUNITY. THE
WAY OF ALL. OF IT ALL HAS
FALLEN ON INDIVIDUALS AND
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS. MANY OF
WHICH ARE AT A BREAKING POINT.
JUST LAST MONTH ANOTHER FRIEND
OF MINE. A VETERAN TOOK HIS OWN
LIFE. HE WAS DOING HIS BEST TO
SAVE OTHERS SIMILAR TO A LOT OF
US. BUT IT CAME. AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH. VETERANS
SHOULD NOT TO FACE THIS ALONE
IN THE SHADOWS. THANK YOU DON'T
HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE SAID
BETTER LIVES AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE VETERANS ALL OR
PURSUING THESE OPTIONS EN MASSE
RIGHT NOW WHETHER GOING TO
OTHER COUNTRIES LIKE MEXICO OR
PERU OR DOING IT UNDER FEAR OF
CRIMINALITY OUTLASTED DITCH
EFFORT TO SAVE THEIR OWN LIVES
AS WELL. THIS IS HAPPENING
CURRENTLY JUST RECENTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH REYES
SECOND OUT CENTRAL IS A
THERAPEUTIC TREATMENT A
SENTIMENT THAT HAS BEEN ECHOED
BY THE FDA AS WELL AS JOHN
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY AND MANY
OTHER PRESTIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS. OF VETERANS ARE
DYING TODAY VETERANS ARE DYING
RIGHT NOW SB FIVE ONE NINE THE
COMPASSIONATE SUPPORT AND
PROVIDES MEASURED HOPE IN A
TIME FRAME OF MONTHS NOT YEARS.
TO THOSE THAT ARE BARELY
HOLDING ON RIGHT NOW. I WOULD
LIKE DATE. EVERYONE HERE FOR
YOUR TIME- FOR YOUR FIGHT GO ON
S. FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
MOVED HER WITNESS- IN PERSON
THE GALLERY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE. I MISS MY LOAD
EITHER A LEE POLICY DIRECTOR
AND COUNSEL FOR THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY ASSOCIATION FOR
PSYCHEDELIC STUDIES OR MAPS
RESEARCH AN EDUCATIONAL
NONPROFIT FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX WITH THE MISSION OF
CREATING MEDICAL LEGAL AND
CULTURAL CONTACTS FOR BENEFIT
FOR PEOPLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
CAREFUL USES OF PSYCHEDELICS. I
WAS BORN TO IMMIGRANT PARENTS
AND FRESNO AND ALTHOUGH THEY
WORK HARD TO GIVE ME THE LIFE
THAT I HAVE I MYSELF HAVE
SUFFERED FROM DEPRESSION
ANXIETY. I HAVE ALSO USED
PRESENTLY ILLICIT SUBSTANCES
FOR THERAPEUTIC SPIRITUAL AND
CELEBRATORY PURPOSES FOR MOST
OF MY LIFE AT TIMES WITH THREE
GENERATIONS OF MY FAMILY. I'VE
ALSO WITNESSED FRIENDS HAVE
CHALLENGING AND SOMETIMES
TRAGIC EXPERIENCES WITH DRUGS.
FROM ADDICTION TO OVERDOSE TO
PSYCHOSIS THE SUICIDE.
CRIMINALISATION DID NOT SOLVE
THOSE RISKS AND OFTEN
EXACERBATED THEM. IN SHORT
PROHIBITION IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER EVIDENCE COLLECTED
OVER THE LAST FIVE DECADES
POINTS TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
CRIMINAL PENALTIES DO NOT DETER
SUBSTANCE USE OR HELP PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS AND INSTEAD INCREASE
TRAUMA AND DESPERATION.
DECRIMINALIZATION WILL EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO SEEK HONEST EDUCATION
THE STIGMATIZE THEIR OWN
BEHAVIOR AND THAT OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND THEM AND FACILITATE WERE
NEEDED THE ABILITY TO SEEK
SUPPORT. FOR DETRIMENTAL
EXPERIENCE OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH SUBSTANCES. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE NOW HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN DRUG POLICY
AWAY FROM PUNITIVE FRAMEWORKS
AND INSTEAD TOWARD HARM
REDUCTION CONCEPTS THAT MEET
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE. BANK
KNOWLEDGE IN GROUP OR
FACILITATED USE AND BY
SPECIFICALLY MAKING SPACE FOR
INTENTIONAL USE THAT IS MADE
SAFER BY THE SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE OF OTHERS. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES HOW PSYCHEDELICS
HAVE BEEN USING TRADITIONS
THROUGHOUT HISTORY AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE MODERN WAYS PEOPLE
USE PSYCHEDELICS TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIVES. I AM ENCOURAGED BY
THE AMENDMENT TO ALLOW THE
COMMISSION ESTABLISHED BY THIS
BILL TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
ON HOW TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES.
FOR CRITICAL SERVICES WHICH
WOULD PREVENT AND REDUCE DRUG
HARMS FROM OCCURRING IN THE
FIRST PLACE LIKE HONEST
EDUCATION ACCESSIBLE HARM
REDUCTION MEASURES AND AN ARMS
CRISIS RESPONSE. THESE
GUARDRAILS ARE CRITICAL TO
RESPONSIBLY TRANSITION AWAY
FROM THE DRUG WAR IN FACT
MATHIS CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF DENVER.
FOR PSILOCYBIN WAS
DECRIMINALIZED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TRAIN ITS FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE CHALLENGING
PSYCHOLOGICAL CRISES ARE NOT
EXASPERATED BY DISPROPORTIONATE
OR INAPPROPRIATE RESPONSES.
MODERN RESEARCH INCLUDING
RESEARCH THAT MAPS A SPONSORED
AND CONDUCTED OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS IS EXPECTED TO
SOON CONFIRMED THE THERAPEUTIC
PROMISE OF THESE SUBSTANCES. AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY THEY'RE
ALREADY BEING USED FOR HEALING
AT GREAT LEGAL RISK BY GROUPS
AND NDIVIDUALS WHO DESERVE
SAFETY WHEN THEY SEEK
ALTERNATIVES. TO CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TREATMENTS. PEOPLE
FROM THE GLOBAL DIASPORA ARE
WORTHY OF KNOWING THEY WILL BE
CRIMINALIZED FOR SEEKING ACCESS
pTO THEIR OWN ANCESTRAL
PRACTICES. AND EVERYONE
DESERVES A POLICY APPROACH FROM
THE GOVERNMENT THAT VALUES
THEIR SAFETY AND WELL BEING
OVER PUNISHMENT. IT'S TIME TO
TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT PLEASE
LET ME KNOW IF I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR PROVIDE ANY
CLARIFICATION WHATSOEVER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE DO HAVE A REGISTER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION JOSEPH
ADAMS WHO'S HERE IN PERSON.
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SO
MY NAME IS JOSEPH WELCOME ADAMS
AND I WAS HERE. TO SPEAK FOR
THE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. BUT HERE I CAME IN
HEREAND SOME AMENDMENTS WERE
ANNOUNCED- I WAS GOING TO COME
HERE AND- I HAD A PROBLEM WITH
THE SOCIAL SHARING ASPECT OF
THIS BILL- I DIDN'T TO HAVING
IT LEGALIZED. SOCIAL SHARING
WITHOUT ANY REGULATIONS BEYOND
THE- PROHIBITION AGAINST
KNOWINGLY SHARING WITH MINORS
WOULD HAVE BEEN. VERY
DANGEROUS- BUT IT'S SOUNDING
LIKE. THEY'RE TAKING OUT THE
SOCIAL SHARING AND SO. NOW I'M
GONNA HAVE TO GO ONCE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FULLY RELEASED
I'M GONNA TO REALLY COME
THROUGH THEM BUT- RIGHT NOW
IT'S LOOKING LIKE I'M ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL NOW. SO
NOW THAT WE GOT RID OF THE
SOCIAL SHARING. AND YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE OR NOT
OPENING A WILD WEST OF.
PSYCHEDELIC GUIDANCE BUSINESSES
WHERE PEOPLE GIVE THE DRUGS FOR
FREE BUT THEN YOU CHARGE FOR
YOUR SERVICES WE'RE NOT DOING
THAT ANYMORE. WE'RE ACTUALLY
JUST. YOU KNOW. JUST FOCUSING
ON POSSESSION AND ACTUALLY JUST
FOCUSING ON THE DRUG WAR ASPECT
SO. I WILL GO AND LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS ONCE THEY'RE UP ON
THE WEBSITE. BUT YEAH CAME HERE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED LOOKS
LIKE IT MIGHT BE SUPPORT NOW SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS- WILL BRING IT BACK
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
FOR- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION WE JUST ASKING FOR
YOUR NAME POSITION. AND ANY
ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT THANK YOU. THAT'S
RIGHT THEY THINK THEY DID A
GENTLEMAN BEFORE WE DO THAT IS
A THING OF THE WITNESSES WHO
CAME IN PERSON HERE IT'S NICE
TO SEE WITNESSES IN PERSON I
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO DO THAT
MUCH- SO- PLEASE- ACTUALLY.
BEFORE YOU GO TO FIND OTHER
OTHERS IN THE GALLERY THAT WANT
US ARE EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
YES IS A GREAT BURKE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DANCING
MAN ON BEHALF OF NEW APPROACH
I'M SEEIN STRONG SUPPORT AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I THINK
STRENGTH IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. OKAY WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES NOW AND AS I
SAID TO NAME POSITION AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE ONLY PLEASE THANK YOU-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN UPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ONE NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE SEVEN Q. WE'LL START WITH
MY NUMBER TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS MICHAEL AND I'M A CITIZEN OF
WEST OF CALIFORNIA. AND I AM
PRO SUPPORT FIVE NINETEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THREE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION- WE HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANY HEARING
TURN FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY I
APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL OF
SOCIAL SHARING BUT REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS CALLER PLEASE THREE
NINETY THANK YOU THIRTY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOSH YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TWO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AND SEVEN MAKE DONALD
ARE BRIGHTER AND SO MAKERS FROM
LA I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FIVE
NINETEEN PERSONALLY FOUND
HEALING FROM. CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ABUSE THANK YOU THANK YOU CAN
THANK NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JAMES MCCARTY CO
FOUNDER OF TO CRIMINALIZE SAN
FRANCISCO THE PSYCHEDELIC SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND THE
OWNER OF THE HEAT STREET TRUMP
SHOP IN SUPPORT OF
DECRIMINALIZATION HOWEVER NOT
IN SUPPORT OF LIMITATION AT
THIS RAW IS LIVE AT THE LAW IS
WRITTEN BECAUSE IT DOES NOT
ADDRESS DISPENSATION FOR THE
EMERGING MARKET THANK YOU ALL
THE JUST IT WAS JUST YOUR NAME
AND POSITION BY. JUST YOUR NAME
AND POSITION PLEASE PLEASE NEXT
CALLER. ONE THREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TELL YOUR ABOUT
US WITH CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DAN GOLDSTINE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTION
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. TWO
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DR AMANDA REISMAN REPRESENTING
THE MENDOCINO COUNTY WOMEN'S
POLITICAL COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GIULIANA MERCER SIXTEEN
YOU'RE A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
AND HER A CARD PROJECT IN
BOSTON- IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES- CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOLD
ON HERE EVERY GLOBAL LIFESTYLE.
HE JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF BELK
DAMAGED. NOT HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH THE PHONE- JOHN LEVEL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTIC OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL-
FOR A VARIETY OF RETURNING WHAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I LOVE MY PHONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN NEXT CALLER. THREE
HUNDRED. ALLEN PRESIDENT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE BASED
COALITION ON BEHALF OF THE
CONGRESS OF RACIAL EQUALITY
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE- Q.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY TWO
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SZCZESNY HANSON I AM THE
AMBASSADOR PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
HER BROKE HEARTS PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS HELEN CHOW I'M A
TEACHER AND A MOM OF TWO- I'M
FROM L. COLE I'M STRONGLY
UPHOLD SB FIVE NINE FIVE ONE
NINE THREE THREE NOTE TO IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TEMPLES AUTO
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. Q. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN ACRE LINE IS
NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU.
HELLO YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JACKIE I'M A MEMBER DEAL COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND PART OF THE
REWARD CARD BUDGET CONDUCTED IT
I AM STRONGLY IN FVOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY KACZYNSKI FROM THE
WILDFLOWER COLLECTIVE AND I AM
IN STRONG. FAVOR OF THE CELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THREE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
STEVEN MOORE FOR THE INDIGENOUS
PEYOTE CONSERVATION INITIATIVE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
POINT NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS CARLOS NINE WITH AMERICANS
AGAINST LEGALIZING MARIJUANA WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THE TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU
PLAY A CHARACTER ON BEHALF OF
HIMSELF IN STRONG FAVOR OF AT
THE FIVE ONE NINE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR SENT HIM A FINE AND I'M
A LICENSED PSYCHOLOGIST WITH
EXPERTISE IN TREATING TRAUMA
AND I SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE NINE
MEDICAL RESEARCH SHOWS THAT. IN
THE RIGHT THERE YOU CAN YOU CAN
BE EFFECTIVE IN TREATING
TREATING DROP YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUDITH DRAIN
REPRESENTING CCP CALIFORNIA
CONCERNED CALIFORNIA PARENTS
REGISTERING A FIRM OPPOSITION
TO THIS ITEM OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS- THE RITA MEYER I'M
A POSTDOCTORAL RESEARCHER AT
UCSF AND ONE OF THE LEADERS OF
THE PSYCHEDELIC AD YOUR CHEN
ECONOMIC COUNTY THAT YOU GET
THAT I STRONGLY SUPPORT AT FIVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS DAVID MILBORNE SHARE
MUSICIAN AND HEALER FOR THE
SAKE OF ALL FUTURE LIFE ON
EARTH I AM STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
SB FIVE ONE NINE THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HELLO
MY NAME IS JEFF AND HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THE STATE NEWS I'M
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
ONE NINE THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE THREE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARIANNA BEEN WATCHING
ME AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. INTO SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KELLY REED
IN STRONG OPPOSITION I'M SORRY
TO BREAK IN ON THIS BUT LAST
TIME I WASN'T ABLE TO GET YOUR
OWN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU. THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BEFORE WE OPEN ONE
THREE SIXTEEN LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE ONE NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO NINE
THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN A
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. EXADATA WHY NUMBER
TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JEANNIE
HALL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. FIVE ONE NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSE OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR YOU. HELLO THIS IS JERRY
KING GRAND RESIDENT OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND LEADER OF THE
AWARE PROJECTS SAN DIEGO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINETY ONE LIKELY STRONGLY WHAT
MAGICALLY COULD RESPECT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WANT TO
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS ALAN STEINER- SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE- ONE. PROJECT
HOUSE STRONGLY OR NAY ABSOLUTE
SECURITY. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. THREE FORTY SEVEN YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. HI I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETEEN
SUPPORTING VETERANS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS LAW ENFORCEMENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
EVERYONE HAS THE RIGHT YOU
THINK YOU HAVE BREAK YOUR
QUESTIONS NOW HOUSE THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY THREE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS DR REGINA MORE AND
LOCAL FOUNDER OF THE SECOND
I'LL PURPOSES DISPOSITION ON
THE SECOND AUG SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION I SUPPORT THE
MEASURE IN DECRIMINALIZATION OF
PSYCHEDELICS BUT DO NOT SUPPORT
POLICY ATTRACTIVE. AMENDMENT
WHICH IS A QUANTITY. ONE THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
FIFTY ONE LINE ABOUT. HELLO
THIS IS KATIE STRANG WITH THE
SAN MARCOS PREVENTION COALITION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THE SPECIAL
ARE WORKING FULL LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON FOR CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND UP WE DO HAVE ONE
MORTGAGE YOU THEY ARE CURRENTLY
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE OKAY.
AND THEY HAVE
REMOVED THEMSELVES FROM ACCUSER
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO ONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. VERY
WELL THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY SOMETHING AND- JUST SO
THE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. SO THE-
SOCIAL SARING HAS HAS HAS
REALLY NOT BEEN REMOVED WE HAVE
READ- RENAMED IT TO BE. THE
CIVITATE OR SUPPORTED USE. AND
WE FURTHER DEFINE WHAT THAT
MEANS AND SO I JUST WANTED
MAKES CHURCH MISTER JOSEPH
OPOKU MADAMS UNDERSTANDS THAT-
I HAD SIGNIFICANT. CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PHRASE THAT THE
TERMINOLOGY THERE AND- AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE
SO AS YOU AS YOU ARE YOUR
POSITION MAY CHANGE NOW THAT
YOU READ AS YOUREAD THE
AMENDMENTS BUT I WANTED HER TO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TO YOU
AND OTHERS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY GREAT
MISTER MASON. WELL I GUESS THIS
IS A QUESTION FOR SOME MEMBER
WICKS AT THIS IS THESE ARE THE
SORTS OF THE TIMES THAT I DON'T
LOVE- THE THIS ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE'RE IN- INSTEAD OF BEING IN
OUR COMMITTEE ROOMS WITH HAVING
EXPERTS HAVING THREE EXPERTS ON
ONE SIDE THREE EXPERTS ON
ANOTHER SIDE- BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE EXPERTS- AND I KNOW THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS IS- IS
STANDING IN BECAUSE THE AUTHOR-
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT TODAY-
BUT I'M STRUGGLING A LITTLE BIT
WITH THIS- BECAUSE AT FIRST
GLANCE- AND SEEING THIS BILL- I
WOULD SAY WILL- NO I'M I'M
ABSOLUTELY- NO- BUT THEN- I
HEARD FROM FOLKS WHO CAME- IN
THE END AND WITH WHOM CALL
FOLKS WHO AND THEIR LIVES HAVE
BEEN CHANGED- BUT BECAUSE OF
BEING ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS AND SOME PROGRAMS. AND SO
I READING THE OPPOSITION
LETTERS MOSTLY FROM A FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT- THERE WAS ONE IN
REGARDS TO LSD. BUT YET I DON'T
HAVE ANYBODY HERE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO A TO
ASK THAT QUESTION OF AND IF TO
FIND OUT WHAT IMPACT IS AND I
GUESS IN LARGE PART OF LOOKING
FOR SORT OF THE THOSE THE GOOD
OUTWEIGH THE BAD AND HOW DO WE
AND HO DO WE GET THERE- WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE GOOD
OUTWEIGHED THE BAD WHAT I DO
KNOW IS- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE DRUGS OVERALL THIS- WHAT
ARE CURRENTLY STATUS QUO. ISN'T
WORKING THAT'S WHY A FEW YEARS
AGO I VOTED FOR- DR EGGMAN'S-
BILL- IN REGARDS TO A PILOT
PROJECT IN- IN THE CITY COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO- AND WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT THIS BEFORE ME NOW
I'M THINKING EITHER DOES THE
POSITIVES OUTWEIGH THE
NEGATIVES BECAUSE IT'S TRUE
THAT THERE IS SOME NEGATIVES
I'M JUST WONDERING IF MAYBE AS
A MEMBER WEEKS IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT. SURE THANK YOU.
PRESERVATION AND YES I'M
FILLING IN FOR- SENATOR WIENER
BUT I WILL TRY MY BEST. I WE
ALSO MIGHT THE- WITNESSES HERE
WHO CAN ALSO SHED SOME LIGHT ON
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS BUT-
YOU KNOW I GET IT RIGHT YOU
LOOK AT THIS BILL YOU THINK. AS
A LEGISLATOR. AM I REALLY GOING
TO DO THIS. YOU KNOW AND TO AND
LEGALIZE SOME OF THE
PSYCHEDELIC DRUGS ON THE FACE
OF IT WHEN YOU SEE IT BUT THEN
WHEN YOU START TALKING TO
PEOPLE. MANY VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AMAZING. YOU KNOW AND
THEY'RE HUNGRY FOR MORE
THERAPEUTIC. RESOURCES THEY'RE
DEALING WITH ANXIETY. AND
DEPRESSION. AND HAVE TRIED MNY
OTHER TYPES. OF MEDICATIONS AND
THERAPEUTIC- RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM CURRENTLY BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS WHAT'S
ACTUALLY WORKING FOR THEM. AND
SO I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THEIR
TESTIMONY IS THE MOST POWERFUL
TESTIMONY. FOR THIS PARTICULAR
BILL- AND I THINK THEY'RE
HUNGRY FOR MORE OF THESE
RESOURCES. ALSO YOU LOOK AT
THESE THE PSYCHEDELICS THESE
ARE NOT ADDICTIVE SUBSTANCES.
YOU KNOW AND SO I THINK YOU DO
HAVE TO WEIGH AT WHICH WE DO
WITH EVERY BILL. DOES THE GOOD
OUTWEIGH THE BAD. AND TO MEET
THE EVIDENCE IS VERY CLEAR IN
THIS CASE OF THIS BILL. THAT
THE GOOD OUTWEIGHS THE BAD. AND
THAT DECRIMINALIZING WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT SMALL AMOUNTS FOR
PERSONAL USE ONLY. IS ONE WAY
THAT I THINK WE CAN NARROWLY
GIVE MORE RESOURCES TO PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT. AND IT DEFINITELY
YOU KNOW THESE TYPES OF
PSYCHEDELICS HELP GET PEOPLE
OFF OF HEAVIER DRUGS AND HARDER
DRUGS DRUGS LIKE HEROIN. WHICH
WE KNOW WILL HAVE A VERY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE BOARD
RURAL URBAN SUBURBAN. AND IF WE
HAVE MORE OF THESE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
WORK TO THAT END I WOULD ALSO
JUST- I DON'T KNOW IF JUST
SCHOOL OR ISMAEL ALI WANTS TO-
HELP ANSWER ANY THOSE THE
QUESTIONS WELL. HAPPY HAPPY TO-
MISIA'S MALES MOVING TO THE TO
THE MICROPHONE IF YOU HAVE.
ANYTHING TO ADD TO JUST JUST IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE PHONE.
PLEASE PLEASE. AFTER AFTER A
SMELL A PLEASEPLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD. AFTERNOON SORRY. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION
I UNDERSTAND THAT SO MUCH OF
PUBLIC POLICY IS WEIGHING THESE
CONSIDERATIONS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION THAT'S
BEEN PAID TO THESE QUESTIONS. I
THINK THE CORE THING TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT A LOT OF
THESE BEHAVIORS ARE ALREADY
OCCURRING A LOT OF THE HARMS
THAT OCCUR FROM PSYCHEDELICS
OCCUR BECAUSE OF AN INTEGRATED
USE OR THESE THINGS THAT ARE
RELATED TO. STIGMA TRAUMA IN
DESPERATION A LOT OF THE SOCIAL
HARMS ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG USE
IN GENERAL AND PSYCHEDELICS IN
PARTICULAR ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
DESPERATION. I THINK FOR PEOPLE
WHETHER THEY'RE VETERANS ARE
OTHERS THE FEAR OF
CRIMINALIZATION AND THE FEAR OF
ARREST IS ONE OF THE MOST
LIKELY DRIVERS FOR PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GOING INWARD INTO
INTERNALIZING THAT STIGMA AND
REFUSING TO. ASK FOR HELP SO
PROBLEMS THAT OCCUR ARE
ACTUALLY EXACERBATED BY THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE FEEL FREE
TO STICK OF CRIMINALIZATION. I
BELIEVE THAT THIS WOULD ALLOW
MORE ROOM FOR THAT- HONEST
EDUCATION TO OCCUR IF THAT FEAR
OF ARREST WERE NOT ON THE TABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
JESSE DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD TO THAT IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE. AND
THAT IS A CHALLENGE WITH OUR
PROCESS BECAUSE. ONCE YOU'RE
GONE YOU'RE GONE SO- OKAY AND
MAYBE IF I CAN'T ANOTHER
ANOTHER QUESTION AND AGAIN THIS
IS PART OF THE- ABA A WITH-
WITH THIS- IN REGARDS TO THE
THAT I'VE HEARD FROM VETERANS-
I'VE GOT THE AND TWENTY PALMS
THEM IN COURT BY A GROUND
COMBAT CENTER- I AM SURROUNDED
BY- SOME OF. THE MARINES- AND-
AND RETIRED- MARINES- AND THOSE
WHO HAVE GONE TO COMBAT I DO
COME BACK WITH- THE TREMENDOUS-
AGONY THAT THE PTSD THAT. THAT
THAT AFFECTS THEM AND WEN YOU
WHEN YOU HEAR FROM THEM- LIKE
LIKE I HAVE LIKE YOU YOU HAD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS- IT DOES
WEIGH ON YOU AND I THINK- ABOUT
ABOUT IT WHY CAN'T WE WHY I
CAN'T WE HAVE A SUPERVISED IN
CALIFORNIA WHY CAN'T WE HAVE.
UNSUPERVISED YOU KNOW FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS- THAT CAN- THEY
CAN SUPERVISE THIS TYPE OF
CLINICAL A WORK WHAT WHAT IS IT
WHAT WE HAVE TO JUST TO
DECRIMINALIZE- THAT THESE.
THESE- THESE SUBSTANCES. QUITE
FRANKLY WE CAN AND WE SHOULD
RAISE I MEAN. BUT THE REALITY
MATTERS WE HAVE PEOPLE DYING
EVERY SINGLE DAY RIGHT NOW. OF
HEROIN OVERDOSES OF SUICIDE. OF
DEPRESSION THAT'S IMPACTING
THEM. AND IF WE CAN
DECRIMINALIZE THIS PIECE OF IT
AND START THAT PROCESS AND
CONTINUE TO WORK ON- MORE
REGULATED SETTINGS. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING- BUT THIS I THINK TAKING
AWAY THE SORT OF
CRIMINALIZATION OF SMALL
AMOUNTS OF POSSESSION I ALSO
THINK WE'LL TAKE THIS OUT OF
THE SHADOWS. AND INTO MORE OF
THE MAINSTREAM AND THEN WE CAN
CONSIDER FURTHER ADDITIONAL-
REGULATORY LISTENING FOR THESE
TYPES OF A- PSYCHEDELICS OKAY
MR JUST WANTED IT ONE LAST
THING IS UP TO- I'M STILL
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS WITH
THIS BILL- BUT I AM GOING TO
DEVOTE TO MOVE IT OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND RETAIN THE RIGHT
TO BE ABLE TO VOTE AGAINST IT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FLOOR I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOME
MORE. QUESTIONS ANSWERED SHE-
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
ALSO RESPONDED THAT REALLY
QUICK SEE MR TIGHTER. CAN I
JUST RESPOND THAT MISTER CHAIR
YEAH. JUST ONE LAST THING I
THINK YOU KNOW. ON BEHALF OF.
SENATOR WIENER AND MYSELF AS
WELL. ALSO BE TO WORK WITH YOU
IF THERE'S MORE LANGUAGE THAT
MAKES YOU MORE COMFORTABLE WHEN
THE BILL REACHES THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. OF THE DEVICE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY
ON THIS AND I APPRECIATE THE
TURMOIL YOU EXPRESSED BECAUSE
THAT'S EXACTLY THE INTERNAL
TURMOIL I HAVE YET I REPRESENT
A RELATIVELY- BLUER DISTRICT
AND I THINK I HAVE CONSTITUENTS
WHO WOULD VERY MUCH WANT TO SEE
ME SUPPORT THIS. BUT FOR ME
THIS IS ALSO BEYOND DEMOCRATIC
OR REPUBLICAN OR ANY PARTISAN
LINE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA AND YOU TRY
TO. BEST COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT MAKES SENSE AND I
GOTTA SAY IT'S- SOMEWHAT
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THERE'S
ALWAYS A LACK OF THE SPECIFIC
DATA YOU'RE TRYING TO LOOK FOR.
YET AT THE SAME TIME A LOT OF
THIS FEAR THAT IS PLACED THAN
US. WHEN YOU. SCRATCH THE
SURFACE AND WHEN YOU LOOK INTO
A DEEPER YOU SEE THAT IT REALLY
ISN'T BASED ON A GREAT DEAL OF
EVIDENCE IT'S ON ITS OWN. JUST
YOU KNOW FIVE YEARS AGO WE KEPT
ON HEARING FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES THAT
YOU KNOW DECRIMINALIZING.
MARIJUANA AND CANNABIS IS GOING
TO BE HORRIBLE FOR US I CAN'T
THINK OF A SINGLE DEPARTMENT OR
AGENCY THAT ACTUALLY WAS IN
FAVOUR. WHAT'S SURPRISING TO ME
IS. WE HAVE A BILL TODAY THAT
SEVERAL DIFFERENT POLICE.
AGENCIES ARE ACTUALLY
SUPPORTING- THE FEAR WITH
MARIJUANA WAS. YUP PART ONE
CRIMES ARE GONNA GO UP THERE'S
GOING TO BE ROBBERY THERE'S
GOING TO BE. MANY DIFFERENT
SMALL SMALLER RELATED THEFTS
AND BURGLARIES AND ROBBERIES IT
ACTUALLY WENT ON THE DECLINE
IT'S ONLY GONE UP RECENTLY IN
THIS LAST YEAR BUT WE KNOW THAT
THAT INCREASE HAS NOTHING TO DO
AS A DIRECT CORRELATION TO THE
LEGALIZATION BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. YOU LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED IN OREGON. EVEN
THOUGH IT JUST PASSED LAST
NOVEMBER. AND IT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED AS OF JANUARY THERE
IS NO. NO CREDIBLE DEDUCTION
THAT THERE'S BEEN ANY INCREASE
IN- ROBBERIES OR ANYTHING
RELATED TO BECAUSE AS A SUBSET
DO TO OTHERS I'M SORRY AS A
SUBSET OF CRIME ACTIVITY DUE
TO. THE LEGALIZATION OF THESE
DRUGS AND AGAIN IT'S ONLY FOR A
PERIOD OF SIX MONTHS SO MAYBE A
LITTLE OVER SIX MONTHS BUT
AGAIN THERE IS NO CREDIBLE DATA
THAT SUGGESTING IT. SO I KIND.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO OVERCOME SOME
OF THE INNER VOICES OF WANTING
TO BE SAFE. AND WANTING TO TAKE
THE SAFE ROUTE IN THIS ISSUE IN
THIS INSTANCE. I NEVER HAD AN
ISSUE SUPPORTING
DECRIMINALIZING CANNABIS
BECAUSE- LET'S FACE IT PEOPLE
WHO USE CANNABIS ARE NEVER
GOING TO WANT TO GET OFF THE
COUCH. SO IT'S NOT GOING TO
CREATE A PROBLEM. BUT- I DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS. WORKED OUT
WITH THE AUTHOR- FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND IF THIS WAS ONLY TO
BE INTRODUCED AS A METAPHOR
MEDICINAL PURPOSES- THERE WAS
GETTING OUT THE OPPOSITION FROM
THE HEALTHCARE. ARENA OR THE
DOCTORS AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. THAT'S WHY. THIS
MEASURE WAS INTRODUCED IN A WAY
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE
MICRO DOSES. SO THAT ITS
PURPOSE IS SOLELY FOR MEDICAL
PURPOSES FOR TO ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEPRESSION OR
OTHER ELEMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
FIND RELIEF SO I'M INCLINED TO
SUPPORT IT. VERY- HESITANTLY
AND THE- I DON'T KNOW IF I WILL
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ONCE IT COMES ON THE FLOOR BUT
I DO WANNA I DO WANT THIS
CONVERSATION TO GO FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO BE.
THINKING ABOUT THIS IN A WAY OF
HOW DO WE STOP JUST
CRIMINALIZING THINGS BUT
LOOKING AT TRYING TO. USE IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIX AILMENTS-
SO WITH THAT THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR ON ON
WORKING ON THIS- AND- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE AND-
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR IN HIS AREA OF MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST BRIEFLY I SUPPORT THIS
BILL WHEN I FIRST HEARD IT HI I
THOUGHT WHAT ON EARTH AND WE
PROPOSING HERE. LEGALIZING IT
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO BUY IT IN
GETTING THE HIT GETTING IN THE
HANDS OF. OUR YOUTH AND YOU
KNOW A MILLION TALK ABOUT MY
YOUTH BUT- IT WAS TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT HAVING THIS PRODUCT-
READILY AVAILABLE TO OUR YOUTH
IS NOT A POSITIVE THING BUT WE
ARE DECRIMINALIZING POSSESSION
BUT I CONCUR WITH MR MAYS I
THINK THE REAL ISSUE. IS THAT
IF THIS HAS A VIABLE PURPOSE I
COULD HEAR FROM SOME THE
WITNESSES. IT SHOULD BE-
SANCTION FOR THE SALE YOU
SHOULD WE SHOULD DO IT LIKE WE
DID WITH MEDICINAL MARIJUANA
FOR THE PAST THIRTY YEARS AND-
GO GET A DOCTOR'S NOTE. AND
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
INSTANCES WHERE IS THIS IS
SHOWN THERE HAS SOME VALUE SO I
THINK THIS IS LITERALLY THE
WRONG ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN THE LAST I GET THAT THE-
AUTHOR WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THE
CRIMINALIZATION AND THE IMPACT
THE SOME PEOPLE. COULD BE
CHARGED TODAY WITH POSSESSION
BUT THE REAL ISSUE OF THIS DOES
HAS A SOCIETAL BENEFITS. WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE ON THE
OTHER PIECE OF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY- ANYONE ELSE.
YES MISS KOREA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND TO THE MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BROUGHT UP THIS
DISCUSSION AND TO- THE ASSEMBLY%
MEMBER FOR PRESENTING ON A BILL
I KNOW IT'S NOT YOUR BILL AND-
I WISH THE SENATOR WAS HERE HAD
A CONVERSATION WITH HIM. A
COUPLE OF TIMES ABOUT THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW I E. I'M VERY
CONFLICTED. I GENERALLY FALL IN
THE CATEGORY OF WANTING TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO. PUSH
FORWARD LEGISLATION THAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
ORIENTED THAT'S ABOUT REDUCING
CAR SERRATION. THAT'S ABOUT
HELPING PEOPLE AT THE END OF
THE DAY RESTART THEIR LIVES. I
DON'T KNOW IF I WANT TO SEE.
MORE DRUGS IN MY COMMUNITY. WE
ARE ALREADY DEALING WITH HUGE
ISSUES RELATED TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROBLEMS. AT THE- ABILITY FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE TO
DO SOMETHING IN MANY CASES FOR
FOLKS TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WITH SOCIAL WORKERS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH- EVALUATIONS
THAT ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF
THE DAY. HELP PEOPLE. MY
QUESTIONS ARE STILL UNANSWERED
IN TERMS OF. THE ACT OF BUYING
AND SELLING IT'S STILL ILLEGAL.
SO THE AMOUNTS THAT ARE ON HERE
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
ALLOWABLE AMOUNTS ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE- I WOULD NEED TO SEE THEM
AND I SEE THE THERE ARE GROUNDS
AND- FOR L. IS D. FOUR DMT.
FOR- MOLLY ECSTASY MDMA SAYS
THE M. T. I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT SOME OF THIS STUFF IS
CERTAIN MUSHROOMS I FEEL VERY I
FEEL REALLY- APPREHENSIVE OF
PUSHING A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
FORWARD THAT- DOESN'T HAVE A
PLAN IN TERMS OF THE ACT OF THE
SALE AND BUYING THE STILL
ILLEGAL. AND SO YOUR STATE YOU
ARE IN MANY WAYS PROMOTING AN
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY OF DRUGS.
I'M NOT OKAY WITH THAT IN MY
COMMUNITY- I WANT TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL I
UNDERSTAND AND THANKFUL TO THE
TESTIMONY EARLIER FROM THE
VETERANS WHO ARE TRYING TO FIND
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ADDRESS
ISSUES OF PTSD THAT PROBLEM IN
ITSELF IS THAT THE TUITION IS
ONE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
PROBLEM ONE THAT WE SHOULD
INVEST IN ONE THE SHOULD HAVE-
PERFECT MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
IN THE ROOM. TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE AND HELP VETERANS THAT
NEED THOSE SERVICES. BUT IF
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT RIGHT
NOW. THE BILL DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE THAT BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A
CLINICAL SETTING. AND THAT YOU
ARE ADVOCATING TO HELP THESE
DRUGS TO SIMPLY BE ON THE
STREET. I'M SORRY I JUST I
CAN'T SUPPORT THAT AND I WANT
TO FIND A PATHWAY THERE-
ANOTHER COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
MEDICINAL MARIJUANA MEDICINAL.
TOOK TWENTY YEARS TO GET TO
THAT LEVEL AND SURE WE WANT TO
EXPEDITE THINGS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THINGS MOVE FASTER BUT
THERE WAS A CARD ASSOCIATED
THERE WAS A DOCTOR ASSOCIATED
THERE IS AN INCREASE OF USAGE
TO NOW THAT ITS RECREATIONAL
AND IT'S MORE ACCEPTABLE. BUT
IT WASN'T JUST LET'S. LEGALIZE
AND THAT FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENS IT WAS THERE WAS A
PROCESS. AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PROCESS IS
HERE. I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN.
HELP EDUCATE ME OR MAYBE THIS
BILL JUST ISN'T REALLY FULLY
THERE YET THE INTENT IS GOOD.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT MORE
THAN NEEDS TO BE DONE AND WORK
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ENSURE THAT
THESE TYPES OF DRUGS. DON'T END
UP IN THE WRONG HANDS AND
ACTUALLY END UP HURTING PEOPLE
THAT ARE UNDER TWENTY ONE. AS
IT RELATES TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I WANTED A
FOR CELEBRATION THE COMMENTS
AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A
MEMBER WHO ALWAYS- LEADS WITH
YOUR HEART AND YOU'RE HERE
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO HELP PEOPLE
AND YOU WANT TO HELP YOUR
COMMUNITY- AND YOU CITED A
COUPLE DIFFERENT- EXAMPLES HERE
YOU DON'T WANT MORE DRUGS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY. I DON'T WANT
MORE DRUGS IN MY COMMUNITY
EITHER BUT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO'S DYING ON
THE STREETS DOING HEROIN. AND A
VETERAN WHO'S- SEEKING
THERAPEUTIC RESOURCES TO DEAL
WITH PTSD. SAYING THOSE ARE
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS. AND
THESE TYPES OF A HOST ENGINES
CAN ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES CAN HELP
PEOPLE WHO ARE. DEALING WITH
DRUG ADDICTION. YOU KNOW THE
FDA IS CURRENTLY TRYING TO GO
THROUGH A PROCESS OF LEGALIZING
THIS. IT COULD TAKE A NUMBER OF
YEARS. A NUMBER OF YEARS AND IN
THE MEANTIME WE SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE PEOPLE.
BEGGING FOR THIS TO BE A
RESOURCE. AND I DON'T WANT TO
GET IN THE WAY OF PEOPLE
BEGGING FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH. THE ISSUES THAT THEY ARE
CONFRONTED WITH EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND NIGHT. AND SO IF WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT PATH WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS.
THERE WAS AN UNDERGROUND MARKET
FOR VERY LONG TIME THERE'S
STILL AN UNDERGROUND MARCH. YOU
KNOW AND IT WAS ONLY ONCE WE
HAVE THE POLITICAL COURAGE TO
SAY LOOK AT WHAT THE RESEARCH
IS TELLING US. ABOUT THIS. THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO THEN SAY HERE'S
A PATH FOR LEGALIZATION RIGHT
SO YES WE SHOULD HAVE CLINICAL
STUDIES. MANY THERAPISTS OFFER
THAT TYPE OF STUFF RIGHT YES
THE FDA SHOULD PURSUE
LEGALIZATION AND THEY'RE DOING
THAT AND THAT'S GONNA TAKE A
NUMBER OF YEARS. BUT IN THE
MEANTIME WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SMALL AMOUNTS RIGHT FOR
PERSONAL POSSESSION- YOU WOULD
MENTION THE SORT OF UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY THAT YOU'VE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT'S HAPPENING TODAY.
RIGHT NOW. AND IF WE CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY THAT FOR AGAIN FOR
THERAPEUTIC PURPOSES THE STUFF
CAN BE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE THEN
BY ALL MEANS I WANT TO GIVE
PEOPLE THE TOOLS IN THEIR TOOL
BOX THAT THEY HAVE AND YOU KNOW
GET I'M NOT THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL SO I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS FOR YOU- BUT IT IS MY
HOPE THAT AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS WE CAN CONTINUE TO-
DEFINED THIS BILL MORE
SPECIFICALLY. I'D BE HAPPY AND
I'M SURE SENATOR WIENER WOULD
BE AS WELL TO SIT DOWN WITH YOU
WITH MORE TO TIONAL CONCERNS
TELL CRAFTED IN A WAY- BUT
AGAIN I THINK IT THE GOAL IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THESE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE I
GUESS WHAT I'M I'M THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND WHAT I'M STILL NOT
HEARING IS THE HOW. IF YOU ARE
A VETERAN THAT NEED SERVICES.
THAT WANTS TO TRY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF
PTSD WHAT IF THE HOUSE. I'D
LOVE FOR MY WITNESS TO IF
THAT'S OKAY MISTER CHAIR PLEASE
GO AHEAD- TO HAVE A- OUR
WITNESS SPEAK TO THAT. THE
SPANISH MAIL. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS CONVERSATION THESE
QUESTIONS- ALSO A TWO THINGS
ONE REGARDING THE COMMISSION OF
THE BILL WHICH IS- IN THERE I
BELIEVE TO THINK THROUGH A LOT
OF THESE QUESTIONS REGARDING
WHAT THAT MORE REGULATED
STRUCTURE MIGHT LOOK LIKE- SO I
DO THINK THAT SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS ARE RESPONDED TO BY AT
LEAST THE EXISTENCE OF THAT AND
AGAIN THE AMENDMENTS THAT CAME
IN TODAY ALLOWED THAT TO BE A
TIERED PIECE WHERE. THE FIRST
ROUND OF IT IS MERELY EDUCATION
AND HARM REDUCTION RESOURCES
AND THEN THE SECOND BEING GOING
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE JUST
ASK MORE AROUND REGULATED USE-
OVERSIGHT AND SO ON- THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION IS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN SELF ORGANIZING A LOT
OF THESE VETERANS GROUPS THAT
YOU'VE SEEN JOINT HAVE BEEN.
HOLDING CIRCLES ARE HOLDING
COMMUNITY CEREMONIES AT
THEMSELVES SO RIGHT NOW A LOT
OF THE EXPERIENCE THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED AROUND SHARED USE AND
IT FACILITATED USE EITHER COMES
FROM TRADITIONS THAT ARE COMING
OUT OF AS JUST MENTIONED
EARLIER CENTRAL OR SOUTH
AMERICA. WHERE THESE.
SUBSTANCES HAVE BEEN USING
CEREMONIAL CONTEXT FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS AND PEOPLE HAVE
TRAINED AND TRAVELED AND
TRAINED. TO DO THAT- OR IT
RIGHT NOW UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF ISSUES REGARDING LICENSURE-
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY
ANOTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THAT
CONCERN FOR- CURRENTLY LICENSED
FACILITATORS HAS BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF FEAR. OF
LIABILITY AND OTHER RELATED
ISSUES SO THAT WAY IT'S BEEN
HAPPENING IS THAT COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN SELF ORGANIZING TO DO
THESE CIRCLES. AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD THE HEALING IS ON GOING
AND PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
THAT I DON'T KNOW THAT
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE INCLUDING SOME THAT WE
SEE. ON THE STREET AS YOU
MENTIONED YOU WERE DYING FROM
HER AND ARE ALSO THOSE VETERANS
WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM PTSD.
THOSE ARE NOT NECESSARILY
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AND THERE
IS A NEED THAT'S A VERY EXTREME
THAT'S VERY THAT'S VERY VISIBLE
THROUGHOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK THANK YOU I DON'T I'M NOT
SURE THAT THAT ACTUALLY ANSWERS
MY QUESTION MY QUESTION IS. HOW
HOW ARE YOU GETTING THIS
POTENTIAL MEDICATION LET'S CALL
IT MEDICATION FOR WHAT IT IS TO
FOR ADDRESSING ISSUES. OF PTSD.
WHAT IS THE HOW OUTSIDE OF
GOING TO SOUTH AMERICA AND
PARTICIPATING IN A- OF AN
INDIGENOUS CEREMONY AND RITUAL
THAT TAKES YEARS AND DECADES
FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
THAT YOU SHOULD NEVER DO ALONE.
WHAT IF THE HOW AND IF I AND I
THINK SERVE A COMMUNITY OF
VETERANS FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN. WHAT IS THE HOW
OLD AND HOW AN INDIVIDUAL CAN
GET A SEEK ASSISTANCE AND
ACTUALLY BUY THESE DRUGS WHAT
DOES THAT PROCESS LOOK LIKE
ACCORDING TO THIS BILL. THIS
BILL DOES NOT SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
THE PURCHASE PROCESS THAT
EXPLICITLY AVOIDS THAT
CONVERSATION EIGHT EXPRESSLY
AVOIDS CREATING AN- ECONOMY A
MARKET OUT OF IT. WHICH IS I
BELIEVE WHAT THE COMMISSION IS
INTENDED TO DO SO RIGHT NOW THE
PURCHASE EVERYTHING LEADING UP
TO THE PERSONAL POSSESSION
REMAINS ILLEGAL- WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SHARING RIGHT NOW IS THAT TRUTH
THAT'S A VERY HARD FOR US TO
MANAGE TO DEAL WITH I THINK. IF
THIS BILL WERE A BILL THAT SAID
WE ARE CREATING A PLATFORM IN
WHICH IN CERTAIN CLINICS OR
SETTINGS OR- TRUSTED CENTERS
WITH PROFESSIONALS. THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN MOVE
FORWARD I WOULD BE 1100% OKAY
WITH THAT. BUT THE FACT THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
CONTINUED ILLEGAL FAIL. I AM
ONLY ADDRESSES ISSUES OF
QUANTITY AMOUNTS ARE ALLOWABLE
AMOUNTS THAT ARE CONTROLLED. A
SUBSTANCE IN ORDER FOR YOU TO
NOT BE ARRESTED COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THINGS- I THINK IT IS
IT'S A STEP FORWARD IN AT LEAST
THE CONVERSATION- I JUST I'M
NOT SURE THAT JUST LEGALIZING
WITHOUT A PATHWAY. ON HOW WE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THAT- IS THE
RIGHT COURSE FOR RIGHT NOW. AND
SO THAT'S- YOU KNOW I'M I'M
SORRY TO SAY THAT THAT SOME.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE WAYS
THAT. AND THERE ARE NEW METHODS
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED WHEN-
RELATED TO ISSUES OF PTSD IN
VETERANS THAT I AM 1100% IN
SUPPORT AND WE HAVE SEEN THOSE
STUDIES. BUT THIS DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT. THIS THIS
ADDRESSES A PORTION THAT
CONTINUES TO ALSO INDICATE THAT
THE SALE AND BUYING OF. THESE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES IS
ACTUALLY STILL ILLEGAL. YEP
I'LL LET YOU GO AHEAD THANKS.
JUST ONE SUPER QUICK NO
RESPONSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT I'LL JUST NOTE THAT- WITH
SOME OF THESE SUBSTANCES IN
PARTICULAR THE PLANTS- I
BELIEVE THAT HOME GROW IS ALSO
PERMITTED SO THERE WOULD BE A
LEGAL WAY TO CULTIVATE PLANTS
AND FUNGI- THAT ERROR INCLUDED
THAT OUR NUMBER OF THE
SUBSTANCES AND THIS BILL SO
THAT IS ONE WAY IN THAT. SAFE
NON SALE NINE- IT ECONOMIC
ACCESS MIGHT BE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE CULTIVATION OF SOME
OF THESE SUBSTANCES AND THAT'S
WHERE I THINK SOME OF THOSE
ANSWERS COULD OR SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS COULD BE ANSWERED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I MISS BURKE. ASSEMBLY THIS
MAKES WILL ALSO I AM A FIRST
NOT UNLIKE MY COLLEAGUE I DON'T
KNOW A LOT OF THESE THINGS ARE
AND HAVE HAD TO LEARN ABOUT
THEM OVER THE OURSE OF THE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS OR SO- AND
EVEN ON THE AMOUNT THAT FEW DID
PUT THEM IN FRONT OF ME I
WOULDN'T KNOW IF IT LOOK LIKE A
LOT OR A LITTLE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU BUT- I WILL AND I DO
HAVE TO SAY THAT I WAS SIMILAR.
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES IN THE FACT THAT I
WOULD ORIGINALLY THIS THOUGHT
THERE WAS JUST NO WAY I COULD
VOTE FOR THIS I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR. I AM THE AUTHOR AND
THE NUMBER OF FOR THEIR
AMENDMENTS THEY IT IT MADE IT
MUCH EASIER FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND AND KIND OF GET TO
GET TO THE PLACE WHERE I COULD
I COULD SEE THAT THIS WAS
NECESSARY I THINK IT HELPS FOR
ME TO KNOW THAT THEIR IT IS
UNDER FDA APPROVAL A LOT OF
THESE DRUGS ARE. BEING REVIEWED
BY THE FDA FOR THEIR CLINICAL
PURPOSES I THINK THAT'S
ESPECIALLY HELPFUL AND I DO
THINK THAT THE SHARE PROVISION
THAT THE CHAIR AND PUT IN PLACE
THAT ACTUALLY DOESN'T NARAL
WHAT SHARE MEANS AND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE- HELPS ME UNDERSTAND
THAT REALLY THE GOAL IS TO PAY
FOR IT TO BE EXCHANGED WITH A
CLINICIAN- ON A VERY SMALL
LEVEL AND ON A MICRO DOES OR
WHATEVER THE PROPER TERM WOULD
BE ON ALL OF THESE DRUGS I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A STANDARD
TERM ACROSS THE BOARD- BUT I DO
THINK THAT THAT IS VERY HELPFUL
TO KNOW THE FDA'S. IS IN THE
PROCESS OF APPROVING A LOT OF
THESE FOR THERAPEUTIC USE AND
THAT THESE THESE DOSES ARE
CONSIDERED MICRO. DOSE- IN
THEIR SPECIALTIES. FOR ME.
OBVIOUSLY DECRIMINALIZATION IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR MY
COMMUNITY. OB I HAVE THE SAME
ISSUES. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO OF DRUG USE IN MY
COMMUNITY HOWEVER. I THINK THAT
THE DEMAND TO CRIMINALIZATION
AT THESE LEVELS I THINK IF. I
CAN'T SEE AS BEING ACCEPTABLE
THEN I DO THINK. THAT FOR THOSE
WHO STRUGGLE WITH SOME OF THESE
THERAPEUTIC ISSUES TO HAVE TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY AND WHATEVER
VETERANS WHICH I THINK.
OBVIOUSLY FIRST TIER VETERANS
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT FOR
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING WE- PUT THEM IN THAT
SITUATION. SO WHATEVER WE CAN
DO TO CREATE ALLEVIATE THE PAIN
THAT THEY HAVE IT INTO WORD.
AND THE MENTAL ANGUISH THAT
THEY AREN'T HAVE HAVE AND
CONTINUE TO INDOOR. IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. AND TO DO IT
CAREFULLY LIKE I BELIEVE THIS
BILL HAS NARROWED IT TO YOU. I
THINK IS VITAL. I ALSO THINK
IT'S- I WAS I WAS SAD TO HEAR
SOME OF THE STORIES ABOUT THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE HAD TO SEND
THEIR KIDS AWAY. OTHER
COUNTRIES. IN THE MIDDLE OF
KNOWING THAT THEY WERE GOING
THROUGH THESE DAYS ADDICTIONS
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
HAVING TO SEND THEM. THEIR KIDS
AWAY FROM THEM. THEIR FAMILIES
I KNOW I DON'T LIKE SENDING MY
KID TO DISNEYLAND. NOT TO
MENTION CENTER OF THE COUNTRY
WHEN SHE'S AT OUR WEAKEST I.
GUESS I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER
THAN THAT FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
FOR OUR VETERANS. SO WITH THAT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY IT TOOK ME A LONG TIME TO
GET TERE AND- IT'S TAKEN A LOT
OF WORK FROM. THE STAFF HERE
AND THE CHAIR BUT WITH THAT I.
I'D LIKE TO SECOND THE BILL
AND- I WILL BE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANYONE
ELSE. AS FOR SAY THANK YOU-
MISS WEEKS REPRESENTING THE
BILL ON ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WIENER- IT DOESN'T JOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- YOU KNOW I
THINK SOME OF WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM MEMBERS HERE IS ARE NOT
UNLIKE THE CAN SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE- I THINK WHAT
IT WHAT WHAT IS DIFFERENT FOR
ME. IS THE- IS THE GROUP
WORKING GROUPS OF PEOPLE
WORKING TO WITH FACILITATED.
CARE FOR PEOPLE. I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS LIKE GOING OUT
ON THE STREET CORNER AND BUYING
SOMETHING AND YOU KNOW WHATEVER
AND THIS ISN'T EVEN THERE ISN'T
EVEN A REAL THIS IS IN THE
SALES OF THIS ISN'T THIS IS
NOT. NOT THIS GROUP COMING
TOGETHER AS- AND SELLING THIS
TO PEOPLE THAT'S NOT THE WAY
THIS IS WORKING. I THINK OF-
YOU KNOW IT WASN'T. IT WASN'T
JUST BUT BUT JUST THREE YEARS
AGO MAYBE MAYBE FOR THAT THE
FDA ACTUALLY APNA PROVED- A
CANNABIS THROUGH A CANNABIS
DERIVED- MEDICATION FOR THE
TREATMENT OF SEIZURES IN YOUNG
CHILDREN IT'S TAKEN. HOW LONG
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN ANOTHER
OTHERS OTHER THINGS ARE COMING
ALONG SO ARE APPROVAL PROCESS
IS REALLY REALLY CHALLENGING
AND SO THE IDEA THAT A
PHYSICIAN MIGHT ACTUALLY DO
THIS AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
BECAUSE OF THE WAY OUR
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES ACT IS- I
CAN SEE WOULD BE OF CONCERN- SO
FOR ME- THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THIS AND HEAR
THOSE STORIES AND THE
REALIZATION- I WAS CONVINCED.
OF THE THERAPEUTIC VALUE OF
MANY OF THESE SUBSTANCES AND
THE ROLE THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THEY CAN PLAY IN IN TREATMENT
FOR A PTSD ANXIETY DEPRESSION
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO RESPOND TO OTHER
OTHER MODALITIES. IT'S THERE'S
A LOT OF THINGS THAT PEOPLE GO
THROUGH TO GET TO THIS POINT
AND AS YOU HEARD AS WE HEARD
FROM SOME OF THE FAMILIES.
APPARENTLY PARTICULAR THEY WENT
THROUGH EVERYTHING WITH THEIR
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR SON TO
TRY TO GET TO THIS POINT AND
THIS WAS LIKE THE LAST RESORT
AND IT MADE A DIFFERENCE AND TO
ME THAT'S PRETTY THAT'S PRETTY
COMPELLING. A MANY TO CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BREADTH OF THE SCOPE
STILL REMAIN AND AS SCOPE OF
THE BILL STILL REMAIN. THE
WHOLESALE DECRIMINALIZATION OF
HALLUCINOGENIC FOR PERSONAL USE
THAT RECEIVED APPROVAL OF THESE
DRUGS. AND BY EXTENSION THE
IMPLICATION THAT APPROVAL
BRINGS. TO THE POTENTIAL
INCREASED USE BY MINORS IS
TROUBLING. I HAVE TO REFLECT
BACK TO REMEMBER IN TALKING TO
MY SON WHO IS NOW TWENTY FIVE.
IN HIGH SCHOOL- MEMBER HEARING
HIM SAY- I SAID YOU KNOW CAN
YOU TELL ME WHAT IT'S LIKE AND
SAYS HE SAYS WHATEVER YOU WANT
THAT. I CAN GET ANYTHING I
WANT. AT ANY TIME. AT IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AND SO THE IDEA THAT
THIS IS YEAH THIS IS THIS IS
OUT THERE IN COMMUNITIES NOW-
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT- THIS
OF THIS FACILITATED USE I THINK
IS A VERY DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT. THAN THAN WHAT YOU
MIGHT SEE ON THE STREET SO. I'M
ALSO TROUBLED BY THE LACK OF
PUBLIC AWARENESS AROUND HOW
THESE. SUBSTANCES MIGHT AFFECT
PERSONS AT RISK OF FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS OR WITH A FAMILY FAMILY
HISTORIES OF MENTAL ILLNESS.
THE AMENDMENTS- AND THANK YOU-
THROUGH- THANK YOU THROUGHOUT
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER THREE
YOU SEE IS ME. TAKING COMMITTEE
DAY- ADDING PERSON LIMIT FOR
PERSONAL POSSESSION ADDING IN
SOME HARM REDUCTION EDUCATION-
FIRST RESPONDER TRAINING OR A
BEGINNING. AND BUT THE VERY
FACT WE'RE PROVING THESE DRUGS
FOR PERSONAL USE AND REALLY
EVEN. FOR FACILITATORS
SUPPORTED USE BEFORE DPH HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STUDY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR APPROPRIATE
STRUCTURE GUARDRAILS. FEELS
PREMATURE TO ME. A LITTLE BIT-
I'M HOPEFUL AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO CONSIDER ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. THE PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE- STRUCTURES AND
GUARDRAILS. I DO WANT TO IMPAIR
AND REITERATE THOUGH HOW
COMPELLED I WAS BY THE CASE
MADE FOR DEBT THE THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS- THAT THESE
HALLUCINOGENIC OFFER. FOR THOSE
REASONS I SUPPORT THE DEATH THE
BILL TODAY- WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS WEEK'S. I
JUST WANT TO THANK. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THIS THANK- MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION. WHETHER YOU ARE
GOING TO MOVE THE BILL OUT VOTE
TO VOTE OR NOT APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION. YEAH I WILL SAY I
THINK. ALL OF US HERE.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT PARTY WE ARE
WE CAME HERE BECAUSE WE WANT TO
HELP PEOPLE. THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO DO. AND THIS IS
WONDERFUL THE TOOLBOX THAT I
BELIEVE. WE CAN EMPLOY THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY HELP PEOPLE. RIGHT
NOW THAT DESPERATELY NEED HELP
IN ADDITION TO VETERANS THERE'S
ALSO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. USES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T TRUST THE
SYSTEM WITH WHICH THEY ARE
OPERATING IN RIGHT NOW. SO
THEY'RE SEEKING OTHER REMEDIES.
TO BE ABLE TO HEAL FROM THOSE
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES. WE KNOW
THAT THESE DRUGS ARE NOT
ADDICTIVE. WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE
DECRIMINALIZE THIS WE TAKE IT
OUT OF THE SHADOWS WE PROVIDE
MORE EDUCATION WE PROVIDE. A
THERAPEUTIC SETTING FOR THIS
THAT CAN BE ACTUALLY VERY
POWERFUL AND IMPACTFUL IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT MANY OTHER COUNTRIES AND
STATES ARE CONSIDERING SIMILAR
THINGS AS IS THE FTA. SO I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
CONVERSATION HERE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
WICKS- WITH THAT- WE WILL- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
NAZARIAN THE SECOND BY MISS
BURKE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BIGELOW HELLO NO BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO NOT
VOTING FLORIDA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NO. MCCARTY MCCARTY
I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE. RIVAS.
RIVAS NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON NO. FIVE TO
THREE THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS WEEKS. BAKER THIS RUBIO
YES PLEASE. IF ITEM NUMBER NINE
SB THREE TEN. WITH THE MESSAGE
CARE. AT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT SB THREE TEN A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HELP SAVE LIVES OF
CANCER PATIENTS AND WILL
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CRITICAL
MEDICATION TO THOSE THAT CAN
AFFORD IT. FIRST I WANT TO NOTE
THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED MEMBERS FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE AND I
ALSO WANT THANK GOD A CO AUTHOR
SO I'M SOME WHO FIT IN THIS
COMMITTEE- FOR SUPPORTING THIS
ISSUE AS WELL THIS BILL CREATES
A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM THAT WILL
ALLOW CANCER PATIENTS TO DONATE
THEIR UNUSED MEDICATIONS TO
PATIENTS IN NEED. THROUGH THEIR
CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN TRAGICALLY
A RECENT STUDY SHOWS ABOUT
THIRTY FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
REPORTED KNOWING OF AT LEAST
ONE FRIEND OR FAMILY MEMBER IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS WHO DIED
AFTER NOT RECEIVING THE NEEDED
MEDICATION TREATMENT DUE TO THE
HIGH COST I KNOW ONE PERSON
PERSONALLY THAT HAD OVER THREE
AT THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS%
WORTH OF MEDICATION. THAT
ARRIVED AFTER HIS WIFE PASSED
WITH BREAST CANCER AND HE
WASN'T ABLE TO DONATE IT SO IT
WAS LOST AT LEAST TWELVE OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY HAVE
SIMILAR PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME THAT
CALIFORNIA. JOIN THEM. IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE DONATION PROGRAM WILL
REQUIRE A PATIENT PHYSICIAN
RELATIONSHIP. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THE PHYSICIAN WILL BE
THE PERSON WHO PRESCRIBED THE
MEDICATION INITIALLY AND WILL
BE ABLE TO ASSESS ITS INTEGRITY
BEFORE DONATING IT. TO ANOTHER
PATIENT. IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MY TWO WITNESSES
THAT ARE HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY FIRST WITNESS WILL BE
TESTIFIED REMOTELY. BE CARDENAS
DUNCAN CANCER PATIENT FROM SAN
LEANDRO. AND MY SECOND WITNESS
WILL BE HONEST SAID SHORT ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGIST
WHO'S THE SCHOOLS THE COSPONSOR
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR I SEE- THE SHORT
IN THE- GALLERY THERE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO GO AHEAD FIRST. I'M
HAPPY TO DEFER TO THE PATIENT
ON THE PHONE IF THAT WORKS FOR
YOU SAID THAT BY THE I'M FINE
WITH THAT TOO- SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD- THEN TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR OUR OUR- WITNESS IN SUPPORT
THE- CARD IN THIS. THE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL COME BACK THEN HOW ABOUT
HOW BOUT NOW TO SET. SOUNDS
GREAT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE A SAFE PATIENT AND
PHYSICIAN DRIVEN CANCER
SPECIFIC DRUG DONATION PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA. WHICH WOULD YOU
COULD HAVE ENHANCE PATIENTS
ACCESS TO CARE REDUCE WASTE IN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE TREATMENT TO
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. ASIANS
ARE OFTEN PRESCRIBED COSTLY
ANTI CANCER MEDICATIONS THAT
OCCASIONALLY DUE TO NTOLERANCE
OR SIDE EFFECTS GO UNUSED. BUT
THESE UNUSED EXPENSIVE
MEDICATIONS ARE OFTEN DISCARDED
DUE TO A LACK OF SYSTEM TO
REPURPOSE THE MEDICATIONS FOR
OTHER NEEDY PATIENTS.
FURTHERMORE THE APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR THE MEDICATIONS CAN
TAKE WEEKS FOR PATIENTS TO
RECEIVE THE MEDICATION IN START
TREATMENT. IN CANCER CARE
DELAYING TREATMENT CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH FOR MANY PATIENTS. WE
HAVE IMPLANTED INTO THE PROGRAM
A MARRIED A PATIENT PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT PATIENT
SAFETY IS OUR FIRST OBLIGATION.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THOSE
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT PATIENTS WILL WORK TO
ENSURE THEY CAN HAVE TIMELY
ACCESS TO THEIR NEEDED
TREATMENT. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
STUDY FROM RESEARCHERS AT
MEMORIAL SLOAN KETTERING BUT
NEARLY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
WAS LOST ANNUALLY AND WASTED
CANCER DRUGS. EVEN WASTED
CANCER MEDICATION REPRESENTS AN
EXPENSE FOR CALIFORNIA PATIENT
AND A LOST OPPORTUNITY FOR
TREATMENT AND TIMELY TREATMENT.
OTHER STATES WITH PROGRAMS IN
PLACE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR. WILL HAVE SAFE PATIENTS
IN THEIR STATES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. WE'RE EXCITED TO BE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND
THE CO AUTHORS IN THE ROOM. TO
BRING THIS INNOVATIVE PROGRAM
TO CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
INCOME MEMBERS OF OUR PATIENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD OF
CHAIR YES. MEDICARE YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE CARD IN A SECOND
POINT A PRIVILEGE I WOULD I
COULD GET TO ON MUTE OKAY I
THINK MY STATEMENT YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
BEATRICE BY THE NEXT DOWNTURN I
AM LIVING WITH CHRONIC MYELOID
LEUKEMIA. I HAVE BEEN
PRESCRIBED SEVEN TYPE OF ORAL
CHEMO MEDICATION. THE REASON
FOR THIS IS THAT CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS DID NOT RESPOND
EFFECTIVELY AND HAVE TO BE
STOPPED. DOING THIS CHANGES OF
PRESCRIPTION I WAS NOT ABLE TO
FINISH THE MEDICATION AND
SEVERAL TIMES THEY WERE BILLS
THAT COULD NOT BE USED IN OTHER
WORDS FINISH THIS PRESCRIBE
MEDICATION. AND HAVE TO BE
DISCARDED. I ALWAYS FELT A
SENSE OF GUILT TO DISCARD THIS
MEDICATION WHAT IF THERE HAD
BEEN A SYSTEM IN PLACE WHERE
OTHER CANCER. PATIENTS COULD
HAVE BENEFITTED. THE PRISON
SYSTEM. AVERAGE COST WORK SIX
THOUSAND OR MORE PER MONTH. I
AM GRATEFUL THAT I HAVE MEDICAL
COVERAGE AND DID NOT HAVE TO
PAY THE FULL AMOUNT. SENATOR
RUBIO SB THREE TEN IF THE
CENTRAL TO BECOME LAW. I READ
THE CONTEXT OF THIS BILL AND IN
MY OPINION IT WILL BE IT WILL
BE DOCUMENTED IT WILL BE WELL
DOCUMENTED INCLUDING THE
REGULATIONS AS TO HOW THIS
DONATED MEDICATION WILL BE
MONITORED AND SYSTEMS IN PLACE
HOW IT WILL BE RECYCLED AND
ENFORCE. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS THAT
AFFECT CANCER PATIENTS THEY
LACK ACCESS TO CANCER
MEDICATION. SO I FULLY REQUEST
YOUR YOUR YES VOTE SO THAT
CANCER MEDICATION CAN BE
DONATED IN CANCER PATIENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE THIS MUCH
NEEDED HELP BENEFIT. THANK YOU
FOR PARKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE MY PRESENT AGE SIX AND
PATIENT THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE O THE PHONE LINES NOW WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY REGISTERED-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO THIS
WILL BE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. I JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU RECOMMEND
ONE OR IF YOU RECOMMEND ONE IF.
YOU REPRESENT ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW- UP. AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YEAR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE THE
PLACE YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO SHOW OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND WE WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH LINE. TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD TO TWENTY. TWO TWENTY CAN
EITHER AS. NEXT CALLER PLEASE I
AM ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M SORRY-
THEIR LINES ARE NOT OPENING.
WINE TWO EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ON MISTER CHAIR NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WHEN WE ARE BACK.
AND WE WILL GO. TO NOBODY'S
GONNA ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. NOBODY IS GOING UP
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
REFEREE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THE BILL DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU FOR SEX EXCEPT IN THE
AMENDMENTS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I FEEL NO WE'VE ALL
EITHER AT SOME POINT OR ANOTHER
KNOWN SOMEONE THAT HAS CANCER
AND- THIS CAN MEAN BOTH THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH FOR SOME OF OUR-
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
WITH THAT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS BY- BYE MISTER NAZARIAN IS
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WHAT I WOULD
AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO RIO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON HIGH. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL AND OF
YOUR ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SIX
EIGHTY TWO WAS ON CONSENT
THAT'S ALREADY PASSED OUT SO
PLEASE SIR GO AHEAD ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. C. R. ELEVEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID
TODAY I'M HONORED TO PRESENT S.
C. ARE YOU LOVE IT THE CANCER
PATIENT. BILL OF RIGHTS I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH ME TO STRENGTHEN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE RESOLUTION. WE
ALL HAVE AGAIN BEEN TOUCHED ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER BY SOMEONE.
THAT'S STRUGGLING WITH CANCER
IN THE THANK YOUR VALLEY WE ARE
SO LUCKY TO HAVE THE CITY OF
HOPE RIGHT IN OUR BACKYARD. A
DESIGNATED NATIONAL CANCER
INSTITUTE. CANCER RESEARCH
CENTERS LIKE CITY OF HOPE
CONDUCT CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH
TO DEVELOP NEW TREATMENTS AND
CURES. UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
CANCER PATIENTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE FROM VULNERABLE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS THOSE LIFE
SAVING MEDICATIONS AND THE BEST
CHANCE OF A CURE IS THE FIRST
CHANCE FOR A CURE. WHICH IS WHY
PATIENTS DESERVE INFORMATION
ABOUT TREATMENT OPTIONS AND
RELEVANT MEDICAL RESEARCH.
THAT'S WHY I HAVE AUTHORED THIS
CANCER PATIENT BILL OF RIGHTS
THIS RESOLUTION IS SUPPORTED BY
MANY PATIENT AND GREW UP
PROVIDER GROUPS THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY THE CHRONIC CARE
COALITION AND MORE. THE
RESOLUTION HAS OVER THIRTY
BIPARTISAN CO AUTHORS AND THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ARE TWO WITNESSES IF
I MAY I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE DR
JOSEPH ALL BERNATH. THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND SENIOR MEDICAL DIRECTOR AT
CITY OF HOPE AND COLMA MAKE DAL
A CANCER PATIENT AT CITY OF
HOPE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD- CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR
JOSEPH ALBURNUS. I NEED A
COLLEGES- AT THE CITY OF HOPE
IS SERVICE BASED PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. AND
CHEMICAL PRODUCTION THE
DEPARTMENT OLOGY. I APPRECIATE
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY AND PAPERMASTER ELEVEN
WHICH CLAIMED SIX PRINCIPLES
THAT MAKE UP THE CANCER PATIENT
BILL OF RIGHTS. THE CITY OF
HOPE IS A SPONSOR OF SCR ELEVEN
AND WE BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT
ALL CANCER PATIENTS SHOULD BE
AFFORDED APPROPRIATE CARE AT
THE RIGHT TIME. AND
INSTITUTIONS WITH THE REQUISITE
EXPERTISE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER ANNUALLY. EACH YEAR
THOUSANDS OF THESE CANCER
PATIENTS ARE EITHER
MISDIAGNOSED PLACED IN
TREATMENT REGIMENS.
INAPPROPRIATE OR INEFFECTIVE
FOR THEIR CONDITION. AND
ABSTRACT PERCET OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CLINICAL
ONCOLOGY REPORTED THAT ABOUT
55% OF CANCER PATIENTS
CALIFORNIA. DO NOT RECEIVE CARE
THAT'S CONSISTENT CLINICAL
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED BY THE
NATIONAL CANCER INSTITUTE
CANCER NETWORKS. OF CANCER
SCIENCE ADVANCES MORE EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS CHILLERS ARE
AVAILABLE THERE'S A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THOSE ADVANCES AND
PENSION ACCESS TO GOOD QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. THE CAN SAVE LIVES.
CANCER CURES INVOLVING AND THIS
REQUIRES ONGOING ACCESS FOR
PATIENTS TO THE MOST RECENT
THERAPEUTICS AND CARE
TECHNOLOGY. THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LIMITED OR DELAYED ACCESS TO
PICK UP YOUR TREATMENTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT. WE NOT ONLY TO
MISDIAGNOSIS. IT'LL TO
MISTREATMENT THAT CAN LEAD TO
UNEXPECTED UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE
TO TOXIC CHEMOTHERAPY SUFFERING
ONE PREVENTABLE DEATH. MANY
CANCER PATIENTS CALIFORNIA- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOR NOT BASED
UPON CURRENT CAN DOCTOR. AND
MANY OF THESE ARE STORE CLEAN
UNDER COULD WELL LIKE TO HAVE
FORCED OUTCOMES AND TREAT THE
DR THAT PARKS GUIDE. TWO TWENTY
TO THIRTY PROTECT USING.
MEDICAL BENEFICIARIES WERE ALSO
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE WORSE
SURVIVAL OUTCOMES AND GAPS CARE
BASED UPON THE NEED TO IMPROVE
CANCER CARE EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA A COALITION OF
PATIENT ADVOCACY GROUPS
PROVIDERS HAVE COME TOGETHER
WITH THE SUPPORT OF SENATOR
RUBIO TO DEVELOP A CANCER
PATIENT BILL OF RIGHTS.
DEMONSTRATING THAT'S YOUR
ELEVEN HAVE YOU PROVED OUTCOMES
COULD BE ATTRIBUTED TO
PARTICIPATION IN CLINICAL
TRIALS AS WELL UNFORTUNATELY
ONLY 8% OF CANCER PATIENTS
EVER. PARTICIPATE IN A CLINICAL
TRIAL THIS IS NOT DRIVEN BY
CHOICE ONCE WAS PREVIOUSLY
BELIEVED REVIEW INVOLVING
RESEARCHERS FROM COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY. AND THE AMERICAN
CANCER SOCIETY. NOT SPAULDING
NINE THOUSAND CANCER PATIENTS
AND FOUND THAT OVER HALF OF
PATIENTS. HAVE A CLINICAL TRIAL
AVAILABLE TO THEM AFTER
INSTITUTION. ONE AVAILABLE A
MAJORITY OF CANCER PATIENTS
FIFTY FIVE POINT 1% TO CREATE A
PRETTY BIG CLINICAL TRIALS. WE
BELIEVE THAT YOUR ELEVEN
HIGHLIGHTS THE ETHNIC AND
SOCIOECONOMIC DISPARITIES IN
CANCER OUTCOMES AND PROMOTE
ACCESS TO CUTTING EDGE
TREATMENTS AND CLINICAL TRIALS.
FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE AND DISADVANTAGED
CANCER PATIENT. APPRECIATE
SENATOR RUBIO'S LEADERSHIP IN
ADVOCATING FOR CANCER PATIENTS
CALIFORNIA AND WE VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORTER INTRODUCTION OF THIS.
YEAR ELEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT WITNESS- COMMA
MCDOWELL. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
I NO LONGER SEE COME ON THE
LINE- COME WITH YOUR ON THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AND WILL OPEN UP YOUR
PHONE LINE FOR YOU. ONCE AGAIN
A COMMON IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
WILL OPEN UP YOUR PHONE LINE
FOR YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
SHOWING UP AND I DON'T SEE
COMIC LINE ON THE PHONE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ALL RIGHT
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE THEN- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. C. NINE
THIS OF BOB MOVE MOTION TO BE A
MOTION IS WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SECOND BY MISS
WALDRON- THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPTED THIS BE ADOPTED- THE
DOESN'T ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL HAVE- THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION TO BE ADOPTED-
MOTION MADE BY MR RODRIGUEZ A
SECOND BY MISTER. MISS WALDRON
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE.
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I
REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT IS
OUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON SO. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
CENTER WHERE YOU HAVE SB THREE
EIGHTY. WORDS WE DON'T SEE IN
FRONT OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
VERY OFTEN COMMERCIAL FISHING
OF DUNGENESS CRAB ROCK CRAB
EVISCERATION PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- I'M ONE OF
THINGS THAT WE REALLY HOPE IS
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
FLOUNDER TODAY IN COMMITTEE SO-
BROUGH. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANNA TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR INTO HIS AMAZING TEAM
FOR THE WORK ON THIS AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY RIGHT MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS AN ABNORMAL BILL BUT-
HEALTH DOES PLAY INTO
ESPECIALLY THE TESTING NEARLY
ALL OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
COME TO US FROM THE DUNGENESS
CRAB TASK FORCE THE LEGISLATIVE
MANDATED ADVISORY BODY- THAT
BRINGS FORWARD RECOMMENDATIONS
EACH AND EVERY YEAR- TO THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES
AND AQUACULTURE AND THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION SB EIGHTY
HAS A BROAD SUPPORT. AT
COALITION FROM BOTH INDUSTRIES
ROTH ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WE HAVE MIKE
CONROY ON THE PHONE TODAY HE'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT- LUCAS
PRACTICES WITH US WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND AGAIN
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I DON'T RESEARCHER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER MCGUIRE- WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
YEAH CONFIRMING YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS OF THE
MY NAME IS MIKE CONROY AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION.
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT SENATE BILL
EIGHTY. THIS BILL WOULD IMPROVE
SAFETY OF THE STATE'S
COMMERCIAL CRABBERS AND THEIR
COMMERCIAL FISHING VESSELS AT
SEA. BY ALLOWING THEM TO SET
THEIR YEARS SIXTY FOUR HOURS
BEFORE THE OPENING OF THE
FISHING SEASON. WITH A LOSS OF
MULTIPLE FISHING VESSELS AND
LIVES ON THE WEST COAST IN
RECENT YEARS TAKING ACTIONS
THAT CAN IMPROVE OUR MEMBERS
SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT. AND
INCREASED PRE SOAK PERIOD FOR
THE DUNGENESS CRAB FISHING
GROUNDS WILSHIRE FISHERMEN ARE
FOR THE FLEXIBILITY TO DEPLOY
THEIR FISHING GEAR IN RESPONSE
VARIABLE WEATHER CONDITIONS.
RATHER THAN BEING FORCED TO GO
OUT WITHOUT REGARD TO THE CITY
STATE. THIS INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY WILL IMPROVE SAFETY
AND SAVE LIVES. SB EIGHTY
PROVIDES SOLUTIONS THAT MAY
HAVE BEEN BETTER THAT HAVE BEEN
VETTED AND RECOMMENDED TO YOU
BY THE DENTIST CRAP TASK FORCE
A LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED BODY
TASKED TO ADVISE THE
LEGISLATURE ON SUCH ITEMS. THIS
BILL GREATLY BENEFITS FISHERMAN
AND IS BROADLY SUPPORTED BY
INDUSTRY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE TO VOTE ON SB
EIGHTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY. MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LOOK AS FOR
HOW MAP THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTY. OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
HAS PARTNERED CLOSELY WITH
COMMERCIAL BUDGETS CRAFTER
SHERMAN INCLUDING SUPPORT OF
AND PARTICIPATION THE DUNGEONS
CRIME TASK FORCE. ONGOING
SUPPORT OF THIS CORPORATE BODY
IS CRITICAL INCLUDING THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD THE DIGEST GRAB
PASSPORT HIS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ENABLE THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
RESTORATION OPTION IT SAMPLING
REQUIREMENTS. RECENT OCCURRENCE
AND SEVERITY OF ELEVATED DOMOIC
ACID LEVELS IS ONE OF THE MANY
CLIMBING DRIVING OCEAN CHANGES
IMPACTING FISHERIES BECAUSE OF
THEM THEY DEPEND ON. THE
FEDERATION OPTION WILL GIVE
MANAGERS THE ABILITY TO
MITIGATE IMPACT THE DEMO AYE
CAPTAIN DELAYS ON THE
COMMERCIAL DUNGENESS CRAB.
MICHAEL TO RESPOND TO CHANGING
OCEAN AND FISHERY CONDITION. SB
EIGHTY SAMPLING REQUIREMENT
WILL MAYOR REQUIREMENTS IN
OREGON WASHINGTON. IMPROVE
CERTAINTY IN STOCK ASSESSMENTS
AND SUPPORT MORE DATA
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS UNDER
CHANGING OCEAN CONDITIONS. THE
OBJECTIVES OUTLINED IN SPDR ARE
ALIGNED WITH HIM HE'D OWN
CONSERVATION GOALS WE
APPRECIATE CENTER REQUIRED
CONTINUEDLEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
EIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL MOVE TO THE FRONT IS
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY HERE. I
SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU RECOMMEND
IF YOU IF YOU DID NOT AGAIN. IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE. OF
MISTRUSTED PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES BEFORE I MESS IT UP
ANYMORE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OF
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN Q. OPEN LINE NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY APOLOGIES- HERE TO
SPEAK I WAS HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF S. B. RO ELEVEN BUT I
DROPPED OFF THE CALL. MY
APOLOGIES. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OPEN MY NUMBER TWO FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
CRAIG OUT YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTEEN MEMBERS OF THE
TRINIDAD BAY FISHMAN'S
MARKETING ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
OTHER CALLERS BUT- BUT THE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND SO WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
SPEAKING ON THE BILL. VERY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
A- HUMOR IN ME AND- AND I'M
THROWING IT RIGHT BACK I
APPRECIATE THAT. WE BOTH KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THE CRAB INDUSTRY
IS TO THE NORTH COAST AND HOW
MUCH WE ALL ENJOYED AND SO.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL
AND- MAKES IT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO IMPORT OUR
FISHERIES IMPORTANT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO CONSUME THESE
PRODUCTS SO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THIS ONE TO
SAY THANK YOU- IT SET AN HONOR
TO BE TO WORK WITH THIS AND
WOULD EACH EVERY DAY AND THE
NORTH COAST AT HE IS A STAUNCH
ADVOCATE. FOR NOT JUST THE
CABIN INDUSTRY BUT THE FISHING
COMMUNITIES IN GENERAL-
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I DON'T THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
SOMETIMES I JUST FLOUNDER ALONG
TWO ZERO HANNAH SO- OF- THERE
WAS A WITNESS THERE WAS A
WITNESS THAT WE HAD A WITNESS
TO- THERE. WAS A MOTION AND
THERE WAS A SECOND I DON'T.
KNOW WHO DID IT SO. MR
BIGELOW'S MOTION. THE SECOND BY
MR RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS- I DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS ABOUT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOOD HI WHAT I MAYES. MAYES
EYEING AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE
I AM CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
YOUR BILLS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STATUS IMAGES
YOU'RE THINKING THAT HAS DRIVEN
HUNDREDS. MOVING ON NOW TO ITEM-NUMBER SEVEN- SENATOR PAM SB.
FIVE TEN. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK ME TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
DELETE QUOTE UNVACCINATED QUOTE
IN THE DEFINITIONS OF SCREENING
AND DIAGNOSTIC TESTING AND MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT PLANS ARE NOT
RELIEVED OF COMPLYING WITH
FEDERAL LAW AND GUIDANCE. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE JULY SIX AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN TO TE FINE
DIAGNOSTIC AND SCREENING
TESTING BASED ON CDC GUIDELINES
MAYBE MORE LIMITING THAN
INTENDED INTENT IS TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE UNDER THE- FCRA AND
THE CARES ACT MORE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOUR STAFF
WILL BE NECESSARY TO REDEFINE
THESE DEFINITIONS. IN FACT- I
BELIEVE A MOCK UP TO SENT TO
THE STAFF CORRECT ANSWER SB
FIVE TEN REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO COVER COVER
NINETEEN TESTING AND
VACCINATION WITHOUT COST
SHARING A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FROM BOTH IN NETWORK AND OUT NO
OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDERS DURING
THE FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THESE PROTECTIONS
REMAIN FOR IN NETWORK TESTING
AND VACCINES FOLLOWING THE
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THIS BILL ALSO
PROHIBITS BALANCE BILLING FOR
PROVIDERS FOR KOBE NINETEEN
TESTING IMMUNIZATIONS EVEN
AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY EXPIRES. LASTLY WE
CAN ALREADY TAKE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
PUT A FRAMEWORK IN PLACE THAT
ALLOW FEDERALLY APPROVED
TESTING ANY MUSICIANS WITH NO
COST SHARING FOR A FUTURE
PANDEMIC. WELL WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS WE ARE
STILL WORKING TOWARD
VACCINATING MORE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE GENERAL
FOCUS AND PRIORITIES ARE
ENSURING EVERYONE CAN GET
VACCINE WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF
ENSURING EVERYONE ALSO HAS.
ACCESS TO COVER NINETEEN
TESTING AND VACCINATIONS WITH
NO OUT OF POCKET COSTS THAT'S
WHY SB FIVE TEN IS NEEDED NOW
THERE NEEDS TO BE CONSISTENT
CLEAR LAWS REGARDING COVER
NINETEEN TESTING AND
IMMUNIZATIONS PROTECT
CONSUMERS. BUT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE
AND LEAVE US WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SENATOR PAN WE'LL GO TO OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE- WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY OPERATOR PLEASE. OPEN THE
LINES FOR THE WITNESSES. ALL
LANES ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I'M MORE
PROUD SPONSORS OF SB FIVE TEN
WHICH REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH TESTING
ACTIVATION AND RELATED SERVICES
TO PREVENT OR MITIGATE A
PANDEMIC DISEASES SUCH AS
CHOLERA NINETEEN WITH NO COST
SHARING FOR PATIENTS OR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY GOVERNANCE AND DECLARED
A STATE OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
VEHICLE THAT NINETEEN P.
DEMOCRATIC EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND HELP
BEGIN THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
COVER NINETEEN. IN ORDER TO
ENCOURAGE TESTING TREATMENT AND
VACCINATIONS FEDERAL AND STATE
POLICIES HAVE BEEN ADOPTED TO
MANDATE PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE WITHOUT COST
SHARING AND MANY DIRECTIVES
HAVE BEEN ISSUED TO EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS AND DEPARTMENTAL
GUIDANCE. CDI PUBLISHED
GUIDANCE OUTLINING REQUIREMENTS
ON INSURERS REQUIRING INSURERS
TO COVER TESTING AND SCREENING
REGARDLESS OF NETWORK STATUS
AND ENSURE HER RESPONSIBLE FOR
PAYMENT OF THE WAY FOR COST
SHARING AMOUNTS PROVIDERS. BY
CONTRAST THE GMAC RELEASED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WHICH
CREATED A TIER SYSTEM BASED ON
WHETHER A PATIENT HAS SYMPTOMS
OR THEIR EMPLOYMENT SECTOR AND
SCATTERS WHEREBY THERE WERE
DIFFERENT CRITERIA FOR TESTING
LG BILITY WHETHER PATIENT COST
SHARING IS ALLOWED AND WHETHER
TO PAY PRIOR AUTHORIZATION MAY
BE REQUIRED FOR EACH TIER.
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WERE
LATER REPEALED AND REPLACED
WITH A MORE STREAMLINED WITH A
MORE STREAMLINED APPROACH BUT
STILL INCONSISTENT WITH PDI AND
SOME FEDERAL GUIDANCE. SB FIVE
TEN IF NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
THE FEDERAL STANDARD AT A
MINIMUM IS MAINTAINED ACROSS
HEALTHCARE REGULATORS IN
CALIFORNIA THE PATIENT CAN
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED IN A
TIMELY FASHION WITH NO OUT OF
POCKET COSTS AND PHYSICIANS MAY
RECEIVE FAIR AND REASONABLE
CONGRESS COMPENSATION FOR THE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE IT
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEENTH
ENDEMIC. THE QUESTION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL ALSO
POLITICAL THE NINETEEN TAX THAT
SUGGESTIONS PERFORM. FOR
DIAGNOSTIC AND SCREENING
PURPOSES. COVERED CONTINUES TO
NEEDED MONITOR AND CONTROL THE
SPREAD OF DISEASE MY- ANY. THAT
EXIST ON OUR PER FOR DIAGNOSE
AND HEALTH. I SB FIVE TEN LOCAL
US FOR FUTURE OP BUT BUILDING
ON MY SKIN LEARNT YOUR- AND
SETTING COVER I'M NOT REQUIRED
TO FOR TESTING ON THE TO MAKE
SURE. AT A TIME WHEN HEALTH IN
A HAVE LAID BARE IN OUR CARE TO
LOW JUST. SB FIVE TENANTS ALL
PAGE HAVE ACCESS TO THANK
COVERAGE COKE. VACCINATION
TESTING. DEMAND BONTA THE
SIMPLE MEASURE WHEN I
RESPECTFUL REQUEST YOUR I.
BUILT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE
ON TO A NEXT WITNESS IN SOME.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER DIANA DOUGLAS FOR HEALTH
ACT THE CALIFORNIA THE
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIV TEN SB FIVE
HUNDRED ELIMINATE THE BURDENS
OF COST SHARING AND PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION ASSOCIATED WITH
CUP IN NINETEEN TESTING AND
VACCINATION FOR CALIFORNIANS IN
THE COMMERCIAL HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET. COMBINATION OF FEDERAL
AND STATE LEVEL GUIDANCE AND
REGULATORY ACTION PATHWAYS
CONTOURING FOR COCA NINETEEN
TESTING AN IMMUNIZATION HOWEVER
THE PATCHWORK OF POLICIES THAT
OFTEN BEEN INCONSISTENT AND
PROVEN CONFUSING FOR CONSUMERS
BUT COVERAGE FOR CAPPING
PREVIOUSLY BASED ON A WEB OF
CONFUSING FACTORS INCLUDING
OCCUPATION EXPOSURE AND
SYMPTOMS. DESPITE LATER
CLARIFICATIONS ON COVERAGE AND
INCREASED CONSISTENCY AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN
UNDERSTANDABLY CONFUSED ABOUT
WHAT THEY MIGHT OVER LATER
PEOPLE IF THEY GET TESTED FOR
OR VACCINATED AGAINST COPA
NINETEEN. THE VACCINES ARE
THANKFULLY WIDELY AVAILABLE
THESE DAYS IS STILL MUCH WORK
TO BE DONE TO GET MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED AND BRING US CLOSER
TO FULL COMMUNITY IMMUNITY WE
CANNOT AFFORD FOR VACCINE
ACCESS TO BE HAMPERED BY
CONFUSION OVER COST SHARING
OBLIGATIONS OR BY THE NEED TO
FIND IN NETWORK PROVIDERS.
SPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIANS ARE
MOST VULNERABLE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY SB FIVE TEN WILL HELP
CLEAR FINE ASSURE CALIFORNIANS
THAT WHEN THEY NEED TESTING IT
WILL BE COVERED NO MATTER WHAT.
WHEN THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET IMMUNIZED THEY CAN JUMP
ON THAT CHANCE WITHOUT WORRIES
ABOUT WHO WILL PAY. THE BILL
ALSO ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK THAT
WE WON'T HAVE A REPLAY OF THE
CONFUSION WE FACED OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF ON THE
OFFENSIVE FUTURE PANDEMIC. FOR
THESE REASONS HEALTH ACCESS
SUPPORTS SB FIVE TEN IN
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR EYES
OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE TO. IN OFF. SO
WHEN THEY READY- JEFF HOW. AND
STEPHANIE WALKEN'S WHENEVER
YO'RE READY PLEASE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE GEN HAMPER CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND
THE REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TEN
ELECTED AMENDED. WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER ENGAGING WITH
UP ON THE BILL. FIRST WE WANT
TO SAY THAT OUR NUMBER HEALTH
PLANS ARE STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AND
EVEN PRIOR TO THE FEDELI AT THE
FEDERALLY ISSUED PUBLIC HEALTH
GOTTEN MANY OF OUR MEMBERS WERE
TAKING PREEMPTIVE DESPITE OF
ACTION. TO HELP CURB IS RADICAL
THE NINETEEN. THROUGHOUT THE
LAST YEAR A HALF HELP ME THE
WORK IN. WITH PROVIDER AND
REGULATORS ENSURE THAT THE
TESTING IDENTIFIED UNIVERSALLY.
AND CONSISTENTLY EVEN WHEN I
DIED HAS SHIFTED. HOWEVER WE
ARE STRONGLY CONCERNED SB FIVE
AND WOULD RETROACTIVELY FORCED
HEALTH PLANS TO COMPLY WITH A
NEW STANDARD THAT WAS NOT IN
EFFECT ON MARCH FOURTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. WE BELIEVE THAT
RETROACTIVELY FORTY HELP PLANT
COMPLY WITH THE LAW THAT WAS
NOT IN EFFECT AT THE TIME IT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY BAD HOLD PUBLIC
POLICY. MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE RETROACTIVITY
PROVISIONS OUTLINED IN THE CELL
OF VIOLATE THE CONTRACT CLAUSE.
IN ARTICLE ONE SECTION NINE OF
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND
ARTICLE ONE SECTION TEN OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION. THE
STATE OR FEDERAL CONSTITUTION
EXPLICITLY CLEAR. THAT A LOT
IMPAIRING EXISTING CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS TO THEM
CONSTITUTIONAL. SB FIVE TEN IN
ITS CURRENT FORM SHIFT THE COST
TO COVER NINETY TESTING RELATED
SEARCHES THE PLAN. EVEN MORE A
PRE EXISTING CONTRACT REQUIRES
THE PROVIDER TO COVER THAT COST.
THE US THE BILL EFFECTIVELY
NULLIFIED. EXISTING AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN PLAN PROVIDERS WHERE MY
PROVIDER TACKY TRACK. WHICH I
ACTUALLY AGREED TO PAY FOR THE
COST OF DIAGNOSTIC TESTING. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE COST SHIFTING
MANDATE NINETY FIVE AND- I AM
PROVIDER CONTRACTS WHICH
DELEGATE TO THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER THE RESPONSIBILITY
PAYING THE COVER NINETEEN
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING RELATED
SERVICES. DELEGATION OF
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITIES
CONTAINED IN PLAN PROVIDER
CONTRACT INCLUDING CAPTIVE
ARRANGEMENT IT'S PART OF A
CAREFULLY BALANCED ALLOCATION
ARREST AT THE CENTRAL TO THE
PROPER FUNCTIONING OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT FEEL UPSET
THIS ARRANGEMENT AND RESPECT
THE REQUESTED RETROACTIVITY
PROVISION BE REMOVED FROM THE
BILL. AMONG OTHER THINGS WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE FIVE
TEN YEARS RETROACTIVELY
OBLIGATE PLANT INSURERS
REIMBURSE PROVIDERS ON THE
POTENTIALLY LAW COST SHARE FROM
THE START OF THE OF THAT.
GENERALLY CLEAR PUBLIC HELP
MAKE AMERICAN THING. WE
UNDERSTAND IS EMERGENCY HAS
CREATED FINANCIAL CHALLENGES%
FOR SOME PROVIDER PRACTICE
WHICH IS WHY HEALTH PLAN SET UP
MEET THE MOMENT BY PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDERS WHERE
FEASIBLE INAPPROPRIATE. HOWEVER
WE. ARE UNCLEAR HOW THIS
SPECIFIC PROVISION WOULD. ACT
WORK IN THE CONFINES OF THE
STATE LAW. PLEASE RE THE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THAT FIVE
LETTERS. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YEAH OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. NUMBER
SEVEN WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF OUR
THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS WITH WITH
RESPECT SB FIVE TEN. LIKE ECHO
MY COLLEAGUES' COMMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF APPLYING
THE BILL RETROACTIVELY. AS WELL
AS HIGHLIGHT FOR USE AND
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS WE HAVE
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT SB FIVE TEN DOES NOT
ESTABLISH A CLEAR METHODOLOGY
FOR REIMBURSING OUT OF NETWORK
PROVIDERS. AND IT'S ALSO
INCONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL LAW.
THE BILL REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO REIMBURSE OUT
OF NETWORK PROVIDERS FOR ALL
TESTING ITEMS OR SERVICES AT A
REASONABLE RATE HOWEVER FEDERAL
LAW DICTATES THAT THERE IS NO
NEGOTIATED RATE. BUDGETS FOR
OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT IS AT THE CASH
PRICE UNLESS THE PLAN
NEGOTIATED A LOWER RATE WITH
THE PROVIDER. THE KERR EFFECT
REQUIRES PROVIDERS TO POST THE
CASH PRICE TAG ON THEIR PUBLIC
WEBSITE. AND AUTHORIZES THE
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO IMPOSE IN MONETARY
PENALTY OF UP TO THREE DOLLARS
PER DAY. ON ANY PROVIDER WHO
FAILED TO DO SO. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS CRITICAL THAT A
REASONABLE MARKET BASED PRICING
BENCHMARK BE ESTABLISHED FOR
CAT MINISTER OUT OF NETWORK. TO
ENSURE AGAINST PRICE GOUGING
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY HAS BEEN A
FAIRLY COMMON OCCURRENCE SINCE.
THE BEGINNING OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. FURTHERMORE
WE BELIEVE PROVISIONS ADDRESS
FUTURE. CONTAINED IN THIS BILL.
WE DID NOT KNOW WHAT. WHEN OR
WHERE THE NEXT GLOBAL TOWN
PANDEMIC BOOKER AND STATUTORILY
DEFINING PARAMETERS FOR FUTURE
PANDEMIC WITHOUT ANY KNOWLEDGE
OF WHAT TESTING PRACTICES
TREATMENT OPTIONS ARE VACCINES
AVAILABILITY IS. IS CERTAINLY
TROUBLESOME AND COULD
ULTIMATELY COMPLICATE ANY
FUTURE RESPONSES. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AND PRANKS THAT
RESPECTFULLY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED THE
BILL. FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES THOSE
ARE IN I'M SORRY FOR SOMEONE IN
THE- IN THE GALLERY LIKE TO SAY
IS JUST YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE. YEAH
MICROBES ON BEHALF OF QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- JUST IN WANTED TO
COMMENT ON THE FACT THAT A
DOCTOR PAN IS PRETTY-
SUPPORTING DR PANDA'S
PRESENTATION THE KNOWLEDGE AND-
SOME SOME CONCERNS ON WITH THE
JULY SIX AMENDMENTS AND THE
MEMBERS HE OFFERED UP TODAY-
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM AND- YOU COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS. ON ON THIS IS IT'S
GOING FORWARD THANKS OKAY THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND WILL BE ASKING
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL. AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN INCH YOU WILL START WITH
MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH ONE VEHICLE
ACCORDING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE THREE OH TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A BRAMBLE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS DAVID
GONZALEZ CITY ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS WOULD OCCUR THE KOMETS
CAPTAIN APPLICANT CONTINUE TO
BE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
PRINT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. BEFORE WE OPEN LINE
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY TWO AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
THREE EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MITAC WOULDN'T NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BOTH WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ALSO SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL VERY
WELL THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MMHM WE HAVE MOTION FOR MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. IN FOR A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISS BURKE HOW MUCH
WOULD BE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE BILL DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WHICH I CLOSE SENATOR PAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD
I WOULD I MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO. FLORA CARILLO
III. FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RIVAS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON. SEVEN ONE
SEVEN ONE USED YOUR ONE VOTE
SHORT WE HAVE MEMBERS MISSING
SO- WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WANT
TO SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AS AREMINDER AS PART EARLIER
COMMENTS THIS IS POOR
PRESENTATION OF AND TESTIMONY
ONLY NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN
TODAY AND WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
CENTER ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT. THE BILL THAT'S
ABOUT PATIENT ADHERENCE TO
PRESCRIBED COVERED MEDICATIONS
IT'S ALSO ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE DIABETES
HIGH CHOLESTEROL ARTHRITIS. AND
MANY OTHER DISEASES AS WELL
SOME MORE RARE THAT REQUIRE
ONGOING MEDICATION AND FOR SOME
SUPPLIES IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
CHRONIC CONDITION UNDER
CONTROL. THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
IN MANY FORTY ARE HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH PLANS. THE
THERE ARE PLANS OF MEDICAL
DEDUCTIBLES WELL OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED- DOLLARS. AND PHARMACY
DEDUCTIBLES OVER FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHICH MEANS THE PENDING
ON THE BENEFIT DESIGN PATIENTS
MUST PAY EVERY YEAR ALL MEDICAL
PHARMACY EXPENSES UP TO THE
DEDUCTIBLE. BEFORE THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO PAY COPAYS FOR
COVERED SERVICES. FACT
ACCORDING TO THE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION AN AVERAGE PERSON
WILL HIT THEIR DEDUCTIBLE IN
LATE MAY WHICH MEANS THEY WILL
PAY OUT OF POCKET FOR SERVICES
FOR THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF
THE YEAR BEFORE THEIR PLAN
BENEFITS KICK IN. A PERSON WITH
ONE OR MORE CHRONIC CONDITIONS
MAY MEET THEIR DEDUCTIBLE
SOONER BUT THEY STILL HAVE TO
GO FOR A PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT
ACTUALLY SEEING THEIR PLAN
BENEFITS MEANING THEY ARE
PAYING OUT OF POCKET. FOR THE
ENTIRE COST OF THE MEDICATION.
AND OF THE OUT OF THE MONEY.
THEN FORTUNATELY THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET THE MEDICATION.
SONJI SIMILAR TO BEING
UNINSURED BEGINNING. MANY
STUDIES SHOW THAT PATIENT NOT
ADHERENCE TO PRESCRIBE
MEDICATION LEADS TO POOR
THERAPEUTIC OUTCOMES
INTROGRESSION DISEASE THAT'S
ESTIMATED TO BE BILLIONS IN
AVOIDABLE HEALTH CARE COST. AND
CERTAINLY OF COURSE IN ADDITION
TO THE FINANCIAL COST THE
HEALTH COSTS AS WELL IN
SOCIETAL COSTS. ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE IMMEDIATE SO THE
EXPENSE ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASING ADHERENCE MAY NOT BE
THE BIGGEST CONCERN. FOR SOME
PLAYERS HOWEVER THERE'S
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THE
LONG TERM COSTS THE POOR
OUTCOMES EXCEEDS THE COST
MEDICATIONS MANY CHRONIC
ILLNESSES. BACK IT'S BEEN
ESTIMATED A HUNDRED TO THREE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS OF
AVOIDABLE HEALTHCARE COSTS HAVE
BEEN ATTRIBUTED TO NOT
ADHERENCE IN THE UNITED STATES
ANNUALLY REPRESENTING 3210% OF
TOTAL. YOU HEALTHCARE COSTS.
REDUCING OUT OF POCKET COSTS
LEAD TO BETTER MEDICATION
ADHERENCE CROSS MANY DIAGNOSES
IN FACT THERE'S A LINEAR
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF PATIENT COST
SHARING IN THE LEVEL OF
EXPERIENCE. I KNOWLEDGE OF THE
TO BERMAN ALICE'S ESTIMATES A
SIGNIFICANT COSTS BUT- IT
THAT'S F. BUT ALSO ESTIMATES A
HUNDRED TWO MILLION DOLLARS
REDUCED COST SHARING FOR PEOPLE
CRIED DISEASE. BECAUSE THE
BILL. STATE COVERS OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED MEDICATIONS TO BURKE
DID NOT HAVE TIME TO COME UP
WITH AN OFFSETTING ESTIMATE SO
THE NET COST INDIA ANALYSIS IS
LIKELY INFLATED. ADDITIONALLY
AS I MENTIONED MANY OF THE COST
SAVINGS OCCUR OVER TIME AND NOT
NECESSARY IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
WHICH IS WHEN. THE TROOPER WHAT
DID YOU BIRTH ESTIMATE INCLUDES
UNDER REPORT. AS A REMINDER
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
COPAYS ELIMINATES THE
DEDUCTIBLE. THAT UP FRONT COST
FOR CHRONIC DISEASE MEDICATIONS
AND SOME SUPPLIES. PATIENTS
WILL STILL HAVE TO PAY COPAYS
AND THEY'RE PUT PLANTS CAN
STILL USE COPAYS AS A MATTER OF
MINUTES. METHOD OF CONTROLLING
UTILIZATION. YEAH I DO I
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD. I'D
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD WITH-
THE CHAIR- SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
WERE REQUESTED- FIRST OF ALL-
IN ORDER TO NARROW THE BILL- E
HAVE TO IT I'M WILLING TO
ACCEPT AMENDMENT THAT THIS
WOULD ONLY APPLY TO GROUP
PLANS. NOT TO INDIVIDUAL PLANS
PEOPLE HAVE A CHOICE NOT TO
HAVE A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLAN.
WHERE IS IN A GROUP PLAN THEY
MAY BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY CAN ONLY GET A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PLAN THAT'S THE ONLY
ONE THAT'S OFFERED. AND IN FACT
BECAUSE IF THAT'S WHAT'S
OFFERED TO THEM AND THAT'S THE
ONLY CHOICE THEY HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATELY THEY CANNOT GO OFF
THE CALVET CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY WOULD NO LONGER GET THE
SUBSIDY TO PURCHASE THAT'S A
FOUR EIGHT LOWER INCOME WORKER-
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM COVERED CALIFORNIA
TO PERHAPS FROM. A PURCHASE A
PLAN THAT DOESN'T HAVE A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE THEY WOULD HAVE THAT
SUBSIDY IN THEIR STOCK WITH THE
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLAN. IN
ADDITION I ALSO AGREED TO A
SUNSET SO WE CAN SEE THE IMPACT
I BELIEVE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOR YOUR SUNSET IN AN
EVALUATION OF THE IMPACT OF THE
BILL. THE PLACE WHERE I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY- WE REMAINED AND
DISAGREEMENT IS- THE IDEA OF
ACTUALLY SELECTING DISEASES-
THAT WOULD COVER FOR THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE THAT- THERE'S
A DESIRE TO AGAIN. TRY TO
REDUCE THE- PERHAPS THE COST OF
THE BILL BUT I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT. WHEN I. STARTED THIS
BILL. BOTH THE SUPPORTERS BUT
INCLUDING THE OPPOSITION TO
HEALTH PLANS WHO ARE AND FORTY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. HAVE BOTH
EXPRESSED TO ME THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO APPROACH. CHRONIC
DISEASE MEDICATION DEDUCTIBLES
ON THE DISEASE BY DISEASE BASIS
THEY WANTED A POLICY THAT CAR
CUT ACROSS. FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROBLEM AND AGAIN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE CRIED DISEASES.
WHO NEED TO BE ON THEIR
MEDICATION AND NOR TO KEEP
THEMSELVES HEALTHIER SO THEY
DON'T HAVE EXACERBATIONS. AND
IT IS. TREMENDOUSLY CHALLENGING
TO SAY WELL THEN WHICH DISEASES
AND CERTAINLY YOU HAVE BEEN
OFFERED SAY WELL WHY WE PICKED
THE TOP FOUR FIVE YOU KNOW THE
CDC. BUT THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE. MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION SO WHAT ABOUT SOMEONE
SCHIZOPHRENIA. WHO NEEDS THEIR
MEDICATION SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE A STABLE HOME
AND GO TO WORK SO THAT THE
HOUSE ACTIVATIONS ARE SOME OF
BI POLAR. WHAT ABOUT AIDS
PATIENTS. WHO ARE WHO ARE HIV
PATIENTS WHO NEED TO HAVE WHO
ARE CHRONIC MEDICATIONS TO
CONTROL HIV. WHAT ABOUT SOMEONE
WHO HAS A NEUROLOGICAL
CONDITION THAT AGAIN REQUIRES
ONGOING TREATMENT FOR THEM OR
FOR THEM NOT ONLY OF COURSE TO
TREAT THEIR CONDITION BUT ALSO
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE TO
FUNCTION. AND EVEN HOLD THE JOB
SO WE CAN'T THERE'S NUMEROUS
CONDITIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AT THAT OFFICE THE SAME PROBLEM
IS THAT IF YOU'RE IN A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PLAN. IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE CASH ON HAND S IF
YOU'RE TO LOOK AT LOWER WAGE
WORKER. AND THE ONLY CHOICE YOU
HAVE A HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLAN
THAT HAS A HIGH. PHARMACY
COPAY. THEN ESSENTIALLY YOU ARE
OUT OF LUCK IN TERMS OF BEING
ABLE TO PAY FOR YOUR MEDICATION
TELL YOU SAVE ENOUGH MONEY. AND
INSTEAD WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT
YOU STOP TAKING YOUR
MEDICATION. AND WITH ALL THE
CHARACTERS THAT COME INCLUDING
BY THE WAY MAYBE ACTUALLY COVER
YOUR DEDUCTIBLE BECAUSE YOU END
UP IN THE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
ROOM. AND NOW YOU FIND YOURSELF
SPENDING SO MUCH NOW YOUR
PASTOR DEDUCTIBLE. I THINK THAT
IS NOT THE PRO TO UNDERTAKE- WE
WENT AHEAD AND THINK ABOUT HOW
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY HAD BEEN
OPEN AND APPRECIATE DISCUSSION
THEY HAD ABOUT THINKING ABOUT
HOW DO WE- NARROW THE BILL BUT-
I ALSO DON'T WANT TO TAKE A
DISEASE BY DISEASE APPROACH AND
THAT IS SOMETHING BOTH AS I
SAID THE HEALTH PLANS. AND THE
DELTA OF THE SUPPORTERS IS
SPELLED PEOPLE CONTENT THIS
COMMUNITY DON'T WANT AS WELL.
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS WE
SHOULD COME OF THE POLICY THAT
APPLIES. ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
ANYONE WHO'S IN THAT TYPE OF
SITUATION SO WITH THAT AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE BILL- I HOPE THAT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
THAT TO ALSO IN ADDITION TO
DEBATING THE BILL TO TRY TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD. AND
WITH THAT- I GUESS I WILL NOT
BE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO VOTE BUT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE- WITNESSES. WITNESSES TO BE
ABLE. TO TESTIFY AS WELL ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE. WITNESSES
IN SOME- AND- PLEASE- WE HAVE
THE OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IN A LETTER OPENER.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'LL GO AHEAD
AND START SO- AFTERNOON THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY COMMENTS-
MY NAME'S KANTOR WE CAN SHARE
THE PARTNERSHIP TO FIGHT
CHRONIC DISEASE. APPIA CD. A
MAJOR FOCUS OF PFPT ADDRESSING
BARRIERS TO ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS
IN THOSE AT RISK. BUT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT DOES IT REMEDY IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
LIVING WITH ONE OR MORE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. BOB NEEDING HIGHER
DEDUCTIBLES BEFORE GETTING
COVERAGE FOR PRESCRIPTION
MEDICINES THEY NEED TO MAINTAIN
THEIR HEALTH. BUT AS YOU JUST
HEARD THAT MORE CENTER PAN TALK
ABOUT- THE HIGHER DEDUCTIBLES.
THE REALITY ISN'T IN
CALIFORNIA- THE AVERAGE
DEDUCTIBLES ARE MUCH HIGHER
THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER INDIVIDUAL FOR TWENTY FOUR
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
FAMILY. AS A HYPER TO THE
PEOPLE LIVING WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS FACE EACH YEAR. I WE
KNOW FROM ECONOMIC STUDIES THAT
HIGH OUT OF POCKET COSTS
MEDICATIONS NEGATIVELY AFFECT
MEDICATION ADHERENCE. SUPPORT
HERE PLEASE WHO AFFORDABLE
COMPLICATIONS. INCREASE THE OUR
VISITS HOSPITALIZATIONS DISEASE
PROGRESSION THE PREACHER THE
DISABILITY AND THAT THAT'LL
COST MONEY. EXACTLY CURRICULA
BUDGET OFFICE ROUTINELY AT THE
25% OFF SUCH. MEETING THAT IF
YOU INCREASE OUR COPAYS BY A
DOLLAR WE'RE NOT RICH PERSON IT
INCREASES NON MEDICATION COSTS
BY 25% I ADDITIONAL STUDY
SHOWED THAT PATIENTS WITH POOR
MORE CHRONIC CONDITIONS IF YOU
INCREASE WHAT THEY PAY OUT OF
POCKET BY A DOLLAR FOR DRUGS.
IT INCREASES TOTAL SPENDING BY
A DOLLAR EIGHTY THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASES TOTAL COSTS SO THOSE
OFFSET YOUR CRITICAL AND REALLY
UNDERSTANDING OF THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY MOVING
IN A VERY SIMILAR DIRECTION-
THEY'RE ALLOWING MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE PLANS TO ELIMINATE
COST SHARING BUT NOT ONLY JUST
THE DOCTOR BILLS WHICH CARRIED
HIM THIS BILL IS JUST FOCUS ON.
BUT ALSO COPAYS- IN ORDER TO
DEAL WITH CHRONICALLY ILL
PATIENTS TO KEEP THE MOTHER
HOSPITAL'S EMERGENCY ROOMS AND
CLINICS AND SO THE BIG PLANS-
IN IN THE MEDICARE ADVANTAGE
PROGRAM- THE HUMANA'S AND- AT
THE END SO ONE OUR- ARE
BASICALLY ELIMINATING COST
SHARING. UP FOR CHRONICALLY ILL
PATIENTS BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE
THE COST HEARING- BURKE
CHRONICALLY ILL PATIENTS.
REALLY DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE BECAUSE YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE TAKING THEIR
MEDICATIONS KEEPING THEM
HEALTHY. AND KEEPING THEM OUT
OF THE HOSPITAL. SO THIS ISSUE
OF MEDICATION ADHERENCE IS SORT
OF A CENTERPIECE TO WHAT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS TRYING
TO. GET OUT INCREASING OF
MEDICATION ADHERENCE. WE KNOW.
OVER THE OVER THE LONG HAUL
STATES MONEY USE PATIENTS
HEALTHIER. AND KEEPS THEM FROM
ADDITIONAL. ARTICLE CARE THAT
WE CAN PREVENT THIS SO WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY EIGHT. AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE REASONS
FOR THE SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO OUR OUR
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT- WHO'S
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WIDE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SURE LET'S TAKE
FROM PHARMA FOR THE RECORD. SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT ELIMINATES THE
DEDUCTIBLE FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS FOR THOSE PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS AS
IDENTIFIED BY THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL. IN CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS CAN FACE A DEDUCTIBLE
UP TO SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT EVEN A BILL OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR A NEW PRESCRIPTION
DRUG WILL LEAD PATIENTS TO
ABANDON THAT PRESCRIPTION AT
THE PHARMACY COUNTER. 45% OF
THE TIME. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC WHEN A PATIENT IS
NEW TO THEIR PRESCRIPTION
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF TREATING THE
CHRONIC DISEASE EARLY ON WE'RE
WAITING FOR THAT DISEASE TO
MANIFEST IN THAT CAN COST THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. MORE OVER
TIME. THIS BILL WOULD HELP
ADDRESS THAT BARRIER TO MAKE
SURE PATIENTS GOT ACCESS TO
THAT MEDICATION FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR DIAGNOSIS.
THE ORIGINAL BILL WAS ESTIMATED
BY TROOPER TO SAVE CALIFORNIANS
A HUNDRED AND TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR WHILE ONLY
INCREASING COST OF PLANS BY
POINT 12% WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ASKED
FOR AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THIS
BILL- AND CONTROL FOR THE
FISCAL IMPACT PHARMA-
RELUCTANTLY HAS AGREED TO LIMIT
THIS BY- ONLY INCLUDING THE
GROUP MARKET PLACE AND
EXCLUDING THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKETPLACE. IN DOING THAT WE
KNOW IN THE TO BERMAN ALICE'S
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET PLACE IS THE ONE THAT
WOULD HAVE BENEFITED THE MOST
SO WE WOULD WANT TO SEE A STUDY
DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LOOK
AT HOW ADHERENCE IS IMPACTED BY
THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
DEDUCTIBLE. WE ALSO ARE IN
AGREEMENT WITH A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET ON THE BILL THANK YOU
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. NIKOLAY THOSE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS BUT REGRETTABLY
TAKING OPPOSE POSITION ON SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT. BUT WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS THE
WRONG SOLUTION FOR THE GROWING
PROBLEM OF DRUG PRICING- BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND. THE DRUGS USED
TO TREAT CHRONIC CONDITIONS
COMMONLY FALL INTO THE
SPECIALTY DRUG DEFINITION AND
MEANING THEY ARE USED TO TREAT
COMPLEX CONDITIONS AND ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE. THESE ARE OFTEN LIFE
SAVING MEDICATIONS OF MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS RELY ON DAILY.
AND SADLY JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
THE HIGH PRICE DRUG CRISIS WE
DO NOT ADDRESS THIS CRISIS WILL
CONTINUE TO BURDEN OUR HEALTH
SYSTEM AND PUT PATIENTS AT
RISK. HEALTH PLANS ARE DOING
THEIR PART TO PROVIDE VALUE IN
ACCESS TO MINERAL IS BY
COVERING 97% OF THE COST OF
SPECIALTY DRUGS. AND THAT IS AN.
INCREASE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. NO THERE ISN'T. DRUG
PRICE PROBLEM BECAUSE WHAT
SPECIALTY DRUGS ACCOUNT FOR ONE
POINT 5% OF ALL THE
PRESCRIPTIONS. THEY COMPRISE
NEARLY FIFTY SIX POINT 1% OF
ANNUAL SPENDING ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. IN RECOGNITION OF THIS
OVERALL DRUG PRICING PROBLEM
THAT CONTRIBUTES TO THIS
PHENOMENON HEALTH PLANS THAT
SUPPORTED COMMONSENSE
SOLUTIONS. AND IT'S INCLUDES
GREATER TRANSPARENCY LAWS IN
THE FORM OF S. B. SEVENTEEN-
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND
DESPITE LEGAL CHALLENGES ARE
FROM THE MANUFACTURERS AND SOME
COMPLIANCE ISSUES. SB SEVENTEEN
WE STILL BELIEVE IT'S GROUND
BREAKING LAW WHICH IS PROVIDE A
GREAT DEAL OF VALUE TO THE
DEBATE OVER HIGH PRICE DRUGS-
WE ALSO APPLY VIA THIRD EFFORTS
OF THE AUTHOR FROM LAST YEAR.
I'M IN THE FORM OF SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO WHICH WAS INTENDED TO
INCREASE THE PRODUCTION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF MORE GENERIC
DRUGS WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING COMPETITION. THUS
LOWERING PRICES. THOSE ARE
SENSIBLE SOLUTIONS ONE DECADE
AT THE ROOT PROBLEM BOB
REGRETTABLY FIVE SIXTY TAKES
THE OPPOSITE APPROACH AND WILL
NUMBER ONE INCREASE PREMIUMS ON
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES EMPLOYERS
IN YOUR DISTRICTS. INDEED THIS
IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE HERE
MANDY BILL THAT HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR- AND THIS
IS BECAUSE WHILE YOU'RE
REGULATING THE BENEFIT DESIGN
THE DRUG COMPANIES ARE STILL
FREE TO PRICE OUR PRODUCTS
WHERE THEY WANT. AND THIS WOULD
BE AN UNFORTUNATE OUTCOME AS WE
HAVE SEEN A REMARKABLY LOW
PREMIUM INCREASES ARE
PARTICULARLY UP THE COVER
CALIFORNIA LEVEL OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS. SO BILLS LIKE
FIVE SIXTY COULD ALSO FOR OUR
PLAN PRODUCTS OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE RULES
AROUND BENEFIT DESIGN. AND DOES
REQUIRE UP PLANS TO INCREASE
OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER
SERVICES- AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S A FAIR
OUTCOME EITHER- IT IS SECOND
OUTCOME DOES COME TO PASS A
SPONSORS OF SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
OR BILLS LIKE IT- CUMULATIVELY-
THEY SHOULD BE PREPARED TO TELL
POLICYMAKERS WHICH SERVICES
WOULD SEE AN- INCREASE IN OUT
OF POCKET COSTS. TO BE START
THE POLICIES ARE IMPLEMENTED-
SO ELIMINATING THE DEDUCTIBLE
DOES NOTHING TO HELP THE LARGER
PROBLEM BY JUST REQUIRES COSTS
TO BE MADE SOMEWHERE ELSE IN
THE BENEFIT DESIGN. AND SO- YOU
KNOW WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE HE TENDS
TO LIMIT THE BILL- BUT THEY
DON'T ADDRESS THE UNDER. LYING
FLAWS WITH THE APPROACH OF SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT AND THOSE ARE
THE REASONS THAT WE OPPOSE IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. AND
WE HAVE AN- WITNESS OFFICE.
WHENEVER YOU'RE- YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT. WELL THE BILL
IS CERTAINLY WELL INTENTIONED
AND UNFORTUNATELY WILL HAVE
LARGE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN WITH SB
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT OR THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MANDATE THE
STATE PHARMACEUTICAL EQUIPMENT
SUPPLY PRICES REMAINING
UNAFFECTED. WHICH BERMAN HOUSES
WHICH HAS BEEN MENTIONED
SEVERAL TIMES NOW INDICATE THAT
SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
INCREASE PREMIUMS ON EMPLOYERS
BY OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS EMPLOYEES BY
NEARLY FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CRE FOUNDATION FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO PREMIUMS FOR
THE AVERAGE FAMILY HEALTH PLAN
AND THE EMPLOYER MARKET HAVE
INCREASED A HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE PERCENT. BY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY KAISER FAMILY FOUNDATION
OF POOR HEALTH BENEFITS SURVEY
INDICATED THAT THE JOB BASED
COVERAGE THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
PREMIUM FOR FAMILY COVERAGE
210-003-0040 TWO DOLLARS. SB
FIVE SIXTY OR DATABASES COST.
TREND ENACTED THE HEALTHCARE
COSTS RIGHT. YOUR TO THE-
AMOUNT MENTION THE AND NOW.
WITH APPRECIATE THE- COMMITTEE
AND THE STAFF CONSIDERATION.
THEY DO UNFORTUNATELY NOT-
LACK- ME BILITY TO ASSUAGE YOUR
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME SO IN
CLOSING WHILE SB FIVE SIXTY
ADDRESSES AN IMPORTANT ISSUE WE
NEED TO REMAIN COGNIZANT OF THE
IMPACT THAT THESE MANDATE HAVE.
A DRIVING HEALTH CARE COSTS
UPWARDS SO FOR THESE REASONS
PROPOSED SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN JUST
YOUR NAME POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY OPERATOR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE SIX EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO APPETITE.
JERRY CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN IN
Q. WILL START WITH MY NUMBER
THREE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBERS PRICE
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THREE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BRANDON MARCHING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU SURE MEMBERS TO
MADDEN REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIGN OF
THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACCESS
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THREE
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE WORD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER STEPHANIE
WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CHAIR
AND- WELL REPRESENTATIVE MY
NAME IS RANDY WHEN YOU ALSO
THAT YOU KNOW DIABETES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF FIVE SIXTY TWO. AS
IT IS A WITH NO LIMITATIONS AND
NO RESTRICTIONS THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORE TO
GAINWITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THREE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JIMMY JACKSON BY A
COMMA CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND BEFORE YOU OPEN MY THREE
SEVENTY SIX OF THE REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK TO SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. MY THREE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS UNDERGO
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE SHOWING SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS
RODRIGUEZ. IT IS NOT A ADEQUATE
QUESTION I THINK OF FOR ONE OF
THE SUPPORTERS OF THE THING WAS
ACTUALLY I'M SORRY MY APOLOGIES
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS. THANK YOU FOR SAYING
SOMETHING. WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY MY APOLOGIES PLEASE.
MICROPHONE PLEASE. WE GOTTA GET
WE GET YOUR MICROPHONE ON OKAY
TRY AGAIN. THEY CAN'T HEAR
MISTER FRED KNOW WHERE-
REPRESENTING- PHARMACEUTICAL
MANAGEMENT MANUFACTURERS
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THAT THAT FAIR
ENOUGH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY MY APOLOGIES TO
MR NETWORK. MR RODRIGUEZ- NOW
WE- ONE OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WE'VE ACTUALLY SPOKE REGARD
ABOUT A COST SAVINGS OF A JUST
A QUESTION I CAN ASK HER- SHE
YOU TALK OF. WHICH IS USUALLY
SO YEAH. IF YOU HAD A QUESTION
YOU YOU TALK ABOUT THE COST
SAVINGS EARLIER DURING YOUR
TESTIMONY. UNDERSKIRT YOU KNOW
WHAT THE COST SAVINGS WOULD BE
FOR THE STATE OR MAYBE THE
PLANS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION A SHORT LISTED FOR THE
RECORD- IF YOU LOOK A THE
STATE SPECIFIC COSTS. SURE
BURKE- LOOKED AT THAT AND SAID
THAT CALPERS WOULD NOT BE
AFFECTED BECAUSE STATE
EMPLOYEES ALREADY BENEFIT FROM
A ZERO DOLLAR DEDUCTIBLE FOR
PATIENTS- MATIC MEDIKAL WOULD
ALSO NOT BE IMPACTED. AND WITH
OUR AMENDMENTS THAT- EXCHANGE
COVERED CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
EXCLUDED SO THE COST TO THE
STATE WOULD BE MINIMAL IT WOULD
JUST BE DMH. AND DELIGHTS-
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE TO FOR I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AT THE END OF THIS
BILL HAS BEEN INTERESTING AS WE
ALL KNOW AND- I RESPECT- DOCTOR
PAN AND YOUR EFFORTS AND I WAS
IN THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
I AM CURIOUS OR- IS. AS THIS
BILL I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS TO BE
DISCUSSED. AND ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY- IS BUILT
ON ICE AND I GUESS CAN'T WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE A VOTE ON
IT TODAY. GREAT BUT ARE WE
GOING TO DO THAT AT SOME POINT
IS THIS WE CAN MAKE THIS TO
YOUR BILL IS KIND ONE WHERE IS
THE COMMITTEE AT WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BECAUSE I DO THINK
FOR. A LOT OF REASONSOF MY
CONSTITUENCIES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- THAT I. DECIDE IS
WHAT I AM CURIOUS BECAUSE THERE
WAS A LOT OF MOVING PARTS WITH
THIS BILL VERY VERY QUICKLY.
AND I AM JUST YEARS WE GET SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THE CURRENT
STATUS OF WHERE THIS BILLS AT
SO. WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER
THAT- YOU KNOW. LOOK I'M I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR. ON THIS WE HAVE A-
WE HAVE A DISAGREEMENT ABOUT.
THE SCOPE OF AND THE BREADTH OF
THIS BILL- AND- IF. IF WE CAN
AGREE ON SOME GUARD RAILS IN
THE FUTURE- I'M HAPPY. HAPPY TO
DO THAT. THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR
OF A TWO YEAR SESSION- THIS
THIS. DOES NOT NECESSARILY
DEAD. AND THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
TO DO THIS- WE HAVE A VERY. BIG
BIG CHASM HERE VERY VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE HERE- AND SO. I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
HIM IF HE IF HE IF HE CHOOSES
TO DO THAT. AND I OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR
BOTH OF THE CHAIRS OF THIS AND
I THINK THAT- IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT- THIS CONVERSATION
CONTINUES AND I HAVE ABSOLUTE
FAITH THAT WE CAN WORK THIS OUT
I LOOK FORWARD TO SOME POINT
BEING ABLE TO VOTE ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. GIVE ANYONE ELSE.
DAN SEEING THAT NO ONE WOULD
YOU I DO HAVE SOME IDEA OF
COMMENT IN A COUPLE COMMENTS
YOU KNOW WELCOME WHILE THIS
BILL IN D. DOES SEEM INCREASE-
PATIENT ACCESS. TO PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. I'M UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
THE PRO THE APPROACH OF TWO
FIRST DOLLAR FOR ALL CHRONIC
DISEASES I REMEMBER THE CHRONIC
DISEASES SIGN IS DEFINED AS
SOMETHING THAT LASTS MORE THAN
A YEAR. SO THAT'S A LOT OF
DISEASES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ALSO FIFTEEN HUNDRED
MEDICATIONS AS WELL. I'M
CONCERNED WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK. AT THE
RISING COSTS OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND ITS IMPACT ON.
HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
AFFORDABILITY YOU KNOW I HAVE A
STRONG INTEREST IN PORTABILITY-
AND- I JUST I AM VERY CONCERNED
THAT THIS POTENTIALLY- WITHOUT.
REALLY LOOKING AT THE COST OF
DRUGS- IS A ATTENTION A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE SO- WE DISAGREE
OBVIOUSLY ON THIS- WHERE WE ARE
AS OF RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE YOU
KNOW EVERYONE'S A LOSER- I WANT
TO. THEIR TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
A PATHWAY HERE- THE FIVE MOST
COMMON FOR MOST COMMON
DISEASES. POTENTIALLY MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE. SO SO I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU IN THE YOU KNOW
IF YOU LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING- RIGHT DOWN TODAY WE'RE
NOT GONNA TAKE A VOTE ON THE
BILL AND- GIVE YOU HAVE A
CHANGE OF CLOTHES. OKAY THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR WOULD
AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK YOU
KNOW BOTH OF US I THINK WE
SHOULD REMAIN THE SAME THINGS
IN FACT I AM PROUD TO HAVE-
WORK WITH YOU TO GET YOUR BILL
OUT ON GENERIC MEDICATIONS-
THAT- THAT THAT YOU WORKED SO
HARD ON APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY- YEAH I MYSELF OF
AUTHORED- BILLS AS WELL
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THOSE SO I THINK WE BOTH. SHARE
THE CONCERN ABOUT
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS WE BOTH
SHARE A CONCERN ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY AS WELL AND AGAIN
I THINK WE SUPPORTED EACH OTHER
IN IN THAT EFFORT- I THINK WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND I
BEGAN I VERY MUCH WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU. I THINK THIS. IS A
POINTED OUT TO THE- TRYING TO
PICK WHICH DOES. ALL RIGHTS OF
THEIR DIFFERENT WAYS WE CAN
LIMIT BACK THAT'S WHY IN FACT I
WAS- LORD WILLING TO ACCEPT
EVEN THOUGH. YOU KNOW SOME
SPONSOR SAID RELUCTANTLY BUT I
WAS WILLING TO SAY OKAY LET'S
DO THE GROUP MARKET BECAUSE
AFTER ALL AS I POINTED OUT.
INDIVIDUAL MARKET. EVEN THOSE
HIGH DEDUCTIBLE PLANS YOU HAVE
A CHOICE ANOTHER PLAN RIGHT YOU
COULD YOU DON'T HAVE TO BUY THE
BROWN'S THANK YOU DESERVE IT
AND WE SHOULD DO IN EDUCATION-
EFFORT. WITH THEM RIGHT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE CHOICES. THE
CHALLENGES OF YOUR GROUP PLAN
AND YOU HAVE A CHOICE THEN THEN
YOUR STOCK RIGHT. IN FACT
ACTUALLY MOST GROUP PLANS
ACTUALLY DON'T PROVIDE
ADOPTABLE EFFECT YOU JUST HEARD
CALPERS DOESN'T BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IT DOESN'T REALLY MAKE
SENSE- IT'S- THAT IT'S NOT A
REALLY EFFECTIVE WAY TO CONTROL
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
STATEMENT ABOUT. YELP REDUCING
FARMERS NO COST. BUT AGAIN. THE
DEDUCTIBLE AND AGAIN WE DON'T
LIMIT TE COPAY THE DEDUCTIBLE
ITSELF I REALLY A BARRIER TO
PEOPLE AGAIN WITH CHRONIC
DISEASES. IN TERMS OF GETTING
MOVED FORWARD. SO I'M VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT WE
CAN TRY TO TALK ABOUT MAYBE
VALUE AND SO FORTH BUT I. I DO
THINK IT'S CHALLENGING TO SAY.
I HAVE TO TAKE IT JUST FROM A
GROUP OF DISEASES- BECAUSE YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WITH RARE
CONDITIONS WHO DEFINITELY STILL
NEEDED TO HAVE THEIR FACING THE
SAME PROBLEM. AS SOMEONE LET'S
SAY WITH DIABETES OR HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE OR SOMETHING THAT'S
MUCH MORE COMMON. AND SO. I YOU
KNOW AND AGAIN I SAID THE
HEALTH PLANS HAVE TOLD ME THEY
DON'T DO THE DISEASE BY THESE
APPROACH EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THE
SPONSORS DON'T WANT TO DO IT
THAT WAY. I'M NOT SURE IT'S
GOOD POLICY SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
IF YOU HAVE A CERTAIN DISEASE.
YOU'RE OKAY WE DON'T THAT'S NOT
IT WE'RE GOING TO GET A LOT OF
DETECTABLE BUT YOU HAVE THAT
OTHER DISEASE WHICH ALSO HAS
THE SAME CHARACTERISTICS DOES
CRIME THIS CITY AND IT'S NEAT.
YOUR NEED TO CONTINUE. SO
PERHAPS AGAIN I LOOK FOR TO
DIALOGUE YOU KNOW MAYBE WE CAN
LOOK AT VALUE LIKE OKAY IS THE
DRUG HOW HELPFUL IS THE DRUG TO
PREVENT YOU FROM. ENDING UP IN
THE HOSPITAL E. ARE. ALL RIGHT
AND I THINK THERE'S OTHER
EFFORTS THAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER
WHICH I KNOW WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THE OVERALL
COST OF THE DRUG. RIGHT TO TRY
TO BRING THAT DOWN- DIFFERENT
TYPES OF POLICIES- BUT- I DO
THINK THAT AND I HOPE WHAT I
LOOK FOR TO AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE. THAT TRYING TO PICK.
WHICH DISEASE AND I UNDERSTAND
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM IN
TERMS OF SAYING WELL THAT'S ONE
WAY TO NARROW DRUG BUT I THINK
I THINK THAT. THAT CREATES A
LOT OF CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
WHY THIS DISEASE VERSES THAT IS
IT MORE BECAUSE IT'S MORE
COMMON THERE FOR YOUR TICKET.
YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT THIS HE'S
LIKE SICKLE CELL THE MAINLY
AFFECTS THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION AND. WE MENTIONED
EACH OF YOU WILL HAVE THE OF
CANCER. OTHER YOUNG VICE GIVE A
RARE. NEAR LA. THE WHY IS IT SO
NOW. FOR YOU. PURSES A LOT NOW
YOU SAY THE DRUG ITSELF IS NOT
AS EFFECTIVE OR DOESN'T HAVE
IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
CONVERSATION BUT I THINK IF
IT'S IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
GONNA KEEP YOU HEALTHY. WHY DO
WE PUT YOU KNOW AND TO KEEP YOU
OUT OF HOSPITAL AND- ALLOW YOU
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A REASONABLE
QUALITY OF LIFE WE CAN GET YOU
TO GO TO WORK AND HAVE THESE
VALLEY. THEN THE QUESTION IS
WHY DO WE WANT HIGHER
DEDUCTIBLE. AS A SORT OF THIS
ROAD BOND TO YOU BE ABLE TO GET
THE MEDICATION AGAIN WE DON'T
ELIMINATE COPAYS. SO I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK I LOOK FOR CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD I KNOW YOU'RE YOU
YOU AND YOUR CAT CAN YOU STAFF
BRING A LOT OF EXPERTISE AS
WELL. AND WE WON'T HAVE THAT
DIALOGUE ABOUT WHAT WE CAN TRY
TO DO THE MOVE- THE- YOUNG.
AFFECTED POLICY FOR SO THAT WE
CAN BE SURE PEOPLE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS. HAVE AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE AND LIKE YOU SAID
YOU AND I THINK AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
AFFORDABILITY. WE WANT PEOPLE
HAVE AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE. SO
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO NOT
ONLY LEAD. DEL GOOD LIVES BUT
ALSO. THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR SOCIETY AS
WELL IN A POSITIVE WAY SO WITH
THAT. AGAIN APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I HOPE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO AN
OPPORTUNITY PERHAPS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE CAN TAKE A VOTE THE
SPOKEN BEFORE AND I CERTAINLY
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS THE HOPEFULLY
MAYBE WE CAN COME TO SOME
AGREEMENT SOMEWHERE. TO FIT THE
BILL IN THE- IN IN THE RIGHT
FRAME SO WE CAN. TRY TO MOVE
THIS POLICY FORWARD. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TALKED HIM. WITH THAT
WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
ITEM OUR NEXT PRESENTER.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HERE IN PRESENTING SB SIX
FIFTY TWO ALL TODAY. THIS IS
THE CORPORATE TRANSPARENCY IN
ELDER CARE ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND LOOK AT THE END OF LIFE
WHICH OFTEN WE DON'T LIKE TO
THINK ABOUT IN IN OUR LINE OF
WORK BUT WE ALL TO GET OLD. AND
SOMEOF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
MEMBERS HER PARENTS OR LOVED.
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY- SAYS
TRUE IN MY FAMILY I'M SURE IS
TRUE IN MANY OF YOURS. END UP
LIVING IN NURSING HOMES AND THE
NATURE OF THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THE WAY WE STRUCTURED IT- THE
BULK OF THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED. BY FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES. OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE DISCOVERED THROUGH
BOTH INVESTIGATIVE
INVESTIGATIONS FROM JOURNALISTS
AND I'M SOME PUBLIC AUDITS HOW
SOME OF THE FOR PROFIT NURSING
HOMES ARE USING COMPLEX
OWNERSHIP STRUCTURES. TO SAFE
AN UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNTS OF
FUNDING TO RELATED PARTIES.
TRANSACTIONS BETWEEN- CORPORATE
ENTITIES ALLOWING CORPORATE
HOME OFFICES TO HIDE THEIR
PROFITS IN SUPPORT FACILITIES
CLAIMS FOR YET MORE PUBLIC
MONEY WHEN INVESTING- OVER A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
MEDICARE SYSTEM THIS YEAR. AND
MUCH OF THAT WILL BE FUNDING
OUR ELDER CARE AND OUR CARICOM
TO ME BUT- THIS BILL IS REALLY
INTENDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
MONEY IS GOING WHERE WE SAY
IT'S GOING. ALLEN THAT IT'S
REACHING PEOPLE IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. WHETHER
IT'S THE CARE WORKERS PUTTING
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO TAKE
CARE OF PEOPLE WE LOVE. OR THE
PEOPLE WE LOVE THEMSELVES TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
SHORT SHRIFT. OR SOMEHOW A
LANGUISHING. WITHOUT A PROPER
RESOURCES WELL- THE FOLKS WHO
OWN THE CORPORATIONS ARE
RUNNING OFF WITH. WITH PROFITS
THANKS TO TRICKY ACCOUNTING
TECHNIQUES- WE THINK THAT. THIS
BILL WILL HOPEFULLY PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY-
THROUGH THE REVIEW AND AUDIT
PROVISIONS IN THE LEGISLATION
NOW AND I WANT TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHAIR AND THEIR
STAFF. AS WELL AS- THE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE HEALTH WHO WAS JUST
HERE PRESENTING WITH YOU FOR
THEIR- THEIR STAFF ASSISTANCE
AND FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE- AS
WELL AS THE- ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES FOR THEIR
PATIENTS IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS.
I WANT TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
NOTED ON PAGES NINE AND TEN. AT
TO REQUIRE THE CONSOLIDATED
FINANCIAL GROUP THE
CONSOLIDATED FINANCIAL PORTS TO
BE REVIEWED BY A CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT. LET'S THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
COMPLETING AN AUTO COMPLETING
AN AUDIT ALREADY. FOR ANY
REASON IN WHICH CASE- THEY'LL
BE DOING MORE THAN JUST A
REVIEW- AND JUST TO REMIND YOU
THAT ALL THESE REVIEWS WOULD
BE. PUBLIC THE CORPORATE
OWNERSHIP STRUCTUR WILL ALSO
BE DISCLOSED ASHTEAD AND WE'RE
IN CONSULTATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW W
HAVE A MEETING SCHEDULED WITH
THE- WITH THE DIRECTOR WE KNOW
THEY'VE GOT A LOT ON THEIR
PLATE AND IN FACT THEY'RE-
THEY'RE CURRENTLY LOOKING AT
THE PROFIT AND LOSS STATEMENT.
PURSUANT TO A IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION FROM THE CHAIR-
BUT WE THINK THIS IS
LEGISLATION CANNOT AFFORD TO
WAIT. I EVEN WHILE THAT WORK IS
WITH IS UNDER WAY WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL YIELD SOME
IMPORTANT DATA- THE KIND OF
FINANCIAL DATA THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR HERE ABOUT THE
NATURE OF RELATED PARTIES-
COMES AT A TIME OF
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT. AND
NEW REVELATIONS ABOUT-
SOMEBODY'S CORPORATE STRUCTURES
AND WAITING ANOTHER FEW YEARS
TO GET THIS INFORMATION COULD
RESULT IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITH THE BE- OF LOSSES- TO
TAXPAYERS- TO. TO THOSE WHO WE
CARE FOR AND TO THOSE WHO CARE
FOR THEM. I WANT TO THANK OUR
SPONSORS THIS YEAR YOU
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM AS WELL AS A. R. P. FOR
THEIR SUPPORT- AND I THINK WE
HAVE- SOME RELIEF WITNESSES ON
THE LINE RIGHT NOW. BOTH THE
CANNER AN SEIU A TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR STERN WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES FOR OUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
AND- WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU TO CHAIRPERSON
WOODEN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. MY NAME
IS TONY YOU COULD TELL I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY FOR CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM WELL SO CALLED SKINNER.
TODAY I AM ALSO REPRESENTING
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SENATOR
STERN CANNER YEAH YOU A. R. P.
AND MANY OTHERS ARE TRYING TO
TURN ARE AWFUL TWENTY TWENTY
INTO INSPIRATION FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. SB SIX FIFTY IS A
BIG PIECE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE PROTECT PLAN A PACKAGE OF
BILLS AIMING TO REPAIR
BREAKDOWNS. IN LONG TERM CARE-
EXPOSED BY THE PANDEMIC IN
CHURCH TO TRY TO PROTECT THE
CITY RESIDENTS FROM. FROM
HARMONY WILL BY POOR PUBLIC
POLICY. SB SIX FIFTY ADDRESSES.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
INVESTING NURSING HOME. THIS IS
TO THEMSELVES. THE MONEY MOVED
TO RELATED PARTIES IS DIVERTED
FROM RESIDENT CARE. HIDING
PROFITS ENABLE THE INDUSTRY TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY FEW YEARS SIMPLY
PERSONALLY ASK FOR MORE MONEY.
INDUSTRY CAPITALIZES ON AN
ASYMMETRY OF INFORMATION THE
NURSING HOMES NO THEIR COSTS
IMPROPER IN THE STATE DOESN'T.
THIS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
RESULT IN THE STATE BEING
RIPPED OFF THANK FOR PRIVATE
JETS IN VACATION HOMES FOR
NURSING HOMEOWNERS INSTEAD OF
FOR THE STAFF AND RESOURCES
CRITICAL TO RESIDENT WELL BEING.
OUR REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM LACKS
MEANINGFUL DISCLOSURE OF
NURSING HOME EXPENDITURES AND
THIS ENABLES GREED AND
DECEPTION. SB SIX FIFTY
REQUIRES NURSING HOMES TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE RELATED PARTY FINANCES
MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
HIDE THEIR PROFITS WHILE GIVING
CALIFORNIA MORE CONTROL TO
SUPPORT RESIDENT CARE. OUR
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS ARE
ISOLATED FRUSTRATED ANGRY EVEN
KNOWS WHO DIED THEY DESPERATELY
NEED A MORE TRANSPARENT AND
SENSIBLE REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM.
PLEASE VOTE YES SEVEN SIX FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. YOUR JOURNEY MEMBERS
FIFTEEN RIGHT NOW LOOK AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND NURSING
HOME EMPLOYEES BUT CONSEQUENCES
OF THAT THE FIFTY FIFTY
INTERNET DALY THANK AND
APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. I'M GOING TO
TAKE YOU MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR
STAFF BUT THE MANY
CONVERSATIONS BUDGET CONCERNS
TO THE BILL AND ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ANY
UNDERSTOOD SURE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND NURSING
HOME. THE COSBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AT THIS AGE HAVE
EXPOSED LONGSTANDING ARSENAL
PRACTICES THAT HAVE CREATED AN
ANIMATED QUOTABLE PROFIT DRIVEN
INDUSTRY SACRIFICES THE SAFETY-AND LIVELIHOOD OF WORKER AND
THE QUALITY OF CARE FOR
RESIDENTS. CHRONIC
UNDERSTAFFING LACK OF
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AND
LOOPHOLES IN THE SYSTEM
APALUTAMIDE AMERICAN HOME
INDUSTRY WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
SEEKING IMPLEMENT REFORMS THAT
WILL MOVE OUR STATE NURSING
HOMES GET THEM TOWARDS ONE
MEDICAL QUALITY CARE CORPORATE
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. I THINK THE
FIFTY AND TO BRING TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO
BILLIONAIRE NURSING HOME OWNERS
WHO HAVE CALLED RICHARD BY
PROFITING FROM MY NETWORK
INTERNALLY TO CORPORATIONS THAT
EXTRACT PROFIT AT EVERY LEVEL
RATHER. THAN INVESTING IN
PATIENT CARE. TWENTY SEVEN
KINDER NEWS. FOUND THAT NURSING
THE BILL WHICH CONTRACT RELATED
PARTY ACTING KNOWS THE EIGHT
PAGE. THEY HAVE RATES OF
PATIENT INJURY AND PRACTICE
THANK AND THEIR THE SUBJECT OF
COMPLAIN ALMOST AS OFTEN AS A-
HOME. FACILITY OWNER HAVE USED.
OWNERSHIP TO OUR THE SHIP
OPERATION CONTROL. LIMIT ME
EXPERTS AND CRY. TO THE LADY
OVER. BETTING LIKE. ACCORDING
TO ASK BETTER TWENTY NINETEEN
THERE WAS OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS BUT- AND SELF REPORTED
RELATED PARTY TRANSACTIONS AND
ABOUT 99% OF THE PORT RELATED
PARTY TRANSACTIONS WILL
REIMBURSABLE. I THINK THAT
FIFTY IS ABOUT ENSURING QUALITY
RESIDENT CARE BY PROVIDING
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
I NEED TO CANCEL THE INDUSTRY
FROM FROM PROFIT CENTERS TO
TRUE CARE CENTERS. OUR MEMBERS
KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT IT'S LIKE
pTO NOT KNOW WHO THE OWNER IS
NORMALLY. GOING BUT WHAT THEY
DO KNOW IS THAT IT'S NOT GOING
TO WORKERS AND RESIDENTS.
DOUBLE FORMS OF SB FIFTY FIFTY
WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO THE NURSING
HOME INDUSTRY AND SHOW THAT
PUBLIC FUNDING FOR MEDICAID AND
MEDICARE. ARE DIRECTED TOWARDS
THE QUALITY OF CARE PROVIDED
FOR RESIDENTS AND TO AND TO
PROTECT THE LOWEST POINT TO
OTHER THAN PRACTICE. AND
PRACTICAL THE NINETEEN- NURSING
HOME RESIDENTS AND WORKERS HAD
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE ISSUES
THAT ARE ROOTED IN THE INDUSTRY
CAN NO LONGER BE IGNORED. OUR
STATE IS IN DIRE NEED OF
TRANSFORMING NURSING HOMES NOT
NURSING HOMES FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY APPARENTLY THE
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA'S AND THE
WORKERS WHO DEDICATE THEIR
LIVES. FOR CAREGIVING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. I THOUGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
THE GALLERY. IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. HI GET OUT MR COMMITTEE
MEMBER SENT SEITER BEHALF OF.
ASSOCIATION HELL FACILITY WE
HAVE A OPPOSED SOME POSITION.
ON THE BILL I RE CAN HAD TO DO
WITH. PUBLIC ACCOUNT AUDIT THAT
WERE RECENTLY. INTO THE BILL.
BUT. WE LOST OUR MICROPHONE
THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GREAT PROJECTION OF YOUR VOICE.
CHAPTER CHALLENGING CONDITION
THERE THANK YOU. MUCH
APPRECIATED WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR- TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME- POSITION ON THE BILL
AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU READ
REPRESENT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE PHONE LINES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FIFTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
B. WE CURRENTLY HAVE THREE IN
CUBA START WITH LINE NUMBER TWO
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHELSEA
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT
PLEASE FINALLY GETTING TO DEAL
WITH THEM. ANNEX TO OPEN MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YUP THIS IS ART
PERSICO SAM'S IS THE GRAY
PANTHERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHY NUMBER
FOUR OH TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI JOSH IT TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT ASSOCIATION OUR
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX IF. TWO TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS CITY WHEREVER THEY'RE
PRESENTING CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RETIRED AMERICANS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS T. SIX FIVE ZERO. EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS- WE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THE
DRAIN HELEN OF EAST BAY GREAT
CHARACTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AND FOUR OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MICHAEL LINE
CONTINUE DISABILITY INACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR ONE HEALTH OKAY. LOOK FOR A
WIN PLEASE MEET YOUR LINE. FOR
A WHEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MELANIE TAYLOR STARK. MITCHELL
CARE GIVERS COALITION AND
WRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE FIFTY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BEFORE WE OPEN LINE FOR- THREE
ENTERING MY RELATED TO GENERAL
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION SB SIX FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS WANTED ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
MYRON WALDEN. LONG BEACH WAIT
TEN DAYS WE ARE FIRMLY IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIX FIFTY. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO INSURANCE
SUPPORTER IN OUR IN OPPOSITION
WELL THANK YOU BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING- WORKING WITH US ON THE
BILL- YOU YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS BUT FOR
WHICH I APPRECIATE. THE BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MR FROM DOCTOR REGULAR. A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE CENTER. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE. OPEN
THE ROLL CALL MEMBERS. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD HI WHAT I
MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NOT VOTING BURKE. CARRILLO.
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. THIS AREA
NAZARIAN I REQUEST RIVAS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I WALDRON. NINE ZERO
BIGGER MUCH YOUR BILL IS OUT
MUCH APPRECIATED BEFORE WE
MOVED TO OUR FINAL PRESENTATION
I THINK THE ARE YOU PRINT YOUR
PRESENT IN THE BILL RECIVED FOR
DO THAT- I WAS GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
THREE NINETY FIVE- ASKED-
SEGMENT SIX THREE PLEASE- CALL
THAT THE CALL AND CALL THE
MEMBERS ON. SB THREE NINETY
FIVE. BURKE BURKE I FLORA LARA
I MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY
I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. TO LIVE IN
A TWO. THE BUDGET NO I CAN'T DO
THE OTHER ONES I GOT I WAS A
DAY OF A DIFFERENT REFERENCE TO
THE- MISTER THEIR INTENT SO I'M
SORRY- MISTER SUNDAY WE HAVE
ONE BILL LEFT MR SANTIAGO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YOU HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I AM VERY
CLEAR MISTER CHAIR AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ON SB ELEVEN TEN THE
RECOVERY AND SENT A FAX- GIVE.
WHICH IS A HARM REDUCTION
PUBLIC HEALTH BILL THAT WOULD
SIMPLY. REQUIRE THE CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT INTERVENTIONS TO
REMEMBER TO BE REIMBURSED BY
MEDICAL KNOWING THE COMMITTEE'S
INTEREST IN THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I WILL BE BRIEF ON MY
PRESENTATION AS WELL THE TWO
WITNESSES. MR TIRE TYRONE
CLIFFORD AND MR STEVE SHEPTOFF.
THANK MISTER CARE THANK YOU AND
I ACTUALLY AT ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IS NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY SO WE DO HAVE- A SKI
SHOP CAR- ON THE PHONE- PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR- STEVE.
SHOPTALK. I WONDER OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DR STEVE SHOPTALK I AM-
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED SCIENTIST
AND CLINICIAN- I DEVELOP
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENTS FOR
ADDICTION PARTICULAR TREATMENT
FOR STIMULANT USE DISORDER BOTH
COCAINE AND METHAMPHETAMINE.
MUCH OF THE WORK ON CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT'S BEEN DONE BY
CALIFORNIA SCIENTISTS AND
CLINICIANS WITH THE SPECIALLY
MEANINGFUL THAT SENATOR WARREN
WIENER AND COLLEAGUES. ARE
COMMITTED TO BRINGING THIS
POTENTIAL TREATMENT TO
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
ADDICTION TO STIMULANTS. BUT
CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT IS IT
THE PROSPERITY DEVELOPMENT
THIRTY YEARS OF SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH. IT PROVIDES
INCENTIVES THAT INCREASE IN
VALUE IN EXCHANGE FOR
BIOLOGICAL SAMPLES EITHER URINE
OR SALIVA TO DOCUMENT DRUG
ABSTINENCE. THE INCENTIVES
INCREASE EACH TIME PATIENTS
PROVIDE CONSECUTIVE SCHEDULED
SAMPLES THAT TEST NEGATIVE FOR
STIMULANTS. THE KEY ADVANTAGE
OF THIS THERAPY IS ITS RESPECT
FOR PEOPLE IT WORKS BY SIMPLY
LETTING POPLE TAILOR THEIR
LIVES SO THAT ENGAGE FORTY
EIGHT TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
DOING THINGS OTHER THAN USING
STIMULANTS LIKE METHAMPHETAMINE
WHICH ESSENTIALLY CREATES
INDIVIDUALLY TAILORED
TREATMENTS TO ACCOMPLISH THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING STIMULANT
FREE SAMPLES AND A DRUG FREE
LIFE. WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT TWENTY
MANAGE IT IS THE MOST POWERFUL
TREATMENT FOR STIMULANT USE
DISORDER FULL STOP. IT IS A FAR
STRONGER THERAPY AND COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY- MOTIVATIONAL
INTERVIEWING APPROACHES
COMMONLY DELIVERING GOOD
TREATMENT PROGRAM. IT CAN BE
COMBINED WITH OTHER THERAPIES
INCLUDING MEDICATION TREATMENT.
AND DISTRICT INCREASE THE POWER
OF THE THIRTIETH OVERALL. COULD
YOU JUST IMAGINE TO THINK ABOUT
IT WE ARE THE WORLD GIVE THE
TREATMENT WHETHER SOUTH
FRANCISCO. HM HANOI I COOPER
TALKS OF THAT WORK. IN OUR
HUNDRED OF STUDIES HAVE BEEN
MANAGEMENT SHOW THAT THE FIVE
THREE AFFECT CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS IN THE SAME RANGE
OF EFFECTIVE ANTIBIOTIC USED TO
TREAT INFECTIONS. BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT CONTINGENCY MANAGEMENT
WERE A MEDICATION IT WOULD. BE
STANDARD OF CARE FOR TREATING
ADDICTION. WHAT IT IS WHAT IT
IS NOW SINCE PAYING PEOPLE TO
WHAT THEY DO IN. REAL SALT SHOW
THAT THE EFFECTS OF THE THERAPY
DUE TO BRING CHANGES WHEN
DELIVERING CONTINGENCY
MANAGEMENT. IT'S NOT A MAGIC
BULLET WITH THE STATE WELL IT'S
A POWERFUL THERAPY LIKE ALL
MEDICATIONS IT DOES NOT WORK IF
IT'S NOT TAKEN. I DON'T THE
POWERFUL TREATMENT IT IS NOT A
CURE ABOUT THE ENEMY OR OTHER
ADDICTION ADDICTION IS A
CHRONIC RELAPSING CONDITION AND
MULTIPLE TREATMENTS ARE OFTEN
REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE. THE STATE
AFTER THAT. OR CALL THE SAME
EXCITED ABOU THE REAL
POTENTIAL TO BRING THIS
POWERFUL THERAPY THE CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS LIVING WITH ADDICTION
TO METHAMPHETAMINE AND OTHER
DRUGS. REDEFINES PLEASE BE
ONLINE BRINGS REAL HOPE AND
HELP FOR CALIFORNIANS.
ADDICTION WHO WANT TO GET THEIR
LIVES BACK. WHICH IS THE MAIN
REASON PEOPLE ENTER DRUG
TREATMENT. MAKE A REALITY WE
NEED THE SYSTEM TO CHANGE SB
ONE TENTH DOES NOT ANNOUNCE
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO READ AND
TO MAKE THAT SYSTEM CHANGE.
THANKS FOR LETTING ME SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PHONE THERE'S NO
REGISTERED- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES. FOR READ WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME POSITION AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OPERATOR
AN OPEN ALLIANCE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE TEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT NINETEEN
Q. ABOUT WITH MY NUMBER TWO OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TWENTY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIANS BY BE
AFFECTED BY THE AMERICAN
SPECIAL UP IN EVIDENCE STREET
NOT IMPORTANT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF PEAR THERAPEUTICS
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FOUR OH SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
TOMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. TWO THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
CUTTING OFF AND ON BEHALF OF
APLE HELD SO WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. TWO THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
MCMILLAN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SAN MATEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THREE EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DIMITRIUS
THE WORD NATIONALIZATION OF
THOSE WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
TWO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YODER ME HALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BEFORE WE
OPEN ONE THREE NINETY FIVE AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THREE NINETY
FIVE RELATED OPEN. FINDING BILL
ME HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES AND ALL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU- NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE AND
YOU VERY WELL THANK OU VERY
MUCH OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NO ONE WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER FLORES
SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ SAID DUE
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
RECOMMENDATION WHICH I TO CLOSE
MR SANTIAGO- THANK YOU MISTER
RESPECTFULLY WOULD OFTEN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT HI BUT I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. THIS AREA. RIVAS RIVAS
I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO HI SANTIAGO AYE
WALDRON. TEN ZERO TEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS WALDRON I LIVE IN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL THAT BILLS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MR
SANTIAGO. THANK INCLUDES ALL
THE PRESENTATIONS OF THE BILLS
AT THIS POINT WILL GO TO THE-
SO THE TOP OF THE ORDER HERE
AND- AND- CALL A CALL GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE ENTIRE RUN
HERE SO. ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
THREE NINETY FIVE- BY SENATOR
CAFIERO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
TWELVE TO TWELVE TO- ITEM
NUMBER AT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF ITEMS NUMBER TWO SB
FOUR OH TWO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
THREE TWENTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB SIX EIGHTY TO PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAYES ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I BURKE BURKE AYE
FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MCCARTY. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER THREE PLEASE- SB EIGHTY
BY SENATOR REQUIRE PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI.
FLORA. FLUORIDE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE FIFTEEN ZERO
FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. TWO FORTY TWO
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL BY SNATOR
NEWMAN PLEASE LET THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I.
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON OF VOTING. IT'S NINE
ONE QUEUE ITEM ITEM NUMBER
FIVE- SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN PLEASE WITH THE
CALLING CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I
BURKE BURKE AYE FLORA. FLORA
NOTE MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY. THIS AREA.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. NINE EIGHT
THREE NINE THREE NINE THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN- PLEASE- WHICH IS SB FIVE
TEN BY SENATOR PAN PLEASE WITH
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
I. FLORA FLORIDA NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON NO. TEN THREE THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER- NINE- SB THREE TEN
BY SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAYES AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I THINK ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. FLORA.
LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
THINK YOU ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN-
S. ZERO ZERO I'M SORRY. JUMP
THE GUN NINETY PART MY
APOLOGIES- ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
S. C. R. ELEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE FLORA
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I RIVAS. RIVAS I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU- I ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
SIX FIFTY SENATOR STERN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES. BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE WALDRON WALDRON I. TWELVE
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. ONE TEN SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE OPEN ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
CARILLO MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
STILL LEVIN IS ZERO OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN- SB FIVE
NINETEEN BY SENATOR WIENER
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT AGAIN AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I. FLORA FLORA NO.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. EIGHT TWO
FOUR THE BILL'S OUT THANK YOU.
WE WILL WAIT FOR. THAT IS ALL
THAT ARE ALL OF THIS ALL THE
ITEMS WILL WAIT FOR A FEW
MINUTES HERE FOR A COUPLE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES TO RETURN. SO
THANK YOU.
I THINK THE FOR.
PART OF THE.
THE PROBLEMS THAT
I DID NOT. CAN HAVE A BIG.
THE
SYSTEM. HERE. ALL LONGER. THANK
YOU.
YEAH. OKAY.
YEAH YEAH.
WHAT IS THAT IT IS A WONDERFUL.
OKAY. THIS BILL OKAY ALL RIGHT.
MY GOODNESS SORRY NO THAT'S
OKAY. OKAY SO- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. MAYES. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE THANK YOU
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU- FIVE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB THREE TEN
CENTER RUBIO PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES. BIGELOW NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU AND THEN- ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB ONE TEN BY SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES
CARILLO MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE TWELVE ZERO. THANK
YOU YEAH. SO WHERE YOU LEFT.
YEAH RIGHT OKAY. MADAM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. TWO FORTY TWO
CARILLO. I MCCARTY. TEN ONE
THANK YOU M. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
SB SIX FIFTY BY SENATOR STERN.
MAYES CARILLO CARILLO I. ZERO
THANK YOU AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN SB ONE TEN BY SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE CLICK OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES. CARILLO CARILLO I. S. B.
ONE TEN. NOT VOTING SB ONE TEN
CARILLO NOT VOTING. YOU'RE
THINKING ARE YOU THINKING. WANT
SB ONE TEN- WIENER- THIS
CARILLO HI. SB ONE TEN CARILLO
HI. THANK YOU MCCARTY. THIRTEEN
ZERO OKAY THANK YOU.
MMHM. FIRE
OR NOT- YOUR LEADER ONE
LICENSES A FIRE THERE WAS NO
OPPOSITION I WANT ONE OF THOSE.
THE THANKS FOR- KIDDING. OKAY
EVERYTHING.
TWENTY TWO. OKAY
HERE WE GO. SO- MEN SECRETARY.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS S. B. TWO FORTY
TWO BY CENTER NEWMAN. SORRY WE
GET THE NUMBER OF THE- MAYES.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I LIVE IN THE
ONE I'M SORRY ELEVEN YEAH I
LIVE IN A ONE- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN BY CENTER
NEWMAN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY HI ELEVEN A
THREE THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE TEN BY CENTER PAN
PLEASE OPEN ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES. MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI ELEVEN A THREE THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB ONE
TEN BY SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAY HAVE. MCCARTY AYE
MCCARTY AYE FOURTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU AND FINALLY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- ITEM NUMBER TWO SIX
TEN SB FOUR OH TWO SB THREE
TWENTY SIX SB SIX EIGHTY TO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES. MCCARTY
AYE MCCARTY AYE FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT'S IT AND WITH THAT THE S.
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IS INJURED.